hello everyone and welcome to this full
course video on keras and tensorflow by
simply loan
tensorflow and keras are two of the most
widely used popular python libraries for
building machine learning and deep
learning models
our highly experienced instructors will
take you through this course
now let's look at the agenda for today's
video tutorial so we'll first learn the
basics of tensorflow and then look at
what is tensorflow
moving forward
we will learn about how the tensorflow
works with the help of data flow
diagrams
then we'll explore about tensorflow 2.0
tutorial and we'll see the difference
between tensorflow 1.0 and tensorflow
2.0
after that we're going to see two
hands-on
demos on tensorflow object detection api
after learning about tensorflow we'll
look at the basics of keras and then
we'll do a hands-on demonstration using
the keras library and solve
a data science problem
next we are going to learn about the
keras sequential model and finally we'll
explore the keras image classification
model
so let's get started
hello and welcome to the session on what
is tensorflow today we're going to see
what is deep learning very briefly and
then we will talk about what are the
various libraries that are available for
developing deep learning applications
and then we will focus on tensorflow and
what are the various advantages why we
should use tensorflow what is tensorflow
and then we will talk about what are
tensors which are as the name suggests
tensorflow consists of tensors and then
they are executed in a certain graphical
format of flow like a graph and that's
why it is named as such tensorflow and
we will see how to write programs in
tensorflow the programming language of
course will be python but there is a
certain way in which you write deep
learning application or a program in
tensorflow so we will take a look at
that this is a basic introductory
session for beginners and then we will
see one implementation of tensorflow
code one full end to end and that's
pretty much it what you can expect from
this quickly wanted to mention that
there are certain prerequisites before
you actually go through this the
expectation is that you at least have
some idea about some programming
language and preferably python if you
know python absolutely it will be much
easier to understand the code as such
but even if you know any other
programming language i think
it will be okay and you will at least be
able to understand the python code in
addition to that this also involves
especially the case study you will or
the case implementation you will be able
to understand only if you have some idea
about machine learning so in case you
are very new to machine learning and
python everything then it may be a good
idea to check other tutorials that we
have uploaded on let's say about python
and also about machine learning so that
you get a basic understanding and then
come back here otherwise it may be very
difficult to understand this tutorial
all right so having said that let's get
started so what is deep learning again
this video is not about deep learning
but there are other videos we have
created in detail about what is deep
learning in this video we'll just touch
upon the basics so that that's like a
nice segue into tensorflow so deep
learning is um in a way a subset of
machine learning and we use uh primarily
neural networks in deep learning and the
underlying technology behind artificial
intelligence is deep learning and here
we teach them how to recognize let's say
images or voice and so on and so forth
so it is a learning mechanism but here
unlike traditional machine learning the
data is far more complicated and far
more unstructured like it could be
primarily in the form of images or audio
files or text files and one of the core
components of deep learning is neural
network and a neural network somewhat
looks like this there is something known
as an input layer and then there is an
output layer and in between there are a
bunch of hidden layers so typically
there would be at least one hidden layer
and anything more than one hidden layer
is known as a deep neural network so any
neural network with more than three
layers altogether right is known as a
deep neural network all right so what
are the functions of the various layers
let's take a quick look so the input
layer accepts the input so this could be
in the form of let's say if it is an
image it could be the pixel values of
the images so that's what the input
layer does and then it passes on to the
hidden layers and the hidden layers in
turn perform certain computations and
they have what is known as as a part of
the training they have these weights and
biases that they keep updating till the
training process is complete and each
neuron has multiple weights and there
will be one bias and these are like
variables and we will see when we go
into the tensorflow code what we
actually mean by that and so that's what
the hidden layer does it
does a bunch of computation and passes
its values to the output layer and then
the output layer in turn gives the
output it could be in the form of a
class so for example if we are doing
classification it tells us which class a
particular image maybe belongs to for
example let's say if this is a image
classification application then the
input could be a bunch of images of
maybe cats and dogs and the output will
be like it will say okay if this is
activated this gives a zero and this
gives a one that means it is a cat if
this gives a one and this gives a zero
that means it is a dot so that is a kind
of a binary classification and that can
be extended with multiple neurons on the
output side to have many more classes
for example or it can also be used for
regression as well not necessarily only
classification again since this video is
not about deep learning or machine
learning or neural network we will
probably not go into a lot of details
but you can check other videos where we
have given a lot more details about
neural networks and deep learning and so
on so in order to develop a deep
learning application how do you go about
primarily there are two or three
components that are required in order to
develop deep learning application you
need obviously a programming language so
typically python is used and that's what
we are going to use in this particular
video but you can also use other
languages like java or c plus plus and
so on and there are some libraries that
are readily available and for primarily
for doing
machine learning and deep learning
programming so these are a list of
libraries these are by no means the
exhaustive list but some of the most
common ones like keras thiano tensorflow
and so on and so forth tensorflow has
nowadays become very very popular this
is uh developed by google and it is an
open source library and uh keras was
there before now keras has actually now
become a part of tensorflow as well so
it is one player about tensorflow so in
that sense they're well integrated so
combination of keras and tensorflow is
pretty good then of course you have a
torch and dl4j and so on and so forth so
there are multiple libraries but this
video is about tensorflow and we will be
focusing on tensorflow what are the
benefits of tensorflow and what are its
components and our towards the end we
will show you a code in python we've
written a code in python by the way
tensorflow can be used with multiple
languages it supports multiple languages
though python is by far the most popular
language so let's take a look at what
exactly is tensorflow and why we are so
excited about tensorflow so tensorflow
offers um apis now we can earlier
without when these libraries none of
these libraries were there even then we
were doing people were doing machine
learning and deep learning and so on but
the coding mechanism was much more
complicated what these libraries like
tensorflow offer is they provide kind of
a high level api so that we don't have
to go really deep into writing all the
stuff that is required let's say to
prepare a neural network and to even
configure or even to program a neuron
and so on right so these are done by the
library so all you need to do is they
offer a higher level api you need to use
that api and call that api and maybe
pass the data and that would pretty much
it's much easier rather than actually
going down and writing everything by
yourself so tensorflow that way it
offers apis for to write your code in
python or even c plus and so on other
languages java as well it has an
integration with r as well apparently
okay and it supports cpus as well as
gpus now deep learning applications are
very compute intensive especially the
training process needs a lot of
computation it takes very long as you
can imagine that because the the data
size is large and there are so many
iterative processes there are so much of
mathematical calculations matrix
multiplication and so on and so forth so
for that if you perform these activities
on a normal cpu typically it would take
much longer but gpus are graphical
processing units you must have heard
gpus in the context of games and so on
because where you need the screen needs
to be of high resolution and the images
need to be of high resolution and so on
so gpus that as the name such as
graphical processing unit were
originally designed for that but since
they are very good at handling this kind
of iterative calculations and so on now
they are kind of they are being used or
leveraged rather for doing or developing
deep learning applications and
tensorflow supports gpus as well as cpus
so i think that's one of the major
advantages of tensorflow as well now
again what is exactly tensorflow it's a
open source library developed by google
and open source and primarily for deep
learning development but tensorflow also
supports traditional machine learning by
the way so if you want to do some
traditional machine learning we can do
it however it is probably a bit of an
overhead to use tensorflow for doing
traditional machine learning and this is
really good for performing deep learning
activities and again if you want to get
into more details about what's the
difference between machine learning and
deep learning there is another video
about it you can probably take a look at
that video what else it is developed
originally for large numerical
computations so originally when
tensorflow was developed they never
thought of it as keeping deep learning
in mind but ultimately it so happened
that it's really very good for deep
learning development and therefore
google has open sourced it and
tensorflow as the name suggests the data
is in the form of what is known as
tensors these are like multi-dimensional
arrays and they are very handy in
handling large amounts of data and we
will see that as well as we move forward
and then of course the execution
mechanism is in the form of graphs so
that makes it much easier to execute
this code in a distributed manner across
a cluster of computers and and also
using gpus and so on and so forth right
so that's a quick overview about what is
tensorflow we will see little bit more
detail the two major components that is
basically the tensors and the graphs
let's take a look at what they are so
what are tensors tensor is as i
mentioned earlier it is like a
multi-dimensional
array in which the data is stored now
when we are doing deep learning
especially the training process you will
have large amounts of data and the data
is in typically in a very complicated
format and it really helps when you're
able to put this use this or store it in
a compact way and so tensors actually
offer a very nice and compact way of
storing the data handling the data
during computation this is not really
for storing on your hard disk or things
like that but in memory when you are
doing the computation tenses are really
really very handy in terms of keeping
the data compact because they are like
multi-dimensional arrays so the data is
stored in tensors and then it is fed
into the neural network and then you get
the output all right so there are some
terms associated with tensors let's get
ourselves familiarized one is the
dimension and another is the rank so
what is dimension typically dimension is
like the number of elements in a way so
for example this is a five by four
dimension tensor and then you can have
again the multi dimensions right so you
can this can be like three by three by
three so that is uh the dimension and
then you have ranks so what are tensor
ranks ranks are basically traditionally
we would have thought of as dimensions
that is actually in this case it is
called rank so it becomes easier when we
see examples so a tensor's rank is
supposed to be zero when there is only
one element we also call this as scalar
so just one element and this is not
really a vector it's just an element
like 200 it's also known as a scalar so
such a tensor is supposed to be having a
rank of zero then you have let's say a
one dimensional array this is a vector
with a row of elements this has rank of
one now if you have traditionally what
we called as a two-dimensional like a
matrix for example then the rank is two
and in this case the rank is three and
it can have more ranks as well as i
mentioned it is like a multi-dimensional
array so you can have rank five six and
so on okay so those are the
terminologies in tensorflow terms
dimensions and ranks so this is just to
make sure that we are picking the same
language so whenever we talk about the
rank of a tensor you understand what
exactly is meant by that now in addition
to tensors in which the data is actually
stored all right so the data is stored
in the tensors and then once you have
the data there is a computation that
needs to be done now the computation
happens in the form of graphs so what we
typically in a tensorflow program what
we do is it's not like traditional
programming where you just write a bunch
of lines and then everything gets
executed in sequence here we prepare
graphs various nodes and then these are
executed in the form of a session and
they use the data from these tensors now
i know this is a slightly new concept
for a lot of you so it may be a little
difficult to probably understand in the
first cut but when we look at the code
when we go into the tutorial the code
walkthrough i think that time it will
become much clearer as well but to start
with just uh we need to keep in mind
that we have to first prepare a graph
and when you're preparing the graph no
none of the code is actually getting
executed you write the code to prepare
the graph and then you execute that
graph so that's the way by creating a
session that's the way tensorflow
program works so and each of these
computation is represented as what is
known as a data flow graph and we will
also see that whenever you start
tensorflow when you create an object
tensorflow object there will be what is
known as the default graph and then if
required i know probably in the
beginning it may not be required but in
more advanced programming you can
actually have multiple graphs instead of
the default graph you can create your
own graph and have multiple graphs and
use it as well but there is always
whenever you create a tensorflow object
there will be a default graph and this
will be very nicely illustrated in the
example code that we will take to
explain this so there it becomes much
clearer than in these slides so the
graph gets executed and it processes all
the data that we are feeding all the
external data will be fed in the form of
what is known as placeholders and then
you have variables and constants again
this will also become clear when we take
a look at the code and once you have the
graph then the execution can be enabled
either on regular cpus or on gpus and
also in a distributed mode so that the
processing becomes much faster as i
mentioned the training of the models in
deep learning takes extremely long
because of the large amount of data and
therefore using tensorflow actually
makes it much easier to write the code
for gpus or cpus and then execute it in
a distributed manner so this is how the
tensorflow program looks so there is uh
you need to build a computational graph
that's the first step and then you
execute that graph so the first step is
to write the code for preparing the
graph and then you create what is known
as a session and then in that session
you ask the session to execute this
graph so this will again become much
clearer when we look at the code hello
and welcome to the session on installing
tensorflow my name is mohan and i'm
going to take you through the process of
setting up this tensorflow development
environment as some of you may be aware
it's not that easy to set up the
tensorflow environment there are several
components there are several
possibilities for example
you can set up on windows you can set up
on ubuntu now ubuntu has multiple
versions which version to use and then
you have python which release of python
to use whether to do a pip install
whether to do install using anaconda and
how do you then link it up with jupiter
notebook these are multiple
possibilities and it takes up a lot of
time to try all of these so today what
i'm going to do is show you a tried and
tested method of setting up the
tensorflow environment and this will
help primarily those who are starting
with tensorflow so that they don't have
to waste so much time on setting up the
environment in experimenting with the
installation and setting up of the
environment now what we are going to do
is i will show you a method by which you
you know it is a tried and tested method
and of course tensorflow homepage has a
install page and it shows you some ways
to install but again the challenge is
the same there are multiple versions
multiple methods shown there so it's
highly confusing for somebody who is new
as to decide which one which path to
take so in today's session what we are
going to do is we will set up tensorflow
on ubuntu and i am going to show you in
a virtual box but then if you are using
a laptop with ubuntu installed you can
straight away use the same method
however we need to keep one thing in
mind that the various releases and
versions of ubuntu and
python and tensorflow not all of them
are compatible with each other so these
versions and releases need to be very
specific so i will tell you which is the
version and releases what combination is
best suited for you to get started and
later on of course you can then
experiment with other possibilities and
other releases and so on once you get
familiar with tensorflow to start with i
would also like to mention that it is a
good idea to install or start with
ubuntu environment or linux any other
linux also but here we will focus on
ubuntu rather than windows so for those
who are already let's say using a
windows system the question may arise
what do we do but there is a easy option
as you can see i am actually using a
virtual box so you need to install
virtualbox let me just show you so this
is the virtual box oracle vm virtual box
and there are tons of videos on youtube
how to install
a virtual box and how to create ubuntu
image i think we will not spend time on
that but if you're using windows and my
preference would be to set up a virtual
box and set up your environment in
ubuntu image so we will start by
assuming that you have an ubuntu
environment especially release 14.04 lts
there are multiple ubuntu versions and
again we will not try to get the latest
and the greatest versions or latest and
greatest releases but the focus here is
to take the releases and versions which
are working and where you will not the
waste time so the setup process will be
smooth if you stick to these releases
you can of course experiment later on
with other versions and try out but here
we will be working with ubuntu 14.04 lts
and we will use python 3.4 and we will
use tensorflow 1.5 this is a tried and
tested combination and i would also
recommend that you use the same if you
want a smooth start and so let's get
started with that
let me login to my ubuntu system
okay so we have the ubuntu system
running here now if you go to
tensorflow.org there is a page which
mentions how to install tensorflow and
as you can see there are multiple
possibilities you have ubuntu you have
windows and mac os and so on and so
forth and if you go to ubuntu for
example further you will get
multiple options whether you want cpu or
gpu and
whether you want to do a pip install or
using a virtual native pip virtual env
anaconda and so on and so forth so all
these options are
very complicated or rather very
confusing i would say not complicated
depending on whether you're expert or of
course i am talking about beginners here
but if you click on some of these
options they may look very easy so for
example if you go back and
if you select for example native pip it
may appear like oh this is just you know
one
single or two steps and that's about it
everything gets installed you see here
it should be just one step install it
you say pip3 install tensorflow and
everything gets installed unfortunately
it doesn't work that way so it's not as
easy as so don't get kind of fooled by
the simplicity of the of the
documentation here again it's not their
fault because of the multiple
combinations of releases and so on and
so forth it is not that easy so what we
will do is we will take a slightly
roundabout method which is using
anaconda which has a few more steps but
you're sure that this is going to work
so that is what we are going to do and
that's what i am going to show you so
what are the steps involved of course i
will not go exactly by what they have
mentioned here as i said i will show you
the steps which are again sure shot to
work whereas
here again if you follow just this
document there will be some variations
which they have kind of not documented
so that's the reason i will show you the
steps separately all right so these are
the main four steps you need to download
and install anaconda and then create a
virtual environment with python and the
release as i mentioned is python 3.4 and
we will install tensorflow version 1.5
and then we will install and configure
jupiter which will be our development
environment all right so let's get
started this is our ubuntu and let's get
a terminal started here and
okay yes so
all right so we started the terminal and
then what we'll also do is we'll go to
the anaconda website because we need to
install anaconda we need to download and
install anaconda so for that you need to
go to the anaconda website so you can
just open a browser and
google and you will find anaconda
website
so this is the site anaconda.org
click on this link and it will take you
to the anaconda website
you don't have to sign up or anything
like that just look for the download
anaconda
so just click on that it will take you
to the download pages and it
automatically recognizes that you are on
ubuntu so it will show you the links to
download
all right so as you can see it does
recognize that you're on a linux
operating system so
you can just click on this download and
it will start the download there are two
versions of course python with python
3.6 and 2.7 i
recommend you start with python 3.6 now
just want to clarify that we will be
actually using python 3.4 this is just
for the initial installation but
subsequently when we set up the virtual
environment you will see there is one
more step there where we set up the
virtual environment there we will
actually be using python 3.4 so just
that you are not confused all right so
it has started the download we just say
no thanks for this and it is downloading
while it is downloading you can
click on this
link saying how to install anaconda so
there are a couple of steps mentioned
there that we will be using so let me
just in the meanwhile click on this for
some reason the network is a little slow
so it's taking time all right so
once the download is done we will be
using the options that are mentioned
here now the first step of course is we
we are already doing the first step
which is downloading the installer for
linux the second step is not mandatory
so it's an optional step most often you
can actually skip that and third step is
what we are going to do and
since we are using at this point we are
using python 3.6 we should use this
command so basically
the terminal we have opened here is is
to use or to run this command that's the
reason i opened this terminal however
make sure that the download is complete
before you run this command so we'll
just wait for a couple of minutes and
we'll come back once the download is
done all right so as you can see the
download is done this is a fairly large
file so if you are on a slow internet or
low internet bandwidth then it might
take quite a while it's about uh
578 mb and so this is the file now what
you need to do is
you need to go back to this installation
steps and let me minimize this and
yeah so
this is the command that you need to run
so you can just directly copy and paste
this command from here
okay so i do copy right mouse click
now it will ask you a bunch of questions
as documented here so most of them you
need to just say enter or yes and that's
about it except for the last step i will
just show you what i mean and here you
need to do press enter multiple times
just to make sure you agree to all these
agreement uh the license agreement and
so on and so forth so once you do
multiple
enters it will
bring you to the next step
all right so now here again they say do
you accept the terms you just say yes
and then press enter and here it will
ask you a couple of questions and pretty
much you need to just go for the default
version press enter to confirm you just
say press enter and
this is primarily when it will
pretty much start the installation
process of anaconda this might take a
little while depending again on your
internet speed so you need to have some
patience we will also probably come back
once this installation is done or if i
if it asks for any further questions
all right so here you'll get again one
more question do you wish to
wish the installer to
so you just say yes for this question
and
keep going now the last question
i think we are pretty much at the end
and that is about microsoft
vss i guess yeah vs code so for this you
can just say no because we will not be
using this
and
that's it you're done so this is a
completion of
installation of anaconda so it's always
a good idea to exit and start a fresh
terminal
okay so
let's start again terminal
so we are done with the
installation of anaconda the next step
is to create a virtual environment with
python 3.4 so for that this is the
command conda create dash n
and this is the name of your virtual
environment you can give any name but
for easy reference i have given us
tensorflow and we have to specify the
python version as i mentioned earlier we
will be using the combination of python
3.4 and
tensorflow 1.5 now this is not the
latest version python has probably 3.6
at this point at the time of creation of
this video and even tensorflow probably
has the latest version as 1.7 but then
these combinations sometimes may not
work and i found that after several
trials and errors 3.4 with 1.5 seems to
be most reliable and that's the reason i
have chosen this i would recommend you
to try with this first if you're a
beginner and later on maybe you can try
out the other permutations and
combinations all right one step i just
wanted to show you is before we do the
installation or creation of the virtual
environment if you want to just clarify
or confirm whether anaconda has been
installed or not you can run what is
known as anaconda navigator so you just
say anaconda
navigator
okay we need to edit this part hold on
one second i guess it is
all right so you see here when you start
anaconda navigator
this
anaconda navigator will open up that is
the indication that anaconda has been
installed
properly so that's just a quick check
and you don't have to do anything just
you can
go back and close it
once this comes up and
then in the meanwhile let me just open
one more terminal
for the creation of the
virtual environment and
um
yeah so this is your anaconda navigator
and you can just say okay don't show me
just say okay
and
then you can close this you can say file
you can do a file exit or you can click
on close button whichever
all right so we will exit from here
we have a
terminal open here we will use this for
our next steps all right so what we have
to do now is
type in this
piece of
code
or this command
for some reason copy paste is not
working so
it's a small command so it shouldn't be
that big of an issue so we say conda
and we say
create
so this is the command for creating a
new environment slash
dash n
and then we give the name of the
environment so we will we can give any
name for
convenience i'm just calling it
tensorflow
but you can actually name it anything
and then we need to specify with the
which version of python so we say pip
python
and then that is equal
3.4 okay so it will create an
environment this will take a little
while it will ask you a question just
say yes and then it will be done
so this is just a warning you can simply
ignore that
and um for the question that it asks you
just say yes and i think you should be
good
all right so it says do you want to
proceed you say yes then enter
this will again take a little little
time so we will probably move forward
and then come back once this is done
all right so
the environment has been created now
it's always a good idea to whenever some
of these steps get over or each step
gets over you just exit the terminal and
start afresh with the new terminal for
some reason sometimes it causes problem
if you continue so i found that it is
a safe practice to each time exit the
terminal and start afresh now that we
have an environment created
we can by the name tensorflow
you can
enter that environment by calling the
command source
activate
tensorflow to name whatever name you
have given so you'll see here once you
do that you will get this the name of
the environment will be shown here so it
is like your own again a special
environment within within the system and
from here onwards you can do other stuff
like actually installing tensorflow and
so on and you will see that it has
installed python 3 here so 3.4 right so
it is installed that's what we during
creation of this environment we wanted
python 3.4 so that is what it is showing
but we are not yet done so we need to
still install tensorflow so in this
environment you need to run a command
which will actually install the correct
combination of tensorflow now this is as
you can see it's a slightly complicated
command pip install
dash dash ignore install so
what we can do is from within here we
can go and
go to tensorflow
install page and there is a sample code
there you can pick up from there so that
you don't have to type in
so much
so we say tensorflow tensor
flow
dark and i'll also open up probably a
notepad here so that we can construct
that command and go here
you say
ubuntu
if you come further down there will be
by the way we are doing cpu installation
i think uh that is clear we are not
there is a possibility to do gpu as well
we will probably create a separate video
for that
and um if we go here
yeah so
again you probably if you follow the
entire document out here it may still
not work so i do not recommend that for
now at least for beginners but just to
copy this command because this is a
fairly complicated command so this is
much easier to copy from here that's the
reason i'm
on this page
and we will
then modify it according to
yes okay let's say
copy
and don't do it directly here because
that is probably not yet the right
command
let us go and create a notepad
page
empty document
i'll just say
tf.txt
okay this is just a temporary file what
we need to do here is we need to adjust
this command to suit the
versions that we are installing here so
let me just explain what it is what you
need to do
so first thing you can get rid of this
one
yes okay
now here these parts you can simply
ignore here you need to go and change it
to version
1.5
and i think we are good with that okay
so
the cp34 indicates your python 3.4
so later on when you're trying to
experiment and if you want to
do
other combinations of tensorflow and
python version then you can change this
for example you can change this to 3 6
both these places you need to change
this to 3 6 if you are using with python
3.6 and similarly if you want the latest
version which is of tensorflow which is
1.7 you need to change this to 1.7 and
so on but at this point to start with if
you are a beginner i would recommend
that you stick to this tensorflow 1.5
with python 3.4 this is tried and tested
and it works okay just a word of caution
that just by changing these versions
the whole thing
will not work there may be
other places where you may have to some
of the steps may change so just a word
of caution that just by changing this if
you want to try out with a different
version some of the steps may also
change so don't think that just by
changing this this one particular
command you will be
fine okay so
that's been my experience so to start
with i would recommend use this
particular combination all right so it
looks good
uh tensorflow 1.5 and
let me
just reconfirm with my notes and i think
it looks good so this is install ignore
1.5 cp34 cp34
and so on okay
okay so let's hit enter
so it started the process again this
might take a little while so we will
pause the recalling and then get back
when the
installation is done okay so
looks like this installation is done
and as always let us
exit and then come back now
you are currently in the environment
virtual environment um and it's a good
practice before you exit out of the
terminal to come on doctor out of the
virtual environment so just like you did
source activate
you need to do source deactivate
and the name tensor
flow okay you will come back to the
original command prompt and then from
here you can
do an exit now we need to validate
whether the tensorflow installation has
gone through properly or not so
the way to validate is to
first start python and then import
tensorflow library see if it imports
without error so that's the best way to
validate so we'll open a terminal
and whenever you want to get into
the
environment this is how you have to do
come to environment and then say source
and obviously you can also use existing
so source activate
tensorflow okay
so we do this and you need to run python
from here remember you should say
python3 because you have installed
python 3.4 now here when you say import
tensorflow
as df
when you get back a prompt like this
without any errors that means tensorflow
installation has been successful if
tensorflow was not installed properly
you will get an error saying tensorflow
is not available or module doesn't exist
or something like that so tensorflow
installation is done but now we will go
through the process of installing
jupyter notebook so that you can do your
development so let me just exit
and in order to install your jupyter
notebook which is your which is going to
be your development environment we will
first
install ipython using conda so conda
install ipython and then pip install
jupiter so let's first do the
ipython conda
install
python
again it will ask you a question saying
these are the components do you want to
install you just say yes
all right you say yes
once again it will take a little while
so we might pause the recording and come
back once it is done
great so that did not take much
time anyways so we will
as usual we will
exit which is
source deactivate
tensorflow
exit and then we will start a fresh
terminal
in order to install
jupiter
now in some places
they may say
install jupiter using pip3 but in my
experience it did not work with p3 and
that's the reason we will use pip
however just keep in mind you need to
first go to the environment so
source activate
tensorflow
and you need to use this command which
is pip install jupyter usually when
you're on python 3 you use pip3 but as i
said it did not work so
in my experience it works with pip
install and not pick 3. so pip install
jupiter
i hope you already noticed that it is
jupy per
and not jpi
so again it's probably taking a little
while we will pause the recording and
come back once it is done
okay so jupyter installation is also
done
once again
you need to it's a good idea not you
need to but it's a good idea to
come out of this terminal session and
then start afresh
so we exit and we have a fresh terminal
already available here
and
we will once again
go to tensorflow
and we say
jupiter
notebook
that's how you start your jupyter
notebook
so this looks good now only thing is
since we are running
for the first time what you need to do
is if you come back to your command
prompt
it will show you that if you're running
it for the first time
it will say that you need to copy paste
this link so you you can just for the
first time only once you need to do this
copy this
and
paste it in your
browser
and remember this is only the first time
when you're running jupyter you need to
do this
subsequently you don't have to it will
automatically
open up all right so now that we have
jupyter installed and
it starts up we need to test whether
tensorflow
is working fine or not and in order to
do that you can create a new
notebook
and you say
import
tensorflow
as tf and shift enter if everything is
fine then supply is installed properly
you don't get any errors and then it
works fine this is
an indication that tensorflow got
installed successfully
and that's about it so
that's all about installing tensorflow
with python 3.4 so remember this is
installation of tensorflow 1.5 with
python 3.4
on ubuntu and
once again in case you have a windows
system in fact i have also done it on a
windows system you can
use virtualbox to create a virtual
environment
ubuntu environment and then follow these
steps and there are tons of videos to
create virtual box and that's the reason
we have not included those steps in this
and if there are any comments there are
better ways to do this please mention it
in the comment section below or if you
need any further help just mention it
and with your email we will respond to
you now what are the various elements of
a tensorflow program as i mentioned
tensorflow program is slightly different
from regular programming that we do so
even if you're familiar with python this
may still be new for you the way you
write a tensorflow program is different
from the regular python programming that
you would have done or even machine
learning program you would have written
some machine learning program using
scikit-learn or regular python libraries
this is different from even that so let
us see what are the various elements so
first of all the way we handle data
inside of a program itself is a little
different from how we normally do in a
normal programming language a variable
is a variable in your program right so
you have anything that can keep changing
you just create as a variable or even
constants in fact are actually created
as variables but in tensorflow the
storage in the program consists of three
types one is constants another is
variable and the third is a placeholder
so and they are there is a lot of
difference between these types and we
will see how they vary and how they are
used and so on so constants are like
variables which cannot be changed so for
example if you define a constant like
this this is how you define a constant
by the way the simplest format is like
this like for example b is equal to t f
dot constant and then you give a value
here the slightly more advanced version
is you also specify the type so you say
tf.constant 2.0 tf load 32 so the type
is of type float now in case of
constants you cannot during the
computation you cannot really change
these values so for example if you want
to change the value of b from 3 to 5 or
any other number it is not possible so
that is the meaning of constant all
right so then we have variables so
variables we're all familiar with what
are variables whenever we use
programming we use variables so this is
pretty much the same this is the way you
define variables df dot variable now one
thing you need to note is this is the
only type in which we have v capital
okay constant has c a small c and
placeholder as small p but variable as
capital v and tf.variable and then you
give the a value and then you can
specify what is the type and then you
can use the variable change the variable
at any point in time with a different
value and so on you can update the
variable and so on so we will see all of
this in the code i will illustrate how a
variable is defined and how it can be
changed whereas a constant cannot be
changed and so on and so forth and then
we have placeholders placeholders are
really a special type and this may be
something completely new for many of us
who have been doing programming but in
tensorflow this is a completely new
concept so this is very important to
understand this placeholders are like
variables but only thing is that they
are used for feeding the data from
outside so typically when you are
performing some computations you need to
load data from a file or from an image
file or from a csv file or whatever so
there is a provision with the special
kind of variables which can be fed in a
regular basis because the reason one of
the reasons for having this kind of
provision is that if you get the entire
input in one shot typically it may be
very difficult to handle memory and so
on so i think that was the reason they
came up with this mechanism where you
can feed in patches and there is a
certain way of populating the
placeholder we call this feed dig feed
underscore dick and this is a parameter
name by the way and you feed the
placeholders right that is the meaning
here so there is a certain way of
feeding the placeholders and we will
again see this in the example code as we
move forward okay so there are three
types one is the constant which cannot
be changed once you assign a value then
you have variables which are like normal
variables we are all familiar with and
then you have placeholders this is
primarily for feeding data from usually
from outside but of course you can also
for temporary testing purpose you can
feed within the program as well but
primarily the purpose of a placeholder
is to get data from outside so all right
so those were the constants variables
and placeholders that is how you handle
data within the tensorflow program and
then you create a graph and once you
create a graph then you have what is
known as a session and then you create a
session object and you create a session
and then you run a particular
computation or a node or an operation
and so typically what you need to do is
every variable or a computation that you
perform is like an operation or a node
within a graph so initially the graph
will be what is known as the default
graph the moment you create a tensorflow
object or tf this tf here you see this
is the tensorflow object and again in
the code when we go into the code it
will become much
easier to understand so when you create
a tensorflow object there is like a
default graph which doesn't have any
operations no nodes or anything like
that so it's like a clean slate the
moment you assign variables or constants
or placeholders each of them is in
tensorflow terms it is known as an
operation again you need to get familiar
with these terms and they are not very
intuitive this is not really an
operation you're just creating a
constant or a variable but and this c is
equal to a into b would traditionally or
would intuitively be an operation here
you're actually performing an operation
but in tensorflow terms each of these
everything is an operation so if you're
creating a constant that is an operation
another constant or variable that's an
operation so you can actually run each
of these and they're also known as
referred to as nodes and when you're in
your session you will actually
run each of these you can potentially
run each of these nodes okay so a
typical example would look like this so
you have two constants created a is
equal to tf.constant its value is 5 b is
equal to this and then you say c is
equal to a into b and then you create a
session now remember all this you're
just creating a graph at this point no
execution has happened all right so only
at this point once you create a session
and then you say session or says dot run
c is when actually this whole thing will
get executed all right so that is a
different way of programming compared to
our traditional way of writing programs
so you need to get used to this new
format and when we look at the code as
we move forward and when we look in the
jupyter notebook it will become much
easier probably to understand this
rather than in the slide so these are
the slides showing the code but what we
can do is go straight into the
lab and take a look at the various
examples that are there and starting
from the very basic one how you create
variables and so these are some of the
slides that are showing so this is about
how to create variables how to create
constants and the variables or constants
can also be strings so this is like our
first hello world program and we will
talk about placeholders how to define a
placeholder and how to execute and
populate the placeholder values into
placeholder we will see these examples
in the lab actually i will run the code
and
we will also perform a small computation
of adding and multiplying these
variables and
we will in the end we will take up a use
case implementation using tensorflow so
let's first go and see those examples
and then come back and i'll explain this
use case and then we will execute the
use case in the lab so let's go and
check our lab okay so i'm in the jupiter
notebook environment and this is one of
the development environments we can use
this is regular python anytime you do
python programming we use gypted
notebook or there are rather of course
there are other ways of using other
tools like pycharm and so on but for
this particular tutorial i'm comfortable
using jupiter notebook so i will show
you in jupiter notebook so this is the
very basic example to demonstrate how to
create variables and constants and
placeholders and what is the difference
between them how they behave and so on
and as i mentioned the assumption here
is that you know at least some basic
python programming or some programming
language so at least you understand the
code here and first two pieces of code
you will not need machine learning
background but when we do the use case
of the case study there it is expected
that you know at least some basic
machine learning concepts so in case you
need to brush up the machine learning
part you may have to do that before you
go to the third one but here just at
least some idea of programming will be
sufficient so what are we doing here in
this particular line or in this
particular cell we are importing
tensorflow it is uh as i mentioned it is
a library so we are importing tensorflow
and we are calling it tf so this is just
a name you can give it any name but it
is very common and everywhere wherever
tensorflow programming is done it is
always named as tf but you can name
anything actually okay so this will
import the tensorflow into my session
now this is the way to create a variable
so let's start by creating a variable
and this is the name of my variable i'm
starting by giving a name called 0 and
i say 0 is equal to tf.variable and then
i'm giving the value of the variable
here so this is the very basic way and
the simplest way to create a variable we
will see a little later there are other
formats as well but the bare minimum way
of creating a variable is this so i'm
creating a variable by the name zero and
as i mentioned you need to pay attention
to the capital v here in case of
variable it is a capital v uppercase
constant and placeholders are
lowercase now i'm creating a constant
and the constant i'm naming it as 1 and
the way to create a constant is tf dot
constant and then you give the value of
the constant so the value of the
variable here is zero and the value of
constant here is one and again constant
you can also have additional parameters
like a name and so on probably you must
have seen in other tutorials or in other
places where the code is written but the
basic format construct to create a
constant is this this is sufficient to
create a constant so i created one
variable and one constant now what else
can we do again here there is no real
execution happening we are just building
a graph we have not yet executed any
tensorflow code we are building a graph
and i will show you how the graph looks
as well first let us understand the
constants and variables and so on and
then i will show you how the graph is
generated and so on so what i want to do
here is i want to add 0 and 1 and put it
into a new variable called new value so
what i do here tensorflow offers these
methods like add assign multiply or you
have matrix multiplication matmul and so
on right so i will use one of those
methods which is tf dot add and then
pass these two as parameters so we can
add a variable and a constant there are
no restrictions on that so this is a
variable and this is a constant so if i
do this it will be okay i did not
execute this code so it is giving an
error now we are good okay so what it
has done is new value will be equal to
tf dot add 0 1 so then we have one
variable and one constant now let's say
i want to change the value of the
variable because that is possible right
so we want to change the value of the
variable to something some new value so
we have in this case new value has one
because we added a zero and a one so new
value has one now i want to assign this
to this originally what we called as
zero so i will call that as update is
equal to tf dot assign so assign is
basically changing the value so that's
what we we're going to do here now it
has not complained we'll just say fine
right there are no issues now let us try
this something similar
with this 1 as well so 0 is a variable
so we were able to change the value and
we will in a little while we will see
what exactly those values are but before
doing that now let's say i will
uncomment this part and i want to do
something similar for my constant right
1 is a constant now i want to let's say
change the value of the constant and
make that also something different okay
so if i execute this piece of code it
will give an error now again the error
message may not be very intuitive this
doesn't say that you cannot do this for
a constant it will just say tensor
object has no attribute assign now that
sometimes may be confusing especially
when you are starting but the meaning
here is that one is a constant and
you're trying to modify the constant so
it will not allow that's the reason it
is complaining so let's put that back in
the comment and
okay so that is done so only variables
you can modify now what you have to do
let's skip this piece of code i'll come
back to this in a bit
but let's say we start by creating you
remember i told you we need to create a
session so the way to create a session
there are a couple of ways of creating a
session but this is for beginners this
is the easiest way all you need to do is
assign a variable called says or you can
give any name and that is equal to tf
dot session that is the session method
here and you create a session object by
the name says now what i'll do is i'll
skip this as well i there is a purpose
behind that now let's go ahead and run
this piece of particular operation
remember i mentioned that everything you
need to run so as of now the code has
not really got executed tensorflow code
has not got executed you only created
the graph so only when you
run through the session is when that
actually the program gets executed so
when you do this now you see observe
that it is giving an error okay the
reason behind that is remember we skip
these two lines of code for variables
okay this and then this now this is
something very very important to observe
if you have variables in your code what
i mean by that is let's say you're not
using variables but you have only
constants and placeholders then this
will not complain and you will not get
this error but in our case we also have
variables so whenever you have variables
in that case you need to do an
initialization and this is just a
standard code there is nothing that we
need to add or modify or anything like
that this is a standard piece of code
you create this name of course can be
anything you can give us any name but
this global variables initializer is
what you need to call tf.global
variables initializer this will kind of
initialize all the variables that you
may be using and then again remember
this doesn't execute anything right so
all you're doing here is you're creating
an operation but in order to run that
operation you need to also run this
known as run init underscore op so this
operation you need to run after creating
the session all right so we executed
this now let us execute this and now
when i run this piece of code it will
run successfully okay i hope you
observed that so it is whenever you use
variables these two lines of code one is
the operation you need to create an
operation for saying global variables
initializer and then you need to run
before running anything else you need to
do a session.run this operation okay
again only if you're using
variables of course you invariably in
all your programs you will use variables
you cannot just write a program with
constants and placeholders so you can
pretty much assume that this has to be
there in pretty much all the programs
now again why
this has not been taken care of in the
library that's a different question but
you need to keep in mind and always
remember if you don't do this for
whatever reason if you're forgotten you
will get an error and the error won't be
intuitive so you need to remember this
that this could be because of the
variables okay good so we have seen how
to create a constant and we have seen
how to create a variable and we have
seen that you cannot modify or update a
constant and we have also seen if you
have variables that you need to execute
or have these two lines of code to
initialize the variables and then we
have seen that after creating a graph
how to run the graph in a session and i
will show you a little bit more in
detail how exactly the graph gets
created and how it gets executed but
this was the first very quick code on
creating variables and constants now we
will keep going and
we will also show you or i will show you
the placeholders but before that one
more small piece of code so this is how
you write a for loop okay so we are
saying five times you run this piece of
code now like any python program this is
nothing different so you have a for loop
and this is indented that's the reason
and therefore you say session.run update
so this will run five times and it will
get printed that's all so update will
run for five times each time it will
come and do this particular operation
that's all we are we are asking the
system to do so let me just run that and
show you let me yeah so it will
okay so it has done five times
one that's four it is basically adding
if you recall it starts from zero it
adds one to zero then one to one one to
two and so on so it's nothing but it is
generating five numbers one two three
four five that's it okay so then
you can also have your constants as
strings for example so you can also work
in a similar way you can work with
string so most of the computation
happens
mainly on numerical values so we
normally hand handle numbers but there
will be situations where you may have to
handle strings as well or text as well
so this is an example of text operation
so you can similar to numbers you just
create strings or store
in constants instead of a number you say
hello is equal to tf.constant and then
you assign the string that you want it
to be assigned and then the next one is
one more string which is for world and
then you say add these two so it is
nothing but concatenation of these two
words hello and
world
so we will do that and remember this is
only creation of the graph right so in
order to actually execute this graph you
need to run the session now you need to
keep in mind we don't have to create the
session once again because once you
create a session till you close the
session it remains valid okay so we have
created this session here now till you
say says dot close it will remain for
you so that's why we did not create one
more so we are just reusing that session
says dot run hello world so in this
hello world what is the operation that
we are doing here the operation is add
these two concatenate these two so if i
run this it will print hello world okay
now that's string operation now we will
take a look at placeholders so this is
slightly more complicated and something
new even for people who have been
writing programs so but i'll just
explain it with uh with a quick example
first of all how do you declare or
create a placeholder you just do
tf.placeholder and the p is lowercase
only in case of variables the b is
uppercase but otherwise constant and
placeholders it is lowercase and you
just say because as i mentioned this is
a placeholder it doesn't have any value
so you unlike a constant or your
variable you can't usually you will not
specify any value you just say what type
of placeholder you want and very often
most of the cases it is a floating point
so we just say placeholder of type
float32 so this tf dot float32 tells the
system that it is a floating point okay
and then so let me just run this and
then you can do some or define some
computation like for example b is equal
to a into two now remember here right
now a has no value but what we are
saying here is at any point later on
when a gets some value then b should be
equal to twice the value of a that's all
we are saying here okay and also as i
mentioned earlier we are not yet
executing anything we are just creating
the graph here okay so now you have that
now how do you feed the value or
populate the placeholder there is a
certain syntax in which you can populate
the placeholder and you do that using
what is known as a dictionary you're all
probably familiar those with python
especially must be familiar with the
dictionaries so you need to create a
dictionary and then pass that
in order to feed the placeholder so in
this particular example if i want to run
something if i want to calculate or
compute b obviously i need to feed the
value of a so the value of a i'm feeding
using this dictionary and i'm saying
that a is equal to 3. now there are
multiple ways of populating the value of
a because it typically this won't be
just a single a scalar value like in
this case right remember scalar so it's
just one value one number typically it
would be a vector or or a tensor very
often it is a tensor so we will see step
by step so we can start with the very
basic example where a can be a scalar so
in this case a is equal to 3 that's what
we are saying feed underscore dict in
this case feed underscore dick is the
name of a variable by the way so you
can't give anything else here so if you
just say feed is equal to this it will
give you an error all right so keep that
in mind either you specify feed
underscore dick is equal to and give the
dictionary pass the dictionary or use
straight away like in this case this is
another format so let's see first let me
execute this it has given 6 okay i think
let me see if i can clear out this
particular cell so it becomes easier to
understand okay so it is giving you six
let me do that once again clear out this
and then okay and let me change the
format so this is one way of doing it
another way is you don't even have to
specify the name of this parameter feed
underscore dict you just pass the
dictionary and it will
execute okay but typically this makes
the code readable so that's the reason
most of the places whenever you find
tensorflow code you will see that they
explicitly mention feed underscore date
so that the code is readable otherwise
it can get confusing so i will also
comment this and retain the other format
okay so i hope it's clear so what we are
doing here we are running the operation
b and what exactly is bb is twice a a
into 2 so therefore what we are doing
and a therefore b gets a value of 6 and
that's what is being fed into result and
that's what is getting printed here okay
now as i mentioned a need not be just a
scalar value it can be a vector with a
multi-dimension
array and so on and so forth so let's
start showing you examples of that again
let me just clear out the outputs let me
clear this and let me also clear this
for now okay you can also do before
running up this you could we could also
do clear all output all output clear it
will clear everything but that will
we'll have to start all over again so i
am just doing individually all right so
in this example we are taking a one
dimension array where rank is equal to
one and i'm feeding three four five now
let us see what happens if i run this
right as you can imagine it gets
multiplied each number gets multiplied
so the result is 6 8 10 okay now as i
said it can get more complicated now
let's say this is a multi-dimensional
vector so if you what happens if you
feed this okay so as you can see this is
pretty complicated now but if you feed
this again all you're doing is
there is okay there is a slight change
here again you can also
create your dictionary outside and feed
that here you don't have to directly do
it here like in this case you see there
are variations of the exact syntax in
the way you write it right so there is a
slight variation so in this case you are
creating the dictionary straight away
here kind of inline but here you created
the dictionary separately because it's
more complicated and then you are
passing that dictionary here so i said
dictionary is equal to a and then i'm
saying this is what should be the value
of a
this is and i'm feeding that and then
i'm
using directly that dictionary here okay
so this is equivalent to putting this
code here right so if we execute this
what happens same so you get because a
was a let's say this is a
three by
four by two right so that is one yeah
three by four by two right so you see
here this is a multi-dimensional array
so you feed that and the values you see
here is one two three it became two four
six four five six became eight ten
twelve seven eight nine became fourteen
sixteen eighteen and so on and so forth
okay i hope now you got an idea about
placeholders and in real life what
happens is you typically won't create
these dictionaries manually in since
this is a quick demo we did this you
will actually
read the data into this dictionary and
then you feed that when you're doing the
computation okay so it could be a csv
file or it could be a image file so the
input is basically
read and fed in
usually it is also done in patches so
you don't read the entire thing because
there can be large amount of data so
that is the idea behind having these
placeholders and the way we feed these
placeholders there is a provision that
is a deliberately that has been made a
provision for
this kind of getting data into the
program in chunks okay now in this
particular example we will close the
session here and then i will show you
what is the other way of creating a
session right so now if i close the
session here now if i try to do anything
with the session it will give us an
error so i will probably not do that
right now now there is another way or
another format and this is a very common
way of using the session but i didn't
want to start off with this because this
could get a little confusing the a
simpler way was to create session saying
s is equal to tf dot session but
typically you will do it in what is
known as a width block this is a very
common way of creating session so once
you have the graph you would execute the
graph in a session using a width block
and this is the syntax so you say with
df dot session assess all right and then
you put all your code here so what will
happen is you don't have to explicitly
close the session the moment this width
block gets
completed the session gets closed okay
so let's just take a quick look at this
example now if i uh let me clear this
current output be clear okay so this is
the hello world example a little bit
earlier we did that so i'm doing
with tf.session assessment result is
equal to says dot run hello plus world
and then i say print result okay so
within this with block i'm doing all my
computation and this gets executed now
let's say i try to run remember i
created a session here now if i want to
let's say do something like run sesh dot
run a it is giving an error because the
session is no longer valid
right so you cannot either you have to
run this if you want to run this you
have to run this in this with block
or you shouldn't have closed the session
here right you remember this we said
session.close so since we have closed
the session there is no active session
therefore it is giving an error okay now
there is a third way of creating a
session but for now i will skip it
because that is very very specific to
the notebooks and and so on so we will
just avoid it you start with for
beginners i think the best way is to
start with creating a separate session
and then writing your code and then
closing your session now of course
remember if you don't do this part says
dot close it will not give any error or
anything like that only thing is that
it's a good practice and your resources
will get released otherwise
if you do multiple of these programs if
they are running then your resources
will get blocked that's the only thing
and to start with this it is simpler to
do it this way so initially when you're
doing you start with this but as you
move forward as you become familiar with
tensorflow programming i would recommend
all of you to get into this model most
of the programming tensorflow
programming is done like this with
df.sessions okay all right so that was
one book or one page of a code that we
have done explaining about variables
constants and placeholders
now let me explain how the graph works
so in this example we are going to see
how the graph is created how the graph
gets executed and so on okay now that we
got a understanding of constants and
variables and placeholders okay so we
will start as usual by importing our
library and as i said whenever you
create a tf or tensorflow object there
will be what is known as a default graph
and you can get a handle of that by
saying get default graph so let's do
that and you can display the operations
remember every node in the graph is
considered as an operation right so as
of now as you can see
we have not done anything we have not
created a constant or variable or
nothing right so there was there is no
operation so by the way let's do one
thing let's start with the
all output clear so that
i don't have to again do individually so
we i'll just run these two lines of code
okay now so yeah so we have the default
graph and as of now there are no
operations so there is a method called
get underscore operations which will
kind of display or show what are the
various operations that have been
performed on the graph so as i said to
start with they have no operations being
performed so when i try to display it's
empty there are no nothing is there no
operations okay now let's see what
happens when we slowly step by step
start writing or building the graph so
my first step may be to create a
constant okay remember in the previous
example i have shown you how to create a
constant in the most simple or the
simplest way which is like constant and
then the number right now a small
extension of that is you can actually
give a name to your constant now again
this need not be the same i can say a is
equal to name and xyz i can give
anything here okay this is just for your
reference but here for simplicity
because there is a purpose why i am
using the same name as the name of the
variable and there are other reasons as
well why you would give a name again to
a constant or a variable this is again
useful when we are using what is known
as tensorboard otherwise it doesn't have
much value this additional name doesn't
have much value in this our case also we
will be seeing the graph and that's why
i'm using this but otherwise this having
additionally a name usually doesn't add
much value all right so let's create a
constant
i created a constant now let us see
what's going on in the graph so i will
just say operations is equal to get
operations and if you see here now
you remember here it was blank now you
see the first operation is showing up
and this a that's the reason i put here
so it is showing as a and it says that
okay you have performed an operation
and there is a constant you have created
a constant okay all right so let's move
on let's say we want to create a second
constant
and this is b so if i see what does what
are the operations list of operations
that have been performed you see here
there are two of them so you have
operation a which is a constant then you
have an operation b another constant you
recall we in the term operation here is
not very intuitive right so we are just
creating constants or numbers or
variables and it is saying it's an
operation but that's that's a
terminology in tensorflow everything is
an operation here okay all right so then
what else let's say i want to create a
third operation
and that is basically adding which is
this is a real operation in normal sense
as well so let's say i'm creating c
which is
adding a and b and the c value obviously
will be a plus b
okay now
if we want to see what is in c and we
say c you see here it is not showing
30
it just says it is a tensor
and it is of type in 32 right because
we have not executed the graph we are
still only building the graph i hope
this makes it easy to understand okay so
we are just building the graph we have
till we do remember till we do a session
and run a particular operation you're
not actually executing anything okay
you're just building the graph all right
so now let us see what are the
operations we have done a b and now c so
you will see there are three of them a b
and c okay now let's do
one more operation which is d
and here i'm doing multiplication
remember we did a tf dot add now i'll do
tf.multiply and i'm multiplying a and b
and i'm calling this operation as d so a
has
i think
10 and b has 20 so d will be actually
200 when we execute it right now it is
just a tensor and it is of shape in 32
okay and once again we can see what are
the operations abcd and let's do one
last operation here which is e which is
once again multiplication of c and d now
that c has 30 which is a plus b and d
has 200 which is a into b
so now c into d will be 30 into 200
which is which is equal to
6000 but as we have seen earlier that
multiplication will not happen right now
so now you have built a
fairly simple but operation graph which
consists of
a b c d e one two three four five
operations okay so you built a small
it's not a very complicated one but a
simple graph now you need to execute
these operations so what you need to do
you need to create a session okay so
says dot tf is equal to session and then
you can run these session
print says dot run e now am i missing
something do i have to initialize the
variables that's a question for you
thing can tell me do i have to
initialize the variables that remember i
ran one piece of code i think you must
have got the answer i don't have to
because i am just using all constants
here i have not used any variable here
right so i don't have to write execute
that piece of code to initialize the
variables so i can just create a session
and run any of the operations that i
want to run so in this case i am running
session e operation e right this
operation e now i can actually run
individually instead of doing directly e
i could have run only a or i could have
run b and so on and so forth but in this
case i have run e which in turn will do
all the required computations which is
for example assigning the value to a and
b and c doing the multiplication and so
on all those operations will be
performed which are required to do the
computation of e okay now there is a
small piece of code that you can use to
find out what are the various operations
that are there in this particular graph
in this case of course it was very easy
very straightforward i have created
abcde
but in normal programming in real life
this can sometimes help to see
how
what is there in your graph what kind of
operations are going on in your graph so
you can write this piece of code and it
may sometimes help debugging as well
okay all right so i finished my session
what do we have to do we need to close
the session right because i did not use
the width block so i need to close the
session as a good practice so i close
the session good so that's how the graph
works uh i hope it was helpful in
understanding how variables and
constants and placeholders are created
in the previous example we saw and how
exactly you create a graph and then you
actually execute that graph that's the
way tensorflow program works that's the
structure of tensorflow program okay so
now that we understood the structure of
tensorflow programming let's take an
example and a classification example and
take some real
data from from outside external data csv
file and
try to solve a classification problem
for that let's first go back to the
slides and understand what is the
problem statement and then we will come
back okay so what is the case here we
have some census data and which has all
these features or variables like um the
age of a person
what class work class what is his
education what is his marital status
gender and so on and so forth so there
are a bunch of a bunch of features that
are available and
we have to basically classify or not
classify we have to build a model for
classifying whether the income of this
person is above 50k
or below 50k okay so there is actually a
label data available we will then try to
build a model and then see what is the
accuracy so that this is a typical
machine learning problem actually but as
i said tensorflow can be used for doing
machine learning as well so we will as a
simple example we will take uh machine
learning so this is how the high level
the code looks and in tensorflow
programming we also take help of regular
python
libraries like for example
it could be numpy or it could be
scikit-learn or it could be pandas in
this case and because before you
actually develop or before you train
your model create your model you need to
prepare the data into a certain format
and sometimes if you're doing machine
learning activity you all are familiar
those familiar with machine learning
will know you need to split your data
into training and test data sets so all
that can be done using the regular
non-tensorflow libraries right so these
are like regular python libraries and
scikit learn and so on so we use that
and then prepare the data and then use
tensorflow for performing either the
machine learning or deep learning
activity now so what is the advantage of
using tensorflow the main advantage is
that tensorflow offers high level apis
right we talked about that so in this
case we will be using i'll explain what
is in the slide but before that i wanted
to just show you what is the api that we
will be using so we will be using the
estimator api we will be using the
estimator api to create a classifier
what is known as a linear classifier now
in order to do that you need to prepare
the data and you need to prepare the
data into a certain structure or format
and the api itself needs to be fed in a
certain way so that is exactly what we
are doing before we get into the regular
tensorflow code okay so these slides
will quickly show you what exactly is
happening but i will take you into
jupiter notebook and run that code and
show you so here we are importing the
data the data is the name of the file is
census underscore data.csv it's a csv
file and then there is uh
income bracket is one of the columns
which basically is our target that is
what is used that is the label rather
but this doesn't have numeric values so
it has the income so
we need to convert that into binary
values either 0 or 1. so that's what we
are doing here and then we are splitting
using scikit-learn we are doing
splitting of the data into test and
training right so this is a standard
scikit-learn people some of you who are
familiar with machine traditional
machine learning and you have done
machine learning in python using scikit
learn will immediately recognize this
this is a sk learner's scikit learn and
there is a readily available method to
split the data into training and test
that's what we are doing here and then
you need to create what is known as
feature columns and input functions
before you can call the api estimator
api that's what we are doing here and
data and also there is there are
different ways of creating the feature
columns for
numeric values and for categorical
values or rather for continuous values
and categorical values okay so that's
what has been
two types we are doing here we will see
again in the code as well and
then you create your model so this is
basically model is equal to df.estimator
linear classifier and then you're
feeding the feature columns and also
subsequently you will call the training
by passing the input function and you
specify how many iterations to be done
for the training process and again this
is all typical machine learning process
so there is nothing specific for
tensorflow here and then you evaluate
your model because this is
classification model so you can again
take help of the scikit-learn to test
the accuracy and get the reports
evaluation perform the evaluation and
get the report like this one right so
this is the classification report and
you will see what is the precision
recall f1 score and so on again this is
a standard machine learning process all
right so that's pretty much as far as
the code here is concerned once again
let me take you into our uh lab and
we will get started with this particular
code now let me clear out the outputs so
that you can step by step you can see
the output so this is our data and
we will actually this is just a display
here the code starts from here so before
when we start with our tensorflow part
of it as i mentioned we now remember in
the previous examples the data was kind
of cooked up internally we created some
data and we were using it right the
constants variables and so on here is a
real life example so you are actually
getting data from outside so you know
before we get into tensorflow this is
actually regular python code so we are
using pandas for example to create our
data frame so we will import pandas and
then we will basically read our file
into a pandas data frame and this is how
the data
looks right and if you do a head it will
give you about six
readings or observations five or six
observations and then you can take a
look at how your data is looking so for
example you have age work class
education and so on and so forth okay
and you see here this last column income
underscore bracket it says whether the
income is greater than 50k or less than
50k so this cannot be
understood or this cannot be fed into
our
model or
you know so that's the reason we need to
convert this this will not be understood
right so this needs to be converted
saying okay
maybe less than 50 k is 0 and greater
than 50k is 1 so that conversion needs
to be done before we feed it into our
model so that's what we are going to do
as we move forward so this is the code
for doing that okay so we take this and
then we define a function
and then we run that function so now we
have wherever it is
less than 50 k
it will have 0 and greater than 50 k it
will have 1. so we have now updated the
data then the next part is to split our
data into training and test data set so
how are we going to do that we again
will take the standard python library
which is scikit-learn sk learn library
and
we use an existing
function there which is a train test
split and what we are doing here is
basically splitting the data into i'm
sorry i need to run this
and then this okay sorry about that so
once i run this what is what are we
doing here again those are familiar with
scikit learn will immediately recognize
i am splitting this into test and train
i'm saying test size is 30 so 30 percent
of the data should go into test and
training should have 70 percent okay so
that's all we are doing 0.3 indicates 30
so you can again this can be individual
preferences some people do it like 50 50
some people 20 80 and in our case we are
doing
70 30. so training is 70 and test is 30.
okay all right so
we have so far we've been doing regular
non-tensorflow stuff so preparing the
data so that we can now use for
tensorflow and in tensorflow what we are
doing is we will be using the api called
estimator now estimator in order to call
estimator you need to prepare what is
known as feature columns so feature
columns have to be in a certain format
basically it is nothing but the columns
we have to put them in a certain format
and then when we are calling the the
training we need to pass what is known
as an input function again a certain way
in which you need to pass that function
so that is what we need to do before we
create the model and
run the model for training so the next
few lines will be doing that quick look
at before we even get in once again into
the
tensorflow code so this is just showing
us what are the various columns names of
the columns of this data okay so that is
what is shown here and this is more for
when i was writing the code i could copy
paste from here that's the reason i this
line of code is there instead of typing
in these values okay good so now is
where
the actual tensorflow action starts so i
import tensorflow and now i will use
this feature column functionality to
create my feature columns and there is a
certain construct how you create the
feature columns again probably the
details of that is out of scope here but
just that you need to know that we need
to create feature columns and the way
you create feature columns for
continuous values and for categorical
values is slightly different and that's
the reason you have two different blocks
okay so for categorical values you need
to use what is known as tf dot feature
column dot categorical column width
vocabulary list and again within this
again there are two ways in which you
can create for categorical values one is
a vocabulary list where you know
how many types are there so for example
gender column can have only male and
female so in such a case if there are
let's say a finite number of values for
a given column then you use a column
with vocabulary list okay so and then
you say what is the name of the column
and what are the possible values so in
this case male and female now there will
be situations where the the values that
this column can have
okay first of all it is a categorical
column that means it can have names or
some non-numerical values but the number
of values is probably unknown or
undefined so for example occupation now
occupation can have any value it can be
self-employed it can be a software
professional banker a teacher doctor so
so many possibilities are there and we
don't know in the given data how many
occupations have been listed right so
that is where you use what is known as
categorical column with hash bucket and
you specify the hash bucket size so what
it what this says is there can be a
maximum of thousand such values so
typically if you give a safe number
safely large number so that you don't
run out of these number of occupations
so i think thousand is a safe number i
don't think there will be more than
thousand occupations in a given data so
that's the idea behind it but that's a
judgment call we need to take what
should be the size of this bucket size
right hash bucket size so these are two
different types for categorical values
for creating the feature column so we
will execute this for all the
categorical columns obviously you need
to know the type of the columns and that
is where if you see right at the
beginning this information was provided
what is the data type and you see here
the column name and what whether it is
continuous or categorical this
information is provided in the census
data wherever we pick this census data
from by the way this was picked from
online from a government website and we
stored locally so on that website it is
mentioned the details of this data were
mentioned and they have mentioned
whether each of these columns is
categorical or continuous so that
information we have to use and we have
to create feature columns using this
categorical method for the categorical
type of columns and then for numeric or
continuous values you just use what is
known as feature column dot numeric
column okay so these are all continuous
or numeric values like age education
number capital gain capital loss hours
per word these are all numerical values
or continuous values right so you just
say tf.feature underscore column dot
numeric underscore column and then give
the name of the column so once you do
that i think i have executed the
previous one yeah this one now so your
feature columns are ready and you need
to basically create a vector of all
these columns and we call that as feet
underscore calls which is which is like
a short form for feature columns now as
you have seen i mentioned earlier also
there are two things that are needed one
is the feature columns and another is
the input function so feature columns to
first create the model and then to train
the model you need to create an input
function so now we have the feature
columns ready next is to create an input
function and there is a certain way in
which you need to
this construct is pretty much very
common construct so we will use that so
the input function takes these x and y
values for training and tests you
remember these are the x strain is the x
values of the training data set and y
train is the labels of the training data
set so that's what we are using here x
train y train and then we specify what
is the batch size batch size you
remember i mentioned this is what will
say how many records need to be read
each time right so typically in when we
are doing the training process we don't
get the entire data in one shot we do it
in batches so what size you specify here
number of epochs in this case we just
say none but number of epochs is again
probably the definition is not required
here but at a very high level how many
times the entire data has to be passed
through the model right so if you have
thousand records and you pass all the
thousand records
three times for training purpose then
you call that as three epochs right so
there is a difference between the batch
size and epochs so when let's say we
have thousand records and you're saying
batch size is hundred that means there
will be ten batches right so if you take
ten batches then that is one epoch gets
completed okay then you the training
obviously doesn't get completed in one
round okay so you need to pass this data
again maybe a second time or a third
time till you get the right accuracy
that is known as epochs okay again if
you need more details about this you may
have to go through the machine learning
tutorial i think it becomes much clearer
okay so you have your input function as
well let's execute that okay and now we
are ready to create the use the api
right so what will we do we will create
the linear classifier using
tf.estimator.linearclassifier
and this guy needs feature columns right
so that's why we created we did all that
so much of
manipulations to create this feature
columns so we have feature columns so we
pass that and we create our model there
may be a few warnings don't worry about
that so we will just ignore that and now
we use that model and we actually what
we did is we created an instance of the
model we have not really run anything we
just created a instance of the model now
we will create the node for training so
model.train and this needs the input
function remember we we created the
input function so we need to pass the
input function and then we say
the steps is now telling how many
iterations this training
has to be run so we are saying 5000 and
this may be it will probably take a
little long so we will okay but that's
fine i think we will leave it 5000.
sometimes if you have probably a less
powerful machine you can cut it down to
maybe thousand or something like that
but in this case i have a fairly
powerful system so i think it shouldn't
take much long let's
go ahead and give a couple of minutes
for it to get over okay so let us go
back yeah i think this is done you see
here the the hourglass has
disappeared that means this computation
is done yes okay this is done right
saving checkpoint for 5000 that means it
is done so training is done so now what
we have to do we need to do the
evaluation so
again this is a standard machine
learning method so
methodology rather so training has been
done with the training data set now you
need to evaluate using your test data
set so that's what we are doing here for
example you see here x underscore test
is your the test data set remember we
used scikit-learn to split the data into
training and test data set so x
underscore test and a quick question why
are we not using y underscore test here
like we did in case of uh training
obviously we are expecting the model to
predict the values y values right so
that's why we don't pass the y values
here all right so let's execute this for
doing the evaluation all right and then
we
put them in a proper format because the
output doesn't come out in a proper
format so we put it in a list format and
then we can just check yeah so this is
done and
we can check what is the first element
in this what is the probabilities and so
on so it's just
a quick way to see if the values are
there or not you can take any value here
right any element here all right now
that the testing is done what we need to
do again we will probably put them in
some kind of this is more of a
formatting thing we will just uh
run through quickly and then we will use
once again scikit-learn for finding out
the accuracy and so on because
scikit-learn offers what is known as a
classification report functionality so
we will use that and find out how well
our model has performed so you see here
again people with
machine learning background will be
immediately able to recognize this so it
gives us what is the precision what is
the recall and f1 score
this is pretty much like you're getting
like almost 85 percent accuracy which is
pretty okay and
there are other ways to increase the
accuracy for example you can run the
training for more iterations that is one
way get more data and so on and so forth
or use a this is a linear classifier we
could you have used a non-linear
classifier and so on so again multiple
ways of doing it to increase the
accuracy but the idea here was to
quickly show you a piece of
tensorflow code and that's what we have
done here we had the original tensorflow
release of 1.0 and then they came out
with the 2.0 version and the 2.0
addressed so many things out there that
the 1.0 really needed so we start
talking about tensorflow 1.0 versus 2.0
i guess you would need to know this for
a legacy programming job if you're
pulling apart somebody else's code the
first thing is that tensorflow 2.0
supports eager execution by default it
allows you to build your models and run
them instantly and you can see here from
tensorflow 1 to tensorflow 2
we have
almost double the code to do the same
thing so if i want to do with tf.session
or tensorflow session as a session the
session run you have your variables your
session run you have your tables
initializer and then you do your model
fit
x train y train and then your validation
data your x value y value and your epics
and your batch size all that goes into
the fit
and you can see here where that was all
just compressed to make it run easier
you can just create a model and do a fit
on it
and you only have like that last set of
code on there so it's automatic that's
what they mean by the eager so if you
see the first part you're like what the
heck is all the session thing going on
that's tensorflow 1.0 and then when you
get into 2.0 it's just nice and clean
if you remember from the beginning i
said cross
on our list up there
and cross is the high level api in
tensorflow 2.0
cross is the official high level api of
tensorflow 2.0 it has incorporated cross
as tf.caras cross provides a number of
model building apis such as sequential
functional and subclassing so you can
choose the right level of abstraction
for your project and
we'll hopefully touch base a little bit
more on this sequential being the most
common uh form that is your your
layers are going from one side to the
other so everything's going in a
sequential order
functional
is where you can split the layers so you
might have your input coming on one side
it splits into two completely mod
different models and then they come back
together
and one of them might be doing
classification the other one might be
doing just linear regression kind of
stuff or a neural basic
reverse propagation neural network and
then those all come together into
another layer which is your
neural network reverse propagation setup
subclassing
is the most complicated as you're
building your own models and you can
subclass your own models into cross so
very powerful tools here this is all the
stuff that's been coming out currently
in the tensorflow cross setup a third
big change we're going to look at is it
in tensorflow 1.0
in order to use tf layers as variables
you would have to write tf variable
block so you'd have to predefine that
in tensorflow 2 you just add your layers
in under the sequential and it
automatically defines them as long as
they're flat layers
of course this changes a little bit as
the more complicated
tensor you have coming in but all of
it's very easy to do and that's what 2.0
does a really good job of and here we
have
a little bit more on the scope of this
and you can see how tensorflow 1 asks
you to do
these different layers and values if you
look at the scope and the default name
you start looking at all the different
code in there to create the variable
scope that's not even necessary in
tensorf 2.0 so you'd have to do one
before you do do what you see the code
in 2.0 in 2.0 you just create your model
it's a sequential model and then you can
add all your layers in you don't have to
pre-create the
variable scope so if you ever see the
variable scope you know that came from
an older version and then we have the
last two which is our api cleanup and
the autograph
in the api cleanup tensorflow 1 you
could build models using tf gans tf app
tf contrib tf flags etc in tensorflow 2
a lot of apis have been removed and this
is just they just cleaned them up
because people weren't using them and
they've simplified them and that's your
tf app your tf flags your tf logging are
all gone
so there's those are three legacy
features that are not in 2.0 and then we
have our tf function and autograph
feature in the old version tensorflow 1
0 the python functions were limited and
could not be compiled or exported
re-imported
so you were continually having to redo
your code you couldn't very easily just
put a pointer to it and say hey let's
reuse this
in tensorflow 2 you can write a python
function using the tf function to mark
it for the jit compilation for the
python jit so that tensorflow runs it as
a single graph autograph feature of tf
function helps to write graph code using
natural python syntax
now we just threw in a new word in you
graph a graph is not a picture of a
person
you'll hear graph x and some other
things graph is what are all those lines
that are connecting different objects so
if you remember from before where we had
the different layers going through
sequentially each one of those white
lined arrows would be a graph x that's
where that computation is taken care of
and that's what they're talking about
and so if you had your own special code
or python way that you're sending that
information forward you can now put your
own function in there instead of using
whatever function they're using
in neural networks this would be your
activation function although it could be
almost anything out there depending on
what you're doing next let's go for
hierarchy and architecture and then
we'll cover three basic tools in
tensorflow before we roll up our sleeves
and dive into the example so let's just
take a quick look at tensorflow toolkits
in their hierarchy at the high level we
have our object oriented api so this is
what you're working with you have your
tf cross you have your estimators this
sits on top of your tf layers tf losses
tf metrics so you have your reusable
libraries for model building this is
really where tensorflow shines is
between the cross
running your estimators and then being
able to swap in different layers you can
your losses your metrics all of that is
so built into tensorflow makes it really
easy to use and then you can get down to
your low level tf api
you have extensive control over this you
can put your own formulas in there your
own procedures or models in there uh you
could have it split we talked about that
earlier so with the 2.0 you can now have
it split one direction we do a linear
regression model and then go to the
other where it does a neural network and
maybe each neural network has a
different activation set on it and then
it comes together into another layer
which is another neural network so you
can build these really complicated
models and at the low level you can put
in your own apis you can move that stuff
around and most recently we have the tf
code can run on multiple platforms
and so you have your cpu
which is
basically like on the computer i'm
running on i have
eight cores and 16 dedicated threads i
hear they now have one out there that
has over 100 cores
so you have your cpu running and then
you have your gpu which is your graphics
card
and most recently they also include the
tpu setup which is specifically for
tensorflow models
neural network kind of setup
so now you can export the tf code and it
can run on all kinds of different
platforms for the most
diverse setup out there and moving on
from the hierarchy to the architecture
in the tensorflow 2.0 architecture
we have
you can see on the left this is usually
where you start out with and 80 of your
time in data science is spent
pre-processing data making sure it's
loaded correctly and everything looks
right
so the first level in tensorflow is
going to be your read and pre-processed
data your tf data feature columns
this is going to feed into your tf cross
or your pre-made estimators
and kind of you have your tensorflow hub
that sits on top of there so you can see
what's going on
once you have all that set up you have
your distribution strategy where are you
going to run it are you going to be
running it on just your regular cpu are
you going to be running it with the gpu
added in
like i have a pretty high-end graphics
card so it actually grabs that gpu
processor and uses it or do you have a
specialized tpu set up in there that you
paid extra money for
it could be if you're
in later on when you're distributing the
package you might need to run this on
some really high processors because
you're processing at a server level for
let's say net you might be processing
this at a
distribute you're distributing it not
the distribution strategy but you're
distributing it into a server where that
server might be analyzing thousands and
thousands of purchases done
every minute
and so you need that higher speed to
give them a um to give them a
recommendation or a suggestion so they
can buy more stuff off your website or
maybe you're looking for
data fraud analysis working with the
banks you want to be able to run this at
a high speed so that when you have
hundreds of people
sending their transactions in it says
hey this doesn't look right someone's
scamming this person and probably has
their credit card so when we're talking
about all those fun things we're talking
about saved model this is we were
talking about that earlier where it used
to be when you did one of these models
it wouldn't truncate the float numbers
the same and so a model going from one
you build the model on your
machine in the office and then you need
to distribute it and so we have our
tensorflow serving cloud on premium
that's what i was talking about if
you're like a banking or something like
that
now they have tensorflow lite so you can
actually run a tensorflow on an android
or an ios or raspberry pi a little
breakout board there in fact they just
came out with a new one that has a
built-in there's just a little mini tpu
with the camera on it so it can
pre-process a video so you can load your
tensorflow model on to that
um talking about an affordable way to
beta test a new product you have the
tensorflow js which is for browser and
node server so you can get that out on
the browser for some simple computations
that don't require a lot of heavy
lifting but you want to distribute to a
lot of end points and now they also have
other language bindings so you can now
create your tensorflow backend save it
and have it accessed from c java go
c sharp rust r or from whatever package
you're working on so we kind of have an
overview of the architecture and what's
going on behind the scenes and in this
case what's going on as far as
distributing it let's go ahead and take
a look at three specific pieces of
tensorflow
and those are going to be constants
variables and sessions
so very basic things you need to know
and understand when you're working with
the tensorflow
setup so constants in tensorflow in
tensorflow constants are created using
the function constant in other words
they're going to stay static the whole
time whatever you're working with the
syntax for constant
value d type 9 shape equals none name
constant verify shape equals false
that's kind of the syntax you're looking
at and we'll explore this with our hands
on a little more in depth
and you can see here we do z equals t f
dot constant 5.2 name equals x
d type is a float that means that we're
never going to change that 5.2 it's
going to be a constant value and then we
have our variables in tensorflow
variables in tensorflow are in memory
buffers that store tensors
and so we can declare a two by three
tensor populated by ones you could also
do constants this way by the way you can
create a an array of ones for your
constants i'm not sure why you'd do that
but you know you might need that for
some reason
in here we have v equals tf.variables
and then in tensorflow you have tf.ones
and you have the shape which is 2 3
which is then going to create a nice 2
by 3
array that's filled with ones and then
of course you can go in there and
they're variables so you can change them
it's a tensor so you have full control
over that and then you of course have
sessions in tensorflow a session in
tensorflow is used to run a
computational graph to evaluate the
nodes
and remember when we're talking a graph
or graph x we're talking about all that
information then goes through all those
arrows and whatever computations they
have that take it to the next node and
you can see down here where we have
import tensorflow as tf if we do x
equals a tf.constant of 10
we do y equals a tf constant of 2.0 or
20.0 and then you can do z equals
tf.variable
and it's a tf.ad x comma y
and then once you have that set up in
there you go ahead and knit your tf
global variables initializer with tf
session as session you can do a session
run init
and then you print the session run y
uh and so when you run this you're going
to end up with of course the 10 plus 20
is 30. and we'll be looking at this a
lot more closely as we actually roll up
our sleeves and put some code together
so let's go ahead and take a look at
that and for my coding today i'm going
to go ahead and go through anaconda and
then i'll use specifically the jupiter
notebook on there and of course this
code is going to work uh whatever
platform you choose whether you're in a
notebook
the jupiter lab which is just a jupiter
notebook but with tabs for larger
projects we're going to stick with
jupiter notebook
pycharm whatever it is you're going to
use in here you have your spider and
your qt console for different
programming environments the thing to
note
is kind of hard to see but i have my
main
pi 3 6.
right now when i was writing this
tensorflow works in python version 3 6.
if you have python version 37 or 38
you're probably going to get some errors
in there
might be that they've already updated
and i don't know it now you have an
older version
but you want to make sure you're in
python version 3 6 in your environment
and of course in anaconda i can easily
set that environment up make sure you go
ahead and
pip in your
tensor flow or if you're in anaconda you
can do a conda install tensorflow to
make sure it's in your package
so let's just go ahead and dive in and
bring that up
this will open up a nice browser window
i just love the fact i can zoom in and
zoom out depending on what i'm working
on making it really easy to just um
demo for the right size go under new and
let's go ahead and create a new python
and once we're in our new python window
this is going to leave it untitled
let's go ahead and import import
tensorflow as tf
at this point we'll go ahead and just
run it real quick
no errors yay no errors
i
i do that whenever i do my imports
because i unbearably will have opened up
a new environment and forgotten to
install tensorflow into that environment
uh or something along those lines so
it's always good to double check
uh and if we're going to double check
that we also it's also good to know uh
what version we're working with
and we can do that simply by
using the version command in tensorflow
which you should know is is probably
intuitively the tf
dot underscore underscore version
underscore underscore
and
you know it always confuses me because
sometimes you do tf.version for one
thing you do tf dot underscore version
underscore for another thing
this is a double underscore in
tensorflow for pulling your version out
and it's good to know what you're
working with we're going to be working
in tensorflow version 2.1.0 and i did
tell you the the um we were going to dig
a little deeper into our constants and
you can do an array of constants and
we'll just create this nice array
a equals tf.constant
and we're just going to put the array
right in there 4361.
we can run this and now that is what a
is equal to and if we want to just
double check that remember we're in
jupiter notebook where i can just put
the letter a
and it knows that that's going to be
print
otherwise you round you surround it in
print and you can see it's a tf tensor
it has the shape the type and the and
the array on here it's a two by two
array and just like we can create a
constant we can go and create a variable
and this is also going to be a two by
two array and if we go ahead and print
the v out we'll run that
and sure enough there's our tf variable
in here
then we can also let's just go back up
here and add this in here
i could create another tensor and we'll
make it a constant this time
and we're going to put that in over here
we'll have b tf constant
and if we go and print out v and b
we're going to run that
and this is an interesting thing that
always that happens in here you'll see
right here when i print them both out
what happens it only prints the last one
unless you use print commands so
important to remember that in jupyter
notebooks we can easily fix that by go
ahead and print and surround v with
brackets and now we can see with the two
different variables we have uh we have
the three one five two which is a
variable and this is just a flat
constant so it comes up as a tf tensor
shape two kind of two and that's
interesting to note that this label is a
tf.tensor and this is a tf variable
so that's how it's looking in the back
end when you're talking about the
difference between a variable and a
constant
the other thing i want you to notice is
that in variable we capitalize the v and
with the constant we have a lowercase c
little things like that can lose you
when you're programming and you're
trying to find out hey why doesn't this
work
so those are a couple of things to note
in here
and just like any other array in math
we can do like a concatenate or
concatenate the different values here
and you can see we can take a b
concatenated you just do a tf.concat
values and there's our a b axes on one
hopefully you're familiar with axes and
how that works when you're dealing with
matrixes and if we go ahead and print
this out
you'll see right here we end up with a
tensor so let's put it in as a constant
not as a variable
and you have your array four three seven
eight and six one four five it's
concatenated the two together and again
i wanna highlight a couple things on
this our axes equals one this means
we're doing the columns um so if you had
a longer array like right now we have an
array that is like you know has a shape
one whatever it is two comma two
um axes
zero
is going to be your first one and axes
one is going to be your second one and
it translates as columns and rows if we
had a shape let me just put the word
shape here
um
so you know what i'm talking about is
very clear and this is i'll tell you
what i spend a lot of time
looking at these shapes and trying to
figure out which direction i'm going in
and whether to flip it or whatever
so you can get lost in which way your
matrix is going which is column which is
rows are you dealing with the third axes
or the second axes
axis one you know zero one two that's
going to be our columns uh and if you
can do columns then we also can do rows
and that is simply just changing the
concatenate we'll just grab this one
here and copy it we'll do the whole
thing over
ctrl copy
ctrl v and changes from axis 1
to axis 0 and if we run that
you'll see that now we concatenate by
row as opposed to column
and you have four three six one seven
eight four seven so it just brings it
right down and turns it into rows versus
columns you can see the difference there
your output this really you want to look
at the output sometimes just to make
sure your eyes are looking at it
correctly and it's in the format i find
visually looking at it is almost more
important than
understanding what's going on because
conceptually your mind just just too
many dimensions sometimes
the second thing i want you to notice is
this says a numpy array
so tensorflow is utilizing numpy as part
of their format as far as python is
concerned
and so you can treat you can treat this
output like a numpy array because it is
just that it's going to be a numpy array
another thing that comes up uh more than
you would think is filling uh one of
these with zeros or ones and so you can
see here we just create a tensor tf.0
and we give it a shape we tell it what
kind of data type it is in this case
we're doing an integer
and then if we
print out our tensor again we're in
jupiter so i just type out tensor and i
run this you can see i have a nice array
of with shape 3 comma 4 of 0s one of the
things i want to highlight here is
integer 32 if i go to the
tensorflow data types i want you to
notice how
we have float 16 float 32 float 64
complex if we scroll down you'll see the
integer down here 32 the reason for this
is that we want to control how many bits
are used in the precision this is for
exporting it to another platform
so what would happen is i might run it
on this computer where python goes does
a float to indefinite however long it
wants to
and then we can take it but we want to
actually say hey we don't want that high
precision we want to be able to run this
on any computer
and so we need to control whether it's a
tf float 16 in this case we did an
integer 32
we could also do this as a float
so if i run this as a float 32
that means this has a 32-bit precision
you'll see zero point whatever and then
to go with zeros
we have ones if we're going from the
opposite side and so we can easily just
create a tensorflow with ones
and you might ask yourself why would i
want zeros and ones and your first
thought might be to initiate a new
tensor
usually we initiate a lot of this stuff
with random numbers because it does a
better job solving it if you start with
a uniform set of ones or zeros you're
dealing with a lot of bias so be very
careful about starting a neural network
for one of your rows or something like
that with ones and zeros
on the other hand
i use this for masking you can do a lot
of work with masking you can also have
it might be that
one tensor row is masked
you know zero is is false one is true or
whatever you want to do it
and so in that case you do want to use
the zeros and ones and there are cases
where you do want to initialize it with
all zeros or all ones and then swap in
different numbers as a as the tensor
learns so it's another form of control
but in general you see zeros and ones
you usually are talking about a mask
over another array and just like in uh
numpy you can also
do reshapes so if we take our remember
this is shaped three comma four maybe we
to swap that to four comma three
and if we print this out
you will see let me just go and do that
ctrl v
let me run that
and you'll see that the the order of
these is now switched instead of four
across now we have three across and four
down
and just for fun let's go back up here
where we did the ones
and i'm going to change the ones to
tf.random uniform
and we'll go ahead and just take off
well we'll go and leave that we'll go
ahead and run this
and you'll see now we have 0.0441
and this way you can actually see how
the reshape looks a lot different
0.041.15.71
and then instead of having this one it
rolls down here to the 0.14
and this is what i was talking about
sometimes you fill a lot of times you
fill these with random numbers and so
this is the random dot uniform is one of
the ways to do that now i just talked a
little bit about this float 32 and all
these data types
one of the things that comes up of
course is
recasting your data
so if we have a d type float 32 we might
want to convert these to integers
because of the project we're working on
i know one of the projects i've worked
on
ended up wanting to do a lot of round
off so that it would take a dollar
amount or a float value and then have to
rent it off to a dollar amount so we
only wanted two decimal points um in
which case you have a lot of different
options you can multiply by 100 and then
round it off or whatever you want to do
there's a lot or then convert it to an
integer was one way to round it off
kind of
a cheap and dirty trick
uh so we can take this and we can take
the same
tensor and we'll go ahead and create a
as an integer and so we're going to take
this tensor we're going to tf.cast it
and if we print
tensor
and then we're going to go ahead and
print
our
tensor
let me just do a quick copy and paste
and when i'm actually programming i
usually type out a lot of my stuff just
to double check it
in doing a demo
copy and paste works fine but sometimes
be aware that copy and paste can copy
the wrong code over
personal choice depends on what i'm
working on
and you can see here we took um a float
32 4.6 4.2 and so on and it just
converts it right down to a integer
value
sorry integer 32 set up and
remember we talked about
a little bit about reshape
as far as flipping it and i just did
four comma three on the reshape up here
and we talked about axes zero axis one
one of the things that is important to
be able to do is to take one of these
variables
we'll just take this last one tensor as
integer
and i want to go ahead and transpose it
and so i can do
we'll do a
equals tf.transpose
and we'll do our tensor integer in there
and then if i print the a out and we run
this
you'll see that's the same array but
we've flipped it so that our columns and
rows are flipped this is
the same as reshaping so when you
transpose you're just doing a reshape
what's nice about this is if you look at
the numbers the columns
when we went up here and we did the
reshape they kind of roll down to the
next row so you're not maintaining the
structure of your matrix so when we do a
reshape up here they're similar but
they're not quite the same and you can
actually go in here and there's settings
in the reshape that would allow you to
turn it into a transform
so when we come down here it's all done
for you and so there are so many times
you have to transpose
your digits that this is important to
know that you can just do that you can
flip your rows and columns rather
quickly here and just like numpy you can
also do multiple your different math
functions we'll look at multiplication
and so we're going to take matrix
multiplication of tensors
we'll go ahead and create a as a
constant 5839
and we'll put in a vector v 4 comma 2.
and we could have done this where they
matched where this was a 2 by 2 array
but instead
we're going to do just a 2 by 1 array
and the code for that is your tf.mat
mole
so matrix multiplier and we have a times
v and if we go ahead and run this up
let's
make sure we print out our av on there
and if we go ahead and run this
you'll see that we end up with 36 by 30.
and if it's been a while since you've
seen the matrix math
this is
5 times 4 plus 8 times two
three times four plus nine times two
and that's where we get the 36 and 30.
now i know we're covering a lot really
quickly as far as the basic
functionality
so the matrix or your matrix multiplier
is a very commonly used back-end tool as
far as computing
different models or linear regression
stuff like that
one of the things is to note is that
just like in
numpy
you have all of your different math so
we have our tf math
and if we go in here we have
functions we have our cosines absolute
angle all of that's in here so all of
these
are available for you to use in the
tensorflow model
and if we go back to our example and
let's go ahead and pull
oh let's do some multiplication that's
always good we'll stick with our
av
our
constant a and our vector v
and we'll go ahead and do some bit wise
multiplication and we'll create an av
which is a times b let's go and print
that out
and you can see coming across here uh we
have the four two and the five eight
three nine and it produces uh 2032 618
and that's pretty straightforward if you
look at it you have 4 times
5 is 20 4 times 8 is
32 that's where those numbers come from
now we can also quickly create an
identity matrix
which is basically
your main values on the diagonal being
ones and zeros across the other side
let's go ahead and take a look and see
what that
uh looks like and we can do let's do
this
so we're going to get the shape this is
a simple way very similar to your numpy
you can do a dot shape and it's going to
return a tuple in this case our rows and
columns and so we can do a quick
print
we'll do rows
and we'll do columns
and if we run this
you can see we have three rows
two columns
and then if we go ahead and create an
identity
matrix
the script for that
got a wrong button there the script for
that looks like
this where we have the number of rows
equals rows the number of columns equals
columns and d type is a 32 and then if
we go ahead and just print out our
identity
you can see we have a nice identity
column with our ones going across here
now clearly we're not going to go
through every math module
available but we do want to start
looking at this as a prediction model
and seeing how it functions
so we're going to move on to a more of a
direct setup we can actually see the
full tensorflow in use for that let's go
back and create a
new setup
and we'll go in here new
python 3 module
there we go
bring this out so it takes up the whole
window because i like to do that
hopefully made it through that first
part and you have a basic understanding
of tensorflow as far as being
a series of numpy arrays you got your
math equations and different things that
go into them
we're going to start building a full
setup as far as the numpy so you can see
how uh kara sits on top of it and the
different aspects of how it works
the first thing we want to do is we're
going to go ahead and do a lot of
imports uh date times warning scipy
scipy is your
math so the back end scientific math
warnings because
whenever we do a lot of this you have
older versions newer versions
and so sometimes when you get warnings
you want to go ahead and just suppress
them
we'll talk about that if it comes up on
this particular setup and of course date
time
pandas again is your data frame think
rows and columns we import it as pd
numpy is your numbers array which of
course tensorflow is integrated heavily
with
seaborn for our graphics and the seaborn
as sns is going to be set on top of our
matplot library which we import as mpl
and then of course we're going to import
our matplot library pie plot as plt and
right off the bat we're going to set
some graphic colors
patch force edge color equals true
the style we're going to use the 538
style you can look this all up there's
when you get into matplot library into
seabourn there are so many options in
here it's just kind of nice to make it
look pretty when we start the um
when we start up that way we don't have
to think about it later on
and then we're going to take we have our
mplrc we're going to put a patch at
color dim gray line width again this is
all part of our graphics here in our
setup we'll go ahead and do an
interactive shell
node interactivity equals last
expression
uh here we are pd for pandas options
display max columns so we don't want to
display more than 50.
and then our map plot library is going
to be inline this is a jupiter notebook
thing the matplot library in line then
warnings we're going to filter our
warnings and we're just going to ignore
warnings that way when they come up we
don't have to worry about them
not really what you want to do when
you're working on a major project you
want to make sure you know those
warnings and then filter them out and
ignore them later on
and if we run this it's just going to be
loading all that into the background
so that's a little back-end kind of
stuff then what we want to go ahead and
do is we want to go ahead and import
our specific packages
that we're going to be working with
which is under keras now remember cross
kind of sits on tensorflow so when we're
importing cross and the sequential model
we are in effect importing
tensorflow underneath of it we just
brought in the math probably should have
put that up above
and then we have our cross models we're
going to import sequential
now if you remember from our
slide there was three different options
let me just flip back over there so we
can have a quick uh recall on that and
so in cross uh we have sequential
functional and subclassing so remember
those three different setups in here we
talked about earlier and if you remember
from here we have a sequential where
it's going
one tensorflow layer at a time you go
kind of look at think of it as going
from left to right or top to bottom or
whatever direction it's going in but it
goes in one direction all the time where
functional can have a very complicated
graph of directions you can have the
data split into two separate
tensors and then it comes back together
into another tensor
all those kinds of things and then
subclassing is really the really
complicated one where now you're adding
your own sub classes into the tensor to
do external computations right in the
middle of like a huge flow of data
but we're going to stick with sequential
it's not a big jump to go from
sequential to functional
but we're running a sequential
tensorflow and that's what this first
import is here we want to bring in our
sequential
and then we have our layers and let's
talk a little bit about these layers
this is where cross and tensorflow
really are happening this is what makes
them so nice to work with is all these
layers are pre-built
so from cross we have layers import
dense
from cross layers import lstm
when we talk about these layers
cross has so many built-in layers you
can do your own layers
the dense layer is your standard neural
network
by default it uses relu for its
activation
and then the lstm is a long short term
memory layer since we're going to be
looking probably at sequential data
we want to go ahead and do the lstm and
if we go into
cross and we look at their layers this
is across website you can see as we
scroll down for the cross layers that
are built in
we can get down here and we can look at
let's see here we have our layer
activation our base layers um activation
layer weight layer waste there's a lot
of stuff in here we had the relu which
is the basic activation that was listed
up here for layer activations you can
change those
and here we have our core layers and our
dense layers we have an input layer a
dense layer
and then we've added a more customized
one with the long-term short-term memory
layer and of course you can even do your
own custom layers in cross there's a
whole functionality in there if you're
doing your own thing
what's really nice about this is it's
all built in even the convolutional
layers this is for processing graphics
there's a lot of cool things in here you
can do this is why cross is so popular
it's open source and you have all these
tools right at your fingertips so from
cross we're just going to import a
couple layers the dense layer
and the long short term memory layer
and then of course from
sk learn our scikit
we want to go ahead and do our min max
scalar standard scalar for pre editing
our
data and then metrics just so we can
take a look at the errors and compute
those let me go ahead and run this and
that just loads it up we're not
expecting anything from the output and
our file coming in is going to be air
quality.csv and let's go ahead and take
a quick look at that this is in open
office it's just a standard you know mic
can do excel whatever you're using for
your spreadsheet and you can see here we
have a number of columns a number of
rows it actually goes down to like 8
000.
the first thing we want to notice is
that the first row
is kind of just a random number put in
going down probably not something we're
going to work with
the second row
is bendung i'm guessing that's a
reference for the profile
if we scroll to the bottom which i'm not
going to do because it takes forever to
get back up they're all the same uh the
same thing with the status the status is
the same
we have a date so we have a sequential
order here
um here is the jam which i'm going to
guess is the time stamp on there so we
have a date and time we have our o3 co
no2 reading so2 no co2
voc
and then some other numbers here pm1 pm
2.5 pm 4 pm 10
10 without actually
looking through the data i mean some of
this i can guess is like temperature
humidity i'm not sure what the pms are
but we have a whole slew of data here so
we're looking at air quality as far as
an area in a region and what's going on
with our date time stamps on there and
so code wise we're going to read this
into a pandas data frame so our data
frame df is a nice abbreviation commonly
used for data frames equals pd.read csv
and then our the path to it just happens
to be on my d drive
separated by spaces and so if we go
ahead and run this
we'll print out the head of our data and
again this looks very similar to what we
were just looking at
being in jupiter i can take this and go
the other way
make it real small so you can see all
the columns going across and we get a
full view of it
or we can bring it back up in size
that's pretty small on there overshot
but you can see it's the same data we
were just looking at we're looking at
the number we're looking at the profile
which is the bandung
the
date we have a timestamp
our o3 count co and so forth on here and
this is just your basic
pandas printing out the top five rows we
could easily have done
three rows
five rows ten whatever you want to put
in there by default that's five for
pandas now i talk about this all the
time so i know i've already said it at
least once or twice during this video
most of our work is in pre-formatting
data what are we looking at how do we
bring it together
so we want to go ahead and start with
our date time it's come in in two
columns
we have our date here and we have our
time
and we want to go ahead and combine that
and then we have this is just a simple
script in there that says combine date
time that's our formula we're building
our we're going to submit our
pandas data frame
and the tab name when we go ahead and do
this
that's all of our information that we
want to go ahead and create
and then goes for i in range df
shape 0
so we're going to go through
the whole setup and we're going to list
tab append df location i
and here is our date going in there and
then return the numpy array list tab d
types date time 64. that's all we're
doing we're just switching this to a
date time stamp and if we go ahead and
do df date time equals combine date time
and then i always like to
print we'll do df head
just so we can see what that looks like
and so when we come out of this uh we
now have our setup on here and of course
it's added it on to the far right here's
our date time you can see the formats
changed uh so there's our we've added in
the date time column and we've brought
the date over and we've taken this
format here
and it's an actual variable with a 0 0 0
on here well that doesn't look good so
we need to also include the time part of
this and we want to convert it into
hourly data
so let's go ahead and do that
to do that to finish combining our date
time let's go ahead and create a
little
script here to combine the time in there
same thing we just did we're just
creating a numpy array returning a numpy
array and cr forcing this into a date
time format and we can actually spend
hours just going through
these conversions how do you
pull it from the panda's data frame how
do you set it up
so i'm kind of skipping through it a
little fast because i want to stay
focused on tensorflow and cross
keep in mind this is like 80 of your
coding when you're doing a lot of this
stuff is going to be reformatting these
things resetting them back up
so that it looks right on here and you
know it just takes time to get through
all that but that is usually what the
companies are paying you for that's what
the big
bucks are for
and we want to go ahead and a couple
things going on here is we're going to
go ahead and do our date time we're
going to reorganize some of our setup in
here convert into hourly data we just
put a pause in there
now remember we can select from df are
different columns we're going to be
working with and you're going to see
that we actually dropped
a couple of the columns those ones i
showed you earlier they're just
repetitive data so there's nothing in
there that exciting
and then we want to go ahead and we'll
create a
second
data frame here let me just get rid of
the df head
and df2 is we're going to group by date
time and we're looking at the mean value
and then we'll print that out so you can
see we're talking about
we have now reorganized this so we put
in date time 03 co
so now this is in the same order
as it was before and you'll see the date
time
now has our 0 0
same date 1 2 3 and so on so let's group
the data together so there's a lot more
manageable and in the format we want and
in the right sequential order
and if we go back to
there we go our air quality
you can see right here we're looking at
these columns going across we really
don't need since we're going to create
our own
date time column we can get rid of those
these are the different columns of
information we want and that should
reflect right here in the columns we
picked coming across so this is all the
same columns on there that's all we've
done is reformatted our data
grouped it together by date and then you
can see the different data coming out
set up on there and then as a data
scientist
first thing i want to do is get a
description what am i looking at uh and
so we can go ahead and do the df2
describe and this gives us our you know
describe gives us our basic data
analytics information we might be
looking for like what is the mean
standard deviation
uh minimum amount maximum amount we have
our first quarter second quarter and
third quarter
numbers also in there uh so you can get
a quick look at a glance describing the
data or descriptive analysis
and even though we have our quantile
information in here we're going to dig a
little deeper into that
we're going to calculate the quantile
for each variable uh we're going to look
at a number of things for each variable
and we'll see right here q1 uh we can
simply do the quantile 0.25 percent
which should match um our 25 up here and
we'll be looking at the min the max
and we're just going to do this
basically we're breaking this down for
each uh different
variable in there
one of the things is kind of fun to do
we're going to look at that in just a
second let me get put the next piece of
code in here um we gotta clean out some
of our um we're gonna drop a couple
thing our
last rows and first row because those
have
usually have a lot of null values in the
first row is just our titles uh so
that's important it's important to drop
those rows in here and so this right
here as we look at our different
quantiles
again it's it's the same you know we're
still looking at the 25
quantile here
we're going to do a little bit more with
this
so now that we've cleared off our first
and last rows we're going to go ahead
and go through
all of our columns and this way we can
look at each
column individually and so we'll
just create a q1 q3 min max min iqr max
iqr
and calculate the quantile of i of df2
we're basically doing
the math that they did up here but we're
splitting it apart
that's all this is and
this happens a lot because you might
want to look at individual if this was
my own project i would probably spend
days and days going through
what these different values mean
one of the biggest
data science uh
things we can look at that's important
is uh use your use your common sense
you know if you're looking at this data
and it doesn't make sense and you go
back in there and you're like wait a
minute what the heck did i just do
at that point you probably should go
back and double check what you have
going on
now uh we're looking at this and you can
see right here here's our attribute for
our o3 so we've broken it down
we have our q1 5.88 q3 10.37 if we go
back up here here's our 5 8 we've
rounded it off
10.37 is in there
so we've basically done the same math
just split it up we have our minimum and
our max iqr and that's computed let's
see where is it here we go uh q1 minus
1.5 times iqr and the iqr is your q3
minus q1 so that's the difference
between our two different quarters and
this is all
data science
as far as the hard math
we're really not we're actually trying
to focus on cross and tensorflow you've
still got to go through all this stuff i
told you 80 percent of your programming
is going through and understanding what
the heck
uh happened here
what's going on what does this data mean
and so when we're looking in that we're
going to go ahead and say hey um
we've computed these numbers and the
reason we've computed these numbers is
if you take the minimum value and it's
less than your minimum iqr
that means something's going wrong there
and they usually in this case is going
to show us an outlier
so we want to go ahead and find the
minimum value if it's less than the min
minimum iqr it's an outlier and if the
max value is greater than the
max iqr we have an outlier and that's
all this is doing low outliers found
minimum value high outliers found
really important actually outliers are
almost everything in data sometimes
sometimes you do this project just to
find the outliers because you want to
know
crime detection what are we looking for
we're looking for the outliers what
doesn't fit a normal business deal and
then we'll go ahead and throw in
just threw in a lot of code oh my
goodness uh so we have if your max is
greater than iqr print outlier is found
what we want to do is we want to start
cleaning up these outliers and so we
want to convert
we'll do create a convert nand
x max iqr equals max
underscore iqr min iqr equals mini qr so
this is just saying this is the data
we're going to send that's all that is
in python and if x is greater than the
max iqr and x is less than the min iq
are x equals
null we're going to set it to null why
because we want to clear
these outliers out of the data now again
if you're doing fraud detection you
would do the opposite you would be
cleaning everything else that's not in
that series so that you can look at just
the outlier and then we're going to
convert the nand hum again we have x
max iqr is 100
min iqr is men iqr
if x is greater than max iqr and x is
less than min iqr again we're going to
return a null value otherwise it's going
to remain the same value x x equals x
and you can see as we go through the
code if i equals
our hum
then we go ahead and do this
that's a column specific to humidity
that's your hum column
uh then we're going to go ahead and
convert do the
run a map on there and convert the non
hum
you can see here it's this is just
cleanup uh we run we found out that
humidity probably has some weird values
in it
we have our outliers
that's all this is
and so when we go ahead and finish this
and we take a look at our outliers
and we run this code here
we have a low outlier 2.04 we have a
high outlier
99.06
outliers have been interpolated
that means we've given them a new value
chances are these days when you're
looking at something like
these sensors coming in
they probably have a failed sensor in
there something went wrong
that's the kind of thing that you really
don't want to do your data analysis on
so that's what we're doing is we're
pulling that out and then
converting it over and setting it up
method linear
so we interpolate let the linears it's
going to fill that data in
based on a linear regression model of
similar data
same thing with this up here with the
df2i interpolate that's what we're doing
again this is all data prep
we're not actually talking about
tensorflow we're just trying to get all
our data
set up correctly so that when we run it
it's not going to cause problems or have
a huge bias
so we've dealt with outliers
specifically in humidity
and again this is one of these things
where when we start running
we run through this you can see down
here that we have our
outliers found
high low outliers
migrated them in we also know there's
other issues going on with this data
how do we know that
some of it's just looking at the data
playing with it until you start
understanding what's going on let's take
the temp value
and we're going to go ahead and and use
a logarithmic function on the temp value
and
it's interesting because it's like how
do you how do you have to even know to
use logarithmic on the temp value that's
domain specific
we're talking about being an expert in
air care i'm not an expert in air care
um you know it's not what i go look at i
don't look at air care data in fact this
is probably the first air care data set
up i've looked at but the experts come
in there and they come to you and say
hey in data science this is a
exponentially variable variable on here
so we need to go ahead and do
transform it
and use a logarithmic scale on that
so at that point that would be coming
from your
data here we go data science programmer
overview does a lot of stuff connecting
the database and connecting in with the
experts
data analytics a lot of times you're
talking about somebody who is a data
analysis might be all the way usually a
phd level
data science programming level
interfaces database manager that's going
to be the person who's your admin
working on it
so when we're looking at this we're
looking at something they've sent to me
and they said hey
domain air care
this needs to be this is a skew because
the data just goes up exponentially and
affects everything else and we'll go
ahead and take that data
let me just go ahead and run this
just for another quick look at it
we have our
uh we'll do a distribution df
we'll create another data frame from the
temp values and then from a data set
from the log temp so we can put them
side by side
and we'll just go ahead and do a quick
histogram and this is kind of nice plot
of figure figure size here's our plt
from matplot library
and then we'll just do a distribution
underscore df there's our data frames
this is nice because it just integrates
the histogram right into pandas love
pandas
and this is a chart you would send back
to your data analysis and say hey is
this what you wanted this is how the
data is converting on here as a data
sciences scientist the first thing i
note is we've gone from a 10 20 30 scale
to 2.5 3.0 3.5 scale
and the data itself has kind of been
adjusted a little bit based on some kind
of a skew on there so let's jump into
we're getting a little closer to
actually doing our
cross on here
we'll go ahead and split our data up
and this of course is any good data
scientists
you want to have a training set and a
test set uh
and we'll go ahead and do the train size
we're going to use 0.75 of the data make
sure it's an integer you don't want to
take a slice as a float value give you a
nice error
uh and we'll have our train size of 75
percent and the test size is going to be
of course the train size minus the
length of the data set and then we can
simply do train comma test
here's our data set
which is going to be the train size the
test size
and then if we go and print this let me
just go ahead and run this we can see
how these values
split it's a nice split of 1298 and then
433 points of value
that are going to be for our
setup on here and if you remember we're
specifically looking at the data set
where did we create that data set from
that was from up here that's what we
called the
logarithmic
value of the temp
that's where the data set came from so
we're looking at just that column with
this train size and the test with the
train and test data set here and let's
go ahead and do a convert an array of
values into a data set matrix we're
going to create a little
setup in here we create our data set our
data set's going to come in we're going
to do a look back of one so we're going
to look back one piece of data going
backward
and we have our data x and our data y
for i and range length of data set look
back -1
this is creating let me just go ahead
and run this actually the best way to do
this
is to go ahead and create this data
and take a look at the shape of it let
me go ahead and just put that code in
here
so we're going to do a lookbeck one
here's our train x our train y and it's
going to be adding the data on there and
then when we come up here
and we take a look at the shape there we
go
and we run this piece of code here
we look at the shape on this and we have
a new slightly different change on here
but we have a shape of x 1296 comma 1
shape of y train y
test x text y
and so what we're looking at is that
the x comes in
and we're only having a single value at
out
we want to predict what the next one is
that's what this little piece of code is
here for what are we looking for well we
want to look back one that's the um what
we're going to train the data with is
yesterday's data yesterday says hey the
humidity was at
97 percent what should today's humidity
be at if it's 97 yesterday is it going
to go up or is it going to go down today
if 97 does it go up to 100 what's going
on there uh and so our
we're looking forward to the next piece
of data which says hey tomorrow's is
going to you know today's humidity is
this this is what tomorrow's humidity is
going to be
that's all that is all that is is
stacking our data so that
our y is basically
x plus 1 or x could be y minus 1.
and then a couple things to note is our
x data
we're only dealing with the one column
but you need to have it in a shape that
has it by the columns so you have the
two different numbers and since we're
doing just a single point of data
we have and you'll see with the train y
we don't need to have the extra shape on
here
now this is going to run into a problem
and the reason is is that we have what
they call a time step
and the time step is that long-term
short-term memory layer
uh so we're going to add another reshape
on here let me just go down here and put
it into the next cell
and so we want to reshape the input
array in the form of sample time step
features
we're only looking at one feature
and i mean this is one of those things
when you're playing with this you're
like why am i getting an error in the
numpy array why is this giving me
something weird going on uh so we're
going to do is we're going to add one
more
level on here instead of being 12.99 one
we want to go one more
and when they put the code together in
the back you can see we kept the same
shape the 1299
we added the one dimension and then we
have our train x shape one
and this could have depends again on how
far back in the long short term memory
you want to go
that is what that piece of code is for
and that reshape is and you can see the
new shape is now one uh
1299 one one uh versus the 1299 one and
then the other part of the shape 432 one
one again this is our tr our x in and of
course our test x and then our y is just
a single column because we're just doing
one output that we're looking for
so now we've done our 80 percent um you
know that's all the the
writing all the code reformatting our
data
bringing it in now we want to go ahead
and do the fun part which is we're going
to go ahead and create and fit
the lstm neural network
and if we're going to do that the first
thing we need is we're going to need to
go ahead and create a model and we'll do
this sequential model
and if you remember sequential means it
just goes in order that means we have if
you have two layers the layers go from
layer one to layer two or layer zero to
layer one
this is different than functional
functional allows you to split the data
and run two completely separate models
and then bring them back together
we're doing just sequential on here and
then we decided to do the long short
term memory
and we have our input shape uh which it
comes in again this is what all this
switching was we could have easily made
this uh one two three or four going back
as far as the end number on there we
just stuck to going back one
and it's always a good idea when you get
to this point where the heck
is this model coming from
what kind of models do we have available
and there's let me go and put the next
model in there
because we're going to do two models and
the next model is going to go ahead and
we're going to do dent so we have model
equal sequential
and then we're going to add the lstm
model and then we're going to add a
dense model and if you remember from the
very top of our code
where we did the imports oops there we
go our cross this is it right here
here's our importing a dense model and
here's our importing an lstm now just
about every tensorflow model uses dents
your dense model is your basic
forward propagation reverse propagation
error or it does reverse propagation to
program the model
so any of your neural networks that
you've already looked at that
luxon says here's the error and sends
the air backwards that's what this is
the long short term memory is a little
different
the real question that we want to look
at right now is where do you find these
models what kind of models do you have
available and so for that let's go to
the cross website
which is the cross dot io if you go
under api slash layers and i always have
to do a search
just search for cross api layers it'll
open up and you can see we have
your base layers right here class
trainable
weights all kinds of stuff like there
your activation
so a lot of your layers you can switch
how it activates uh relu which is like
your smaller arrays or if you're doing
convolutional neural networks the
convolution usually uses a relu your
sigmoid all the way up to soft mac soft
plus all these different choices as far
as how those are set up and what we want
to do is we want to go ahead and if you
scroll down here you'll see your core
layers and here is your dense layer so
you have an input object your dense
layer your activation layer embedding
layer
this is your your kind of your one set
up on there that's most common
uh convolutional neural networks or
convolutional layers these are like for
doing image categorizing so trying to
find objects in a picture that kind of
thing
we have pooling layers so as you have
the layers come together
usually bring them down into
a single layer although you can still do
like global max pulling 3d and there is
just i mean this list just goes on and
on uh there's all kinds of different
things hidden in here as far as what you
can do
and it changes you know you go in here
and you just have to do a search for
what you're looking for
and figure out what's going to work best
for you
as far as which project you're working
on
long short term memory is a big one
because this is when we start talking
about text
what if someone says the what comes
after the uh the cat and the hat a
little kid's uh book there um it starts
programming it and so you really want to
know not only
what's going on but it's going to be
something that has a history the history
behind it tells you what the next one
coming up is now once we've built all
our different you know we built our
model we've added our different layers
we went in there
play with it remember if you're in
functional you can actually link these
layers together and they branch out and
come back together if you do a
the sub
setup then you can create your own
different model you can embed a model in
there that might be coming linear
regression you can embed a linear
regression model as part of your
functional split and then have that come
back together with other things
so we're going to go ahead and compile
your model this brings everything
together we're going to put in what the
loss is which we'll use the mean squared
error
and we'll go ahead and use the atom
optimizer clearly there's a lot of
choices on here depending on what you're
doing and just like uh any of these uh
different prediction models if you've
been doing any
scikit from python
you'll recognize that we have to then
fit the model uh so what are we doing in
here we're going to send in our train x
our train y
um we're going to decide how many epics
we're going to run it through
500 is probably a lot for this
i'm guessing it'd probably be about two
or three hundred probably do just fine
our batch size
so how many different when you process
it this is the math behind it
if you're in data analytics
you might try to know what this number
is as a data scientist where i haven't
had the phd level math that says this is
why you want to use this particular
batch size you kind of play with this
number a little bit
you can dig deeper into the math
see how it affects the results depending
what you're doing
and there's a number of other settings
on here we did verbose 2. i'd have to
actually look that up to tell you what
verbose means i think that's actually
the default on there if i remember
correctly
there's a lot of different settings when
you go to fit it
the big ones are your epic and your
batch size those are what we're looking
for
and so we're going to go ahead and run
this
and this is going to take a few minutes
to run because it's going through
500 times
through all the data so if you have a
huge data set this is the point where
you're kind of wondering oh my gosh is
this going to finish tomorrow um if i'm
running this on a single machine and i
have a tera terabyte of data
going into it
if this is my personal computer and i'm
running a terabyte of data into this
um you know this is running rather
quickly through all 500 iterations uh
but yeah a terabyte of data we're
talking something closer to days week
you know even with a a
3.5 gigahertz machine in in eight cores
it's still going to take a long time to
go through a full terabyte of data
and then we want to start looking at
putting it into some other framework
like spark or something that will print
the process on there more across
multiple
processors and multiple computers
and if we scroll all the way down to the
bottom you're going to see here's our
square mean error 0.0088
if we scroll way up you'll see it kind
of oscillates between 0.0888 and 0.08089
it's right around 2 to 250 where you
start seeing that oscillation where it's
really not going anywhere so we really
didn't need to go through a full 500
epics
you know if you're retraining the stuff
over and over again it's kind of good to
know where that
error zone is so you don't have to do
all the extra processing of course if
you're going to build a model
we want to go ahead and run a prediction
on it
so let's go ahead and make our
prediction remember we have our training
test set
and our test set or that
we have the
train x and the train y for training it
or train predict and then we have our
test x and our test y going in there uh
so we can test to see how good it did
uh and when we come in here we have
you'll see right here we go ahead and do
our train predict equals
model predict train x
and test predict model predict test x
why would we want to run the prediction
on train x well it's not 100 on its
prediction
we know it has a certain amount of error
and we want to compare the error we have
on what we programmed it with with the
error we get when we run it on new data
that's never seen the model's never seen
before and one of the things we can do
we go ahead and invert the predictions
this helps us
level it off a little bit more
get rid of some of our bias we have
train predict equals and np
exponential m1 the train predict and
then train y equals the exponential m1
for train y and then we do the again
that with train test predict and test y
um
again reformatting the data so that we
can it all matches and then we want to
go ahead and calculate the root mean
square error
so we have our train score
which is your math square root times the
mean square root error train
y and train predict and again we're just
this is just feeding the data through so
we can compare it and the same thing
with the test
and let's take a look at that because
really
the code makes sense if you're going
through it line by line you can see
we're doing but the answer really helps
to zoom in
so we have a train score which is 2.40
of our root mean square error
and we have a test score of 3.16 of the
root mean square error
if these were reversed if our test score
is better than our training score
then we've over trained something's
really wrong at that point you've got to
go back and figure out what you did
wrong
because you should never have a better
result on your test data than you do
when you're training data and that's why
we put them both through that's why we
look at the error for both the training
and the testing
when you're going out and quoting you're
publishing this you're saying hey how
good is my model it's the test score
that you're showing people this is what
it did on my test data that the model
had never seen before this is how good
my model is
and a lot of times you actually want to
put together like a little formal code
where we actually want to print that out
and if we print that out you can see
down here
test prediction standard deviation of
data set 3.16 is less than 4.40
i have to go back
and we're
up here if you remember we did the
square means error this is standard
deviation that's why these numbers are
different it's saying the same thing
that we just talked about
3.16 is less than 4.40 model is good
enough we're saying hey this is this
model is valid we have a valid model
here so we can go ahead and go with that
and along with
putting a formal print out of there um
we want to go ahead and plot what's
going on
uh and this we just want to pretty graft
here so that people can see what's going
on when i walk into a meeting and i'm
dealing with a number of people
they really don't want these numbers
they don't want to say hey what's i mean
standard deviation unless you know what
statistics are
you might be dealing with a number of
different departments head of cells
might not work with standard deviation
or have any idea what that really means
number wise and so at this point we
really want to put it in a graph so we
have something to display and with
displaying you remember that we're
looking at the data
today going into it and what's going to
happen tomorrow
so let's take a quick look at this we're
going to go ahead and shift the train
predictions for plotting we have our
train predict plot
np empty leg data set train predict plot
set it up with uh null values
yeah
you know it's just kind of it's kind of
a weird thing where we're creating the
um
the
data groups as we like them
and then putting the data in there's
what's going on here uh so we have our
train predict plot
uh which is going to be our look back
our length
plus look back
we're just is going to equal train
train predict
so we're creating this basically we're
taking this and we're dumping the train
predict into it so now we have our nice
train predict plot
and then we have the shift test
predictions for the plotting we're going
to continue more of that oops looks like
i put it in here double no it's just uh
yeah they put it in here double
didn't mean to do that
we really only need to do it once oh
here we go
this is where the problem was is because
this is the test predict
so we have our training prediction we're
doing the shift on here
and then the test predict we're going to
look at that same thing we're just
creating those two data sets
test
predict plot length prediction set up on
there
and then we're going to go through the
plotting the original data set and the
predictions so we have a time axis
always nice to have your time set on
there
set that to the time array
time axes lap
all this is setting up the time variable
for the bottom and then we have a lot of
stuff going on here as far as setting up
our figure
let's go ahead and run that and then
we'll break it down
we have on here
our main plot we have two different
plots going on here
the ispu going up and the data and the
ispu here with all these different
settings on it
and so we look at this we have our ax1
that's the main plot i mean our ax
that's the main plot and we have our ax1
which is the secondary plot over here
so we're doing a figure plt
or plt.figure
and we're going to dump those two graphs
on there
and so we take
and if you
go through the code piece by piece
uh which we're not going to do we're
going to do the um the
data set here
exponential reverse exponential so it
looks correctly we're going to label it
the original data set
we're going to plot the train predict
plot that's what we just created
we're going to make that orange and
we'll label it train prediction
test predicts plot we're gonna make that
red and label it test prediction and so
forth um set our ticks up this actually
just put ticks time axes gets its ticks
little little marks there going along
the axes that kind of thing and let's
take a look and see what these graphs
look like
and these are just kind of fun you know
when you show up into a meeting and this
is the final output you say hey this is
what we're looking at
um here's our original data in blue
here's our training prediction you can
see that it trains pretty close to what
the data is up there
i would also probably put a
like a little little time stamp and do
just right before and right after where
we go from train to test prediction
and you can see with the test prediction
the data comes in in red
and then you can also see what the
original data set look like behind it
and how it differs
and then we can just isolate that here
on the right that's all this is is just
the
test prediction on the right uh and it's
you know there's you'll see with the
original data set there's a lot of peaks
were missing and a lot of lows were
missing
but as far as the actual test prediction
it's pretty does pretty good it's pretty
right on you can get a good idea what to
expect for your ispu
and so from this we would probably
publish it and say hey this is
what you expect and this is our area of
this is a range of error that's the kind
of thing i'd put out
on a daily basis maybe we predict the
cells are going to be this or maybe
weekly
so you kind of get a nice you kind of
flatten the
data coming out and you say hey this is
what we're looking at the big takeaway
from this is that we're working with
let me go back up here oops oh too far
there we go
is this model here this is what this is
all about we worked through all of those
pieces
all the tensorflows
and that is to build this sequential
model and we're only putting in the two
layers
this can get pretty complicated if you
get too complicated it never
it never verges into a usable model
so if you have like 30 different layers
in here there's a good chance you might
crash it kind of thing
so don't go too haywire on that and that
you kind of learn as you go again it's
domain knowledge
um and also starting to understand all
these different layers and what they
mean the data
analytics behind those layers
is something that your data analysis
professional will come in and say this
is what we want to try
but i tell you as a data scientist
a lot of these basic setups are common
and i don't know how many times
working with somebody and they're like
oh my gosh if i only did a tangent h
instead of a relu activation
i worked for two weeks to figure that
out well the data science i can run it
through the model in you know five
minutes instead of spending two weeks
doing the the math behind it
so that's one of the advantages of data
scientist is we do it from programming
side and a data analytics is going to
look for it how does it work in math
and this is really the core right here
of tensorflow and cross is being able to
build your data model quickly and
efficiently and of course
with any data science
putting out a pretty graph so that your
shareholders
again we want to take and
reduce the information down to something
people can look at and say oh that's
what's going on they can see stuff
what's going on as far as the dates and
the change in the ispu now let's talk a
little bit about recurrent neural
networks so neural networks are of
different types we have cnn we have rnn
and so on now rnn is one type of neural
network rnn stands for recurrent neural
network the networks like cnn and a n
are feed forward network which means
that the information pretty much only
goes from left to right or from front to
back whichever way you call it whereas
in case of recurrent neural network
there will be some information traveling
backwards as well so that is why it is
known as recurrent neural network and
each of these types have a specific
application so for example convolutional
neural networks or cnn are very good for
doing image processing and
object detection using for video and
images whereas recurrent neural networks
are pretty good for doing nlp or speech
recognition and so on okay so for the
next few minutes we will kind of focus
on recurrent neural networks and we will
see an example of how we can use rnn to
do a time series analysis so in a
typical neural network this is how it
looks right so where you have a neuron
and then the inputs are coming to the
neuron and then you have an output which
goes to other neurons in the other
layers in case of recurrent neural
network what happens is you have the
inputs let's say at a given point in
time but then a part of the previous
output also gets fed in along with the
inputs for the given time now this can
be a little confusing so let's see if we
can take a little expanded view of this
so this is another view of one single
neuron which is what is known as in an
unfolded manner okay so if we are
getting inputs or data over a period of
time then this is how the neuron will
look remember these are not three
neurons this is one neuron and it is
what is known as it is shown in a
unfolded way okay we are on we have
unfolded this single neuron over a
period of time so at a given time let's
say t minus 1 an input of x t minus 1 is
fed to the neuron and it gets a output
of y t minus 1 then the next instant
which is x t at a time t right there is
an input of x t and then there is an
output of y t so this is a single neuron
but it's displayed in an unfolded way so
this is like expanding it over a period
of time so let's start with this part
here this particular neuron gets an
input at an instant t minus 1 let's say
time is equal to t minus 1 it gets an
input of x t minus 1 and it gives an
output of y t minus then when we go to
the instant t here it gets an input of x
t and it also additionally gets an input
from this previous time frame t minus
one so this y t minus one gets fed here
and that results in y t all right then
when we go to the time t plus 1 there is
an input of x t minus 1 at that given
time plus the input from the previous
time frame which is a time frame of t
that also gets fed in here and then we
get an output of y t plus 1 okay so let
me explain once again this is a single
neuron so these are not three different
neurons a single neuron seen over a
period of time from t minus one to t
plus one and unlike a regular feed
forward neuron which only gets x in this
case the input is x and also another
input which is coming from the previous
time frame and that is what this loop is
in this on the left hand side diagram
this loop is indicating that okay so on
the right hand side it is represented in
an unfolded way okay so the input if we
take a time frame t for example is not
only x t which is the input which is the
normal input at the time frame t but it
is also getting an input from the
previous time frame which is this yt
minus 1 which is also being fed as an
input that is the key differentiator
here okay similarly at the instant t
plus 1 it is getting a normal input of x
t plus 1 plus this yt is actually being
fed here and then the output comes as yt
plus one okay so this is the construct
of a recurrent neural network now
recurrent neural networks again can be
of different subtypes it can be
one too many many to one and many too
many depending on what kind of
application we want to use one of the
examples is like the stock price so
you're feeding so there is only one
input only thing is it is spread over a
period of time so you're feeding the
stock price input that is what comes
here as an input and you get an output
which is again the stock price which is
probably predicted over the next two
days or three days or 10 days or
whatever so the number of outputs and
inputs is the same there is only one
input there is only one output only
thing is it is spread over a time so
variables are not many then you have one
to many so there is one input but you
are expecting multiple outputs what is
an example of this lets say you want to
caption an image so how do you want to
do that what is the input that will go
here is just an image which is one input
but what is output you are looking for
you are looking for a phrase maybe right
not just a word but a phrase so it's
like cat is sitting on a map right so
the images there is only one image which
consists of the cat sitting on a mat but
the output are like maybe three or four
words which is saying the cat is sitting
on a mat so this is one too many right
then you can have many to one examples
of this are like you're feeding some
text and you want to know the output
whether the text is what kind of
sentiment is expressed by the text it
could be positive it could be negative
so that's the output you're looking for
so you feed a large number of words
maybe the text may consist of words or
lines or whatever so that is what is the
multiple inputs but the output all it
says is the sentiment is positive so it
is just one output or the sentiment is
negative just one output right so this
is many to one then we have many too
many so what is an example of this let's
say you want to do some translation so
how do you do a translation you feed in
a sentence maybe in a particular
language english and then you want
another a sentence actually in another
language so that is like there are
multiple inputs one sentence can consist
of multiple words and the output also is
a sentence consisting of multiple words
all right so how do we implement rnn
this is an example of implementing an
rnn for a particular use case so in our
particular example we have the data
about milk production over a few months
and using rnn we want to predict because
this is time series analysis so rnn is
good to do time series analysis so using
rnn we want to predict what will be the
milk production in the future so let us
see how we can do that i will first take
you through quickly through the slides
and then i will actually run this in in
a jupiter notebook the code i will run
it in the jupyter notebook so this is
how it looks the code looks so while
this is tensorflow you still
use the standard python libraries like
numpy and pandas and even matplotlib to
do some initial processing getting the
data processing it cleaning it whatever
all that can be still done in within the
same program so that's what we're doing
here we're importing some libraries like
numpy and pandas and then we read the
data file and if we plot the data we see
here it is the data for for the years
1962 to 75 and we can see that there is
a certain trend right so this is how a
typical time series data would look
again some of you if you are not
familiar with time series and time
series analysis and so on i would
recommend you to go through some videos
around that which will make it easy to
understand this so this is our typical
time series data would look in this case
it is nothing but there is only one
variable which is milk production and it
is spread across several years so this
is going from 1962 to 75 and that value
has been plotted so if you see there is
a certain kind of a trend here which is
basically going upwards and there will
be some seasonality so time series data
has these three components right so it
will have a trend it will have a
seasonality it will have seasonality and
then it will have some randomness so
that's what this graph is showing and
now if we want to perform analysis on
this time series analysis on this first
thing we need to do is split the data
into train and test and in this case we
will just use a straightforward method
which is taking the data for the first
13 years so the idea here is we need to
train our model right this is time
series data so what and we want to
predict for the future so the way we
need to use this is we have to take the
data for a certain period of time and
train our model and then we use a part
of the known data so that we can then
ask our model to predict for that
duration and compare it with the known
information so what do we mean by that
so here if you see this data i will show
you in the notebook as well jupiter
notebook as well this has 13 years of
data so what we are doing is we are
taking the first 12 years and using that
as our training set right so 12 years we
are doing and this has about i think 14
years of data so we are taking 13 years
of data for training purpose and then we
are using the last one year remaining
one year of data for testing purpose
because here what we can do is this one
year data we know the values right
because if we want to compare the
accuracy or anything like that we need
to know the value so in this case we
know the values of this one particular
year so we will use that but at the same
time we train the model for 13 years of
data and for the 14th year we will ask
our model to predict and then compare it
with this known value so that we know
how accurate our model is i hope that
makes sense okay so that's what we are
doing here 156 is nothing but 12 into 13
on a monthly basis we get the data the
next step is to scale the data this is
all regular data manipulation data
munching activity and then you split it
you are basically assigning the train
and test data to the to the scaled
variables and then you need to read the
data in batches so
it is very important as i mentioned
earlier also that instead of reading the
entire data in one shot you feed the
data in batches so in order to do that
we are writing a function for that
that's all we are doing here so that is
still here what we have done is regular
python programming there is no
tensorflow as of now here okay so so far
what we have done is preparation data
preparation data munching now what we
are doing is actually training our model
so this is where tensorflow now comes
into picture so we are importing first
step is to import the tensorflow library
so this is how you do it import
tensorflow sdf and then you can define
some variables or constants whichever
way now here of course there are a
couple of ways of doing it you can
create them as tensorflow nodes but that
is a little bit of an overhead we will
just use the regular python
variables are constant so here i am
creating regular python variables and i
am saying number of inputs is one so
instead of hard coding i am just storing
them as variables so this is number of
inputs is 1 number of time steps is 12
number of neurons is 100 and so on right
and then learning rate is 0.03 and
number of iterations we are seeing is 4
000 then we create placeholders now we
will be storing the independent
variables in x and the dependent
variables in y and this we will read
from an external file remember i told
you placeholders are used for getting
data from outside and then feeding it to
our model so that's the reason we have
two placeholders one for reading the x
values and another for reading the y
values in this step we are only just
creating the nodes right so this is just
creating the graph and similarly we are
mentioning what is the loss function and
what is the optimizer and how to run the
optimizer and once that is done you are
initializing the variables and then
you're creating a saver variable or a
saver instance so saver is basically
nothing but in machine learning you can
train your model and you can save it for
later use so that's where this saving
comes into play we will see how to use
that as well and then the last step is
to create your session and run this
graph right so
we are initializing the variables
remember this we run in it so which is
nothing but this one so we are
initializing the variables whatever are
there instead of hard coding remember in
earlier case we were hardcoding how many
iterations so here we are saying for the
given number of iterations which are
stored in this maybe how many iterations
we said is what is the value of
iterations this is training iterations
is 4000. so we specify that based on the
number of training iterations next batch
will basically fetch the data and then
we run the session we are basically
saying train is the node which we will
run in the session and
this will basically train our model and
this is more for printing every hundred
times you print it that's all this
there's nothing more to it so for
example the output would look somewhat
like this this is for 0 this 400 next
for 200 and so okay and then you save
the model you remember saver we created
so you save the model for later use so
this is our test data remember we are
doing this on training data right so
once the training data training is done
we then try to create the inference on
the test data so that we can compare how
accurate this is right so this is how
the test set would look and then we will
basically restore this model okay
because in the previous slide we created
the model and we stored it so now we
have to restore the model and then run
our test data against it and see what
are the values that are predicted what
are the y values and then compare with x
to see the accuracy so train seed is
what we are seeing here so that is what
will have the predicted values and
these predicted values what we want to
do is we want to create an additional
column because remember we need to
compare because we want to find out the
accuracy of this model so we need to
compare the predicted values with the
actual value so what we are doing here
is adding another column called
generator and
assign a value to that all right so this
is the result of the prediction and then
if we need to reshape because we have to
show this in the form of a monthly
results so that's what we're doing here
and
once we generate the results and then
display it we can actually see it
month-wise here and
the actual and the generated values okay
so we create a data frame which is a
combination of the actual values and the
predicted values from the test set and
then we can plot to see how the trend is
as you can see pretty much the actual
value is in blue color and the generated
or predicted value the curve is in
yellow color the trend is maintained so
it will probably it's not a hundred
percent accurate but the trend is
maintained all right so let's do one
thing let's go into the jupiter notebook
and take a look at how this works in
tensorflow environment actually the code
i will walk you through the code this is
my jupiter notebook and
the data is taken from this particular
link in case you're interested you can
download it from there and this is the
data for the years 1962 to 75. the first
thing we do is import these libraries
because before we start with the actual
tensorflow activity we need to prepare
the data and so on so for that you can
use your regular python libraries which
are like numpy pandas and so on so
that's what we're doing here and then we
read the data using pandas into a data
frame so this is a data frame milk is a
data frame and we will do some quick
exploratory analysis just to see how our
data is looking initial
five records that we'll get one two
three four five that is the head so it
goes from 1960 to january to 1960 to may
once we reach change or basically we
need to split this into month
specifically separately so that's what
we are doing here date to time so we
kind of do a little bit of reindexing
and then if we plot this this is how the
data look as you can see there is a
clear upward trend and
there is some seasonality and so on but
anyway we will not break that up into
those components we will just use rnn to
predict and test okay so the next thing
is to check some if we can do run like
info it will tell us what is the
information about this data set so let
us just run that okay it is just telling
us how many total columns and what is
the size of the file and so on and so
forth again in case you're interested in
doing some exploratory analysis so what
we'll do next is we will take the 13
years of data for our training data set
so what are we going to do now let me
step back so what have we seen here we
have seen that there are 168 records so
which is nothing but 14 years of data we
now have to split this into our training
and test data set so how do we do that i
think in case of time series we cannot
do it like 80 20 like we do in normal
splitting in normal machine learning
process here it is time series data so
what we are going to do is we will take
out of this 14 years we will take the
first 13 years of data and we will use
that for training and then we will test
it with the last which is the 14th year
data we will use it for testing okay so
that's what we are going to do here so
let's uh split that so training set will
consist of my 156 records which is
nothing but 12 13 into 12 right my 13
years of data i'm taking for training
and then my test set will consist of the
bottom 12 observations which is last one
year of data which is the 14th year okay
so that's now done training and test
splitting is done the next step is to do
some normalizing which is basically
we'll use our scaling rather we will use
min max scala and we will just scale the
data and now we do it for both test as
well as train now we are ready to create
our rnn model but before that one quick
thing in order to fetch the data we have
to create a function so that's what we
are doing here we create a function
called next batch and how you want to
fetch the steps they are all defined as
our constants if you remember and that's
what this function is all about so we
define that function we will be calling
that in our training method all right so
from here onwards up to there we are
done with the preparation of the data
and whatever functions or whatever are
required from here onwards is where the
tensorflow part starts so the first
thing we do is import the tensorflow
library typically this is a very
standard way of importing the library we
say import tensorflow as tf now tf is
nothing but a name so you can change it
to tf1 or abc or xyz whatever so this
part you can change but by and large
everybody uses this so i would rather
recommend you also use the same syntax
so you say import tensorflow stf so it's
very easy for others to understand as
well and then you declare or define a
bunch of constants that's what we are
doing here like for example the number
of time steps in this case it is 12
number of neurons there are 100 number
of outputs it is only one and so on
right and then the learning rate and all
that we are declaring or defining those
variables in this particular block next
is to create placeholders you remember
the placeholders are used for feeding
the data so we have x and y x is for the
input which is the independent variable
and y is the output which is the
dependent variable and in our case these
are not different characteristics or
features but it is the same one feature
or one variable but it is over a period
of time so that's the only difference so
that's what we are doing here and now we
need to create our network right the
neural network so in our case we said we
will create a rnn layer now there are
different ways or different formats of
rnn which is probably not in scope of
this module so for now we will just
assume we are creating one rnn layer and
one type of rnn
this we will probably do in another
video where we talk in detail about rnn
so for now we are creating a gre cell
with the wrapper and the the syntax for
creating the gru cell is like this the
number of units which we we said there
should be 100 neurons what will be the
activation function in this case it is
relu and then number of outputs in our
case it is only one okay so we create
the cell here okay then we got the gru
cell and then we say what is our output
which is nothing but we get the outputs
and the states and their states and
which is uh the way we get that is
tf.nnn
dot dynamic underscore rnn so if we call
this and we pass the cell and the data
which is basically in placeholder again
remember all we are doing here is we are
creating just the nodes for the graph so
nothing is actually getting executed
from a tensorflow perspective okay all
right so once that is done now we need
to pass this calculate the outputs and
the states using the dynamic underscore
rna method and we pass the cell as a
parameter and then the x values as a
parameter and if we
run that we will have the outputs and
the states and this is where we actually
run the training method
so
or create not really run the training
method but we create the nodes for the
training and optimizer then we have the
initialization of the variables and we
save this model we create a saver object
just to save the model because we will
then restore it and run it to do our
predictions so this is what we will do
here so that is another node and this is
where we actually create a session and
run the training okay so let's go ahead
and do that that will take a little
while because we said 4000 iterations so
we will allow it to finish we will
probably come back once the training is
completed all right so the training is
done now let's go and
run this on the test data so let's just
quickly take a look at the test data set
so this is our one year data for the
year of 1975 so
if we see this is from january february
and so on and we will pass this to our
model so what are we doing here we are
restoring the model here for example
right this is the path that we have
given when we were saving the model
let's go back once and show you let me
show you where we did the saving of the
model yes so we saved the model here so
that again we will restore that and we
will use that to run it on our test data
and see how well it predicts so let's go
ahead and run this and this is just 12
records so this will not take time
remember i told you training is what
takes a lot of time the regular
inference this is called inference
doesn't take much time right so it just
depends on how much data there were only
12 records here so it was very quick but
in training what we do we pass this
multiple times there are iterations 4
000 iterations we did for example so
that takes longer and in general in
machine learning deep learning training
is what takes the maximum amount of time
all right so let's go ahead and see the
results we will in order to plot it we
will have to kind of adjust the format
of the results otherwise we will not be
able to see it in a proper way and then
we will so this is our so what we have
done is we created a data frame which
consists of the predicted value and and
the actual value so this is the data
frame so this is the actual value this
834 782 and so on this is what our model
has predicted so it may not be so easy
to see in a tabler format so let's go
ahead and plot it so that we can compare
these two so when we plot it you will
see that the trend is more or less
maintained right so we go from the blue
color is the actual values and the
yellow color or the orange color
whatever is it is the one which is
generated by our model so it pretty much
is following the actual trend so not bad
for such a quick iteration and
training this tutorial is about object
detection we will walk you through a
tensorflow code using which we will do
object detection in images we will tell
you what are the libraries that are
required a little bit about the cocoa
data set and then we will show you the
implementation
code itself a demo of the code all right
so let's get started so what is the
tensorflow object detection api this is
an open source framework which is
actually provided by the tensorflow team
and there are trained models available
and the sample code is also available
which we can use in order to easily
detect objects in images and videos this
is pretty robust and can
detect objects fairly quickly and this
is very easy for people to use as well
people with very less or no knowledge of
machine learning or deep learning can
also with a little bit of python
programming knowledge can actually use
this api this library to build object
detection applications this is a list of
libraries that are required and they
have been shown in the code as well the
exact purpose of each of this library
why it is required is
out of the scope of this tutorial but we
will see in the code as we walk through
some of these libraries how and why they
are used the cocoa data set coco stands
for common objects in context so this
data set consists of 300 000 images of
90 most commonly found objects like
chairs and tables and so on and so forth
so
this model has been trained or in fact a
set of models have been trained on this
data set and this is pretty good to
detect the most common objects in the
images and videos so with that let's get
into the code all right so the first
part is to import all these libraries
and this we have shown you in the slides
as well again a bunch part of this will
be for doing some helper functions and
maybe for visualizing the images and so
on and so forth so that's the reason
they are required as i said the exact
details of each and every library
probably is out of scope but these are
needed so as a first step maybe you just
go ahead and include these libraries and
run the code and maybe a later point we
can discuss what each of these libraries
does now this will work with tensorflow
version higher than 1.4 so if you are
having tensorflow version below 1.4 you
may have to upgrade to a higher version
so let me go ahead and execute the cell
and
we also need this line of code to make
sure that once we
run this object detection the labeled
images are displayed within this
notebook and many of you by now must be
familiar with this and we will import a
few utility libraries and you will see
that we will be using some of these
for visualization purpose so once the
objects are detected we need to display
the information what that object is and
then what percentage of confidence the
model has so all these details that's
the utility functions that stored here
and then the next part is to prepare the
model as i mentioned we will be using an
existing trained model
the tensorflow team has actually
provided these models the one that we
will be using is ssd with the mobile net
but you can actually use any one of the
ones that are listed in this url let me
just quickly take you through this url
these are a bunch of models trained
models that are readily available for
anybody to use it is open source and let
me scroll down the only thing is that if
there are some of them with the accuracy
is much higher but they take longer and
there are some where the accuracy is not
so high and they are much faster so they
are faster but the accuracy may not be
that very high so you can play around
with some of these and we in this
particular exercise or in this
particular tutorial we are using this
ssd model which is ssd mobile at
question one so that's the model that
we'll be using so in this cell we are
primarily creating a bunch of variables
with the various for example the name of
the model the path and so on and so
forth so that we will be using these
names in the next step which is to
download this model and install it
locally these are also referred to as
frozen models so once they are trained
and then you kind of extract or you
freeze the model so that's the reason
they are called frozen model so that
others can just use this without any
further training so this is where we
download and extract our model locally
so this will take a little while let me
see if i can wait or maybe pause the
video and come back once it is done
might take a little while let's see if
it
completes i have a pretty high speed
network but even then it takes some time
so that's good but this part is over now
let us see this part and yes both are
done so once that is done we need to
load some label mapping now basically
what this will do is your model as you
may be aware by now if you do some
classification the model will actually
not give any output text it will give
some numbers so if there are five
classes it will say okay this belongs to
modern class one or two or three or five
and so on the numbers now each of these
will obviously the numbers will not make
any sense to the outside world so we
need to do some small mapping so in this
case let's say one may be a chair two
maybe a table three maybe a balloon and
so on so that kind of number to text
mapping we need to do and that is what
is being done in this particular cell
and then we have a helper code which
will load the image and convert it into
a numpy array so that the number array
is what gets processed and used by the
model to do the detection part of it so
that is what this
method is all about so we will be the
later on we will be calling that
function and
next is preparation for detection so
here we are basically telling where the
images are stored and how many images or
what is the naming convention or format
of the images now if you want you can
modify this code for example currently i
have test underscore images as my folder
so let me go and show this to you so
this is under my object detection folder
i have another subfolder where i am
storing my images which is text
underscore images now you can rename
this folder and give some other name and
then in your code you can probably give
that particular name for the subfolder
similarly the format of these files what
is the name and format of this files
here it is in a very simple format which
is the names of the files are like beach
one beach two b3 and so on so i have
taken beach as the theme so i have
images which are related to beaches so
this is beach one beach two and then
beach three a few others but we will use
these three for our demo and so that's
what i'm saying here the name of the
images will be beach something dot jpeg
which is uh jpeg format and in this
curly braces basically we will will be
filled with either
one two or three based on in this
particular for loop okay so that is what
this is doing all right so the next step
is to run inference on these images in a
loop and what we are basically doing
here is
getting these images one by one and then
running through the model to find out
what are the objects that can be
detected and then against each of the
object a box will be drawn and it will
be labeled with the name and the
percentage of accuracy or confidence
that the model detects these objects
okay so that is
the function here and so let me just run
that piece of code and here is basically
where we are calling this function so we
are loading this images and then we are
calling this function for each image and
then we are displaying this using the
matplotlib library so let's run this it
will take one image at a time and then
detect the images now the beauty is that
the same format of the code can be used
for doing object detection in a video so
we have another video for doing object
detection
in a video so most of the code out there
will be reused from here and the only
thing is that instead of reading the
images from the local storage we read
the frames from the video and there is a
neat little video reader that is
available and it will be shown in the
other video and frame by frame we read
the video and then pass on to this
function and it will act as if each of
these frames is an image and then it
will do the same object detection on the
entire video so that's in a separate
video just look out for that and
actually the information about that is
uh provided
in the cards the eye symbol so that's
the the video object detection in video
that's the separate tutorial all right
so now that we have all the pieces
together this the last cell is where the
whole action takes place so let's run
this and see how it looks so it will
take probably a little while and there
are about three images let's see what it
detects there we go so good so the first
one it has detected a person and that
too with 97 percent accuracy which is i
think pretty good okay and then the next
image it detects umbrella and chair
there are a few other objects but it's
not able to detect it has detected
umbrella with 63 percent accuracy or
confidence rather and the chair with 58
percent again not bad
then let's see the next image so here
these are actually balloons hot air
balloons but the model thinks it is a
kite which is probably not that bad it
sees there's something in the sky and
therefore probably it thinks it is a
kite and it detects that with 65 percent
confidence okay so that was pretty much
all i wanted to show you in this
particular tutorial about object
detection in images and in this video i
will walk you through the tensorflow
code to perform object detection in a
video so let's get started this part is
basically we are importing all the
libraries we need a lot of these
libraries for example numpy
we need image i o date time and pill and
so on and so forth and of course
matplotlib so we import all these
libraries and then there are a bunch of
variables which have some paths for the
files and folders so this is regular
stuff let's keep moving then we import
the matplotlib and make it inline and
a few more imports all right and then
these are some warnings we can just
ignore them so if i run this code once
again it could go away right and then
here onwards we do the model preparation
now what we're going to do is we're
going to use an existing neural network
model so we are not going to chain a new
one because that really will take a long
time and it needs a lot of computation
resources and so on and it is really not
required there are already models that
have been trained and in this case it is
the ssd with mobilenet that's the model
that we are going to use and this model
is trained to detect objects and it is
readily available as open source so we
can actually use this and if you want to
use other models there are a few more
models available so you can click on
this link here and
let me just take you there there are few
more models but we have chosen this
particular one because this is faster it
may not be very accurate but that is one
of the faster models but on this link
you will see a lot of other models that
are readily available these are trained
models some of them would take a little
longer but they may be more accurate and
so on so you can probably play around
with these other models okay so we will
be using that model so this piece of
code this line is basically importing
that model and this is also known as
frozen model the term we use is frozen
model so we import download and import
that and then we will actually use that
model in our code all right so these two
cells
we have downloaded and import the model
and then once it is available locally we
will then load this into our program all
right so
we are loading this into memory and
you need to perform a couple of
additional steps which is basically we
need to map the numbers to
text as you may be aware when we
actually build the model and when we run
predictions the model will not give a
text the output of the model is usually
a number so we need to map that to a
text so for example if the network
predicts that the output is 5 we know
that 5 means it is an airplane things
like that so this mapping is done in
this next cell all right so let's keep
moving and then we have a helper code
which will basically load the data or
load the images and transform into numpy
arrays this is also used in doing object
detection in images so we are actually
going to reuse because video is nothing
but it consists of frames which in turn
are images so we are going to pretty
much use reuse the same code which we
use for doing object detection in images
so this is where the actual detection
starts so here this is the path for
where the images are stored so this is
here once again we are reusing the code
which we wrote for detecting objects in
an image so this is the path where the
images were stored and this is the
extension and this was done for about
two or three images so we will continue
to use this and
we go down i'll skip this section so
this is the cell where we are actually
loading the video and converting it into
frames and then using frame by frame we
are detecting the objects in the image
so in this code what we are doing
basically is there are a few lines of
code what they do is basically once they
find an object a box will be drawn
around those
each of those objects and the input file
the name of the input video file is
traffic it is the extension is mp4 and
we have this video reader it's a
excellent object which is basically part
of this class called image i o so we can
read and write videos using that and the
video that we are going to use is
traffic.mp4 you can use any mp4 file but
in our case i picked up video which has
like car so let me just show you so this
is in this object detection folder i
have this mp4 file i'll just quickly
play this video it's a little slow yeah
okay so here we go this is the video
it's a short one relatively small video
so that for this particular demo and
what it will do is once we run our code
it will detect each of these cars and it
will annotate them as cars so in this
particular video we only have cars we
can later on see with another video i
think i have cat here so we can also try
with that but let's first check with
this traffic video so let me go back so
we will be reading this frame by frame
and um you know actually we will be
reading the video file but then we will
be analyzing it frame by fame and we
will be reading them at 10 frames per
second that is the rate we are
mentioning here and analyzing it and
then annotating and then writing it back
so you will see that we will have a
video file named something like this
traffic underscore annotated and
we will see the annotated video so let's
go back and run through this piece of
code and then we will come back and see
the annotated video this might take a
little while so i will pause the video
after
running this particular cell and then
come back to show you the results all
right so let's go ahead and run it so it
is running now and it is also important
that at the end you close the video
writer so that it is similar to a file
pointer when you open a file you should
also make sure you close it so that it
doesn't hog the resources so it's very
similar at the end of it the last piece
or last line of code should be video
underscore writer dot close all right so
i'll pause and then i'll come back okay
so i will see you in a little bit all
right so now as you can see here the
processing is done the hourglass has
disappeared that means the video has
been processed so let's go back and
check the annotated video we'll go back
to my file manager so this was the
original traffic.mp4 and now you have
here traffic underscore annotated mp4 so
let's go and run this and see how it
looks
you see here just got each of these cars
are getting detected let me pause and
show you so we pause here it says car 70
let us allow it to go a little further
it detects something on top what is that
truck okay so i think because of the
board on top it somehow thinks there is
a truck let's play some more and see if
it detects anything else so this is
again a car looks like so let us yeah so
this is a car and
it has confidence level of 69 percent
okay this is again a car all right so
basically till the end it goes and
detects each and every car that is
passing by now we can quickly repeat
this process for another video let me
just show you the other video which is a
cat again there is uh this cat is not
really moving or anything but it is just
standing there staring and moving a
little slowly and our application will
our network will detect that this is a
cat and even when the cat moves a little
bit in the other direction it will
continue to detect and show that it is a
cat okay so yeah so this is how the
original video is let's go ahead and
change our code to analyze this one and
see if it detects our network detects
this cat close this here we go and i'll
go back to my code all we need to do is
change this traffic to
cat the extension it will automatically
pick up because it is given here and
then it will run through so very quickly
once again what it is doing is this
video reader video underscore reader has
a neat little feature or interface
whereby you can say for frame in video
underscore reader so it will basically
provide frame by frame so you're in a
loop frame by frame and then you take
that each frame that is given to you you
take it and analyze it as if it is an
image individual image so that's the way
it works so it is very easy to handle
this all right so now let's once again
run just this cell the rest of the stuff
remains the same so i will run this cell
again it will take a little while so the
r classes come back i will pause and
then come back in a little while all
right so the processing is done let's go
and check the annotated video go here so
we have get annotated dot mp4 let's play
this all right so you can see here just
detecting the cat and in the beginning
you also saw it detected something else
here there it looks like it detected one
more object so let's just go back and
see what it has detected here
let's see yes so
what is it trying to show here it's too
small not able to see but uh it is
trying to detect something i think it is
saying it is a car i don't know
all right okay so in this video there's
only pretty much only one object which
is the cat and
let's wait for some time and see if it
continues to detect it when the cat
turns around and moves as well just
in a little bit that's going to happen
and we will see there we go and in spite
of turning the other way i think our
network is able to detect that it is a
cat so let me freeze and then show here
it is actually still continues to detect
it as a cat all right so that's pretty
much it i think that's the only object
that it detects in this particular video
okay so close this so that's pretty much
it thank you very much for watching this
video in this tutorial we will take the
use case of recognizing
handwritten digits this is like a hello
world
of deep learning and this is a nice
little mnist database is a nice little
database that has images of handwritten
digits nicely formatted because very
often
in deep learning and neural networks we
end up spending a lot of time in
preparing the data for training and with
mnist database we can avoid that
you already have the data in the right
format which can be directly used for
training and mnist also offers a bunch
of
built-in utility functions that we can
straight away use and call those
functions without worrying about writing
our own functions and that's one of the
reasons why mnist database is very
popular for training purposes initially
when people want to learn about deep
learning and tensorflow this is the
database that is used and it has a
collection of 70 000 handwritten digits
and
a large part of them
are for training then you have test just
like in any machine learning process and
then you have validation and all of them
are labeled so you have the images and
their label and these images they look
somewhat like this so they are hand
written images collected from a lot of
individuals people have these are
samples written by human beings they
have handwritten these numbers these
numbers going from zero to nine so
people have written these numbers and
then the images of those have been taken
and formatted in such a way that it is
very easy to handle so that is mnis
database and the way we are going to
implement this in our
tensorflow
is we will feed this data especially the
training data along with the label
information and
the data is basically these images are
stored in the form of the pixel
information as we have seen in one of
the previous slides all the images are
nothing but these are pixels
so an image is nothing but an
arrangement of pixels and the value of
the pixel either it is lit up or it is
not or in somewhere in between that's
how the images are stored and that is
how they are fed into the neural network
and for training once the network is
trained when you provide a new image it
will be able to identify within a
certain error of course and for this we
will use one of the simpler neural
network configurations called softmax
and for simplicity what we will do is we
will flatten these pixels so instead of
taking them in a two-dimensional
arrangement we just flatten them out so
for example it starts from here it is a
28 by 28 so there are
784 pixels so pixel number one starts
here it goes all the way up to 28 then
29 starts here and goes up to 56 and so
on and the pixel number 784 is here so
we take all these pixels flatten them
out and feed them like one single line
into our
neural network and this is a what is
known as a soft max layer what it does
is once it is trained it will be able to
identify
what digit this is so there are in this
output layer there are 10
neurons each signifying a digit and at
any given point of time when you feed an
image only
one of these 10 neurons gets activated
so for example if this is trained
properly and if you feed a number 9 like
this
then this particular neuron gets
activated so you get an output from this
neuron let me just use
a pen or a laser to show you here okay
so you're feeding the number nine
let's say this has been trained and now
if you're feeding a number nine this
will get activated now let's say you
fade 1 to the trained
network then this neuron will get
activated if you feed 2 this neuron will
get activated and so on i hope you get
the idea so this is one type of a neural
network or an activation function known
as softmax layer so that's what we will
be using here this is one of the simpler
ones for
quick and easy understanding so this is
how the code would look we will go into
our lab environment in the cloud and
we will show you there directly but very
quickly this is how the code looks and
let me run you through
briefly here and then we will go into
the jupiter notebook where the actual
code is and we will run that as well so
as a first step first of all we are
using python here and that's why the
syntax of the language is python and the
first step is to import the tensorflow
library so
and we do this by using this line of
code saying import tensorflow as tf df
is just for convenience so you can name
give any name and
once you do this tf is tensorflow is
available as an object in the name of tf
and then you can run its methods and
accesses its attributes and so on and so
forth and mnist database is actually an
integral part of tensorflow and that's
again another reason why we as a first
step we always use this example mnist
database example so you just simply
import mnist database as well using this
line of code and you
slightly modify this so that the labels
are in this format what is known as one
hot true which means that the label
information is stored like an array and
let me just use pen to show what exactly
it is so when you do this one hot true
what happens is each label is stored in
the form of an array of 10 digits and
let's say the number is
8 okay so in this case all the remaining
values there will be a bunch of zeros so
this is like array at position zero this
is at position one position two and so
on and so forth let's say this is
position seven then this is position
eight that will be one because our input
is eight and again position nine will be
zero okay so one hot encoding this one
hot encoding true will kind of
load the data in such a way that the
labels are in such a way that only one
of the digits has a value of one and
that indicates so based on which
digit is one we know what is the label
so in this case the 8th position is 1
therefore we know this sample data the
value is 8. similarly if you have a 2
here let's say then the labeled
information will be somewhat like this
so you have your labels so you have this
as zero the zeroth position the first
position is also zero the second
position is one because this indicates
number two and then you have third as
zero and so on okay so that is the
significance of this one hot true all
right and then we can
check how the data is uh looking by
displaying the the data and as i
mentioned earlier this is pretty much in
the form of digital form like numbers so
all these are like pixel values so you
will not really see an image in this
format but there is a way to visualize
that image i will show you in a bit and
this tells you how many images are there
in each set so the training there are 55
000 images in training and in the test
set there are 10 000 and then validation
there are 5 000 so altogether there are
70 000
images all right so let's move on and we
can
view the actual
image by
using the matplotlib library and this is
how you can view this is the code for
viewing the images and you can view them
in color or you can view them in
grayscale so the c map is what tells in
what way we want to view it and what are
the maximum values and the minimum
values of the pixel values so these are
the max and minimum values so of the
pixel values so maximum is 1 because
this is a scaled value so 1 means it is
white and 0 means it is black and in
between
is it can be anywhere in between black
and white
and the way to train the model there is
a certain way in which you write your
tensorflow code and
the first step is to create some
placeholders and then you create a model
in this case we will use the softmax
model one of the simplest ones and
placeholders are primarily to get the
data from outside into the neural
network so this is a very common
mechanism that is used and then of
course you will have variables which are
your you remember these are your weights
and biases so for in our case there are
10 neurons and each neuron actually has
784 because each neuron takes all the
inputs if we go back to our slide here
actually every neuron takes all the 784
inputs right this is the first neuron it
has it receives all the 784 this is the
second neuron this also receives all the
700 so each of these inputs needs to be
multiplied with the weight and that's
what we are talking about here so these
are
this is a a matrix
of 784
values for each of the neurons and so it
is like a 10 by 784 matrix because there
are 10 neurons
and similarly there are biases now
remember i mentioned bias is only one
per neuron so it is not one per input
unlike the weights so therefore there
are only 10 biases because there are
only 10 neurons in this case so that is
what we are creating a variable for
biases so this is something little new
in tensorflow you will see unlike our
regular programming languages where
everything is a variable here the
variables can be of three different
types you have placeholders which are
primarily used for feeding data you have
variables which can change during the
course of computation and then a third
type which is not shown here are
constants so these are like fixed
numbers all right so in a regular
programming language you may have
everything as variables or at the most
variables and constants but in
tensorflow you have three different
types placeholders variables and
constants and then you create what is
known as a graph so tensorflow
programming consists of graphs and
tensors as i mentioned earlier so this
can be considered ultimately as a tensor
and then the graph tells how to execute
the whole implementation so that the
execution is stored in the form of a
graph and in this case what we are doing
is we are doing a multiplication tf you
remember this tf was created as a
tensorflow object here one more level
one more so tf is available here now
tensorflow has what is known as a matrix
multiplication or matmal function so
that is what is being used here in this
case so we are using the matrix
multiplication of tensorflow so that you
multiply your input values x with w
right this is what we were doing x w
plus b you're just adding b and this is
in very similar to one of the earlier
slides where we saw sigma x i wi so
that's what we are doing here matrix
multiplication is multiplying all the
input values with the corresponding
weights and then adding the bias so that
is the graph we created and then we need
to define what is our loss function and
what is our optimizer so in this case we
again use the tensorflow's apis so tf
dot nn soft max cross entropy with
logits is the
api that we will use and reduce mean is
what is like the mechanism whereby which
says that you reduce
the
error and optimizer for doing deduction
of the error what optimizer are we using
so we are using gradient descent
optimizer we discussed about this in a
couple of slides
earlier and for that you need to specify
the learning rate you remember we saw
that there was a slide somewhat like
this and then you define what should be
the learning rate how fast you need to
come down that is the learning rate and
this again needs to be tested and tried
and to find out the optimum level of
this learning rate it shouldn't be very
high in which case it will not converge
or shouldn't be very low because it will
in that case it will take very long so
you define the optimizer and then you
call the method
minimize for that optimizer and that
will kick start the training process and
so far we've been creating the graph and
in order to actually execute that graph
we create what is known as a session and
then we run that session and once the
training is completed we specify how
many times how many iterations we want
it to run so for example in this case we
are saying thousand steps so that is a
exit strategy in a way so you specify
the exit condition so training will run
for thousand iterations and once that is
done we can then evaluate the model
using some of the techniques
shown here so let us
get into the code quickly and see how it
works so this is our cloud environment
now you can install tensorflow on your
local machine as well i'm showing this
demo on our existing cloud but you can
also install tensorflow on your local
machine and there is a separate video on
how to set up your tensorflow
environment you can watch that if you
want to install your local environment
or you can go for other any cloud
service like for example google cloud
amazon or cloud labs any of these you
can
use and
run and try the code okay so it has got
started
we will login
all right so this is our deep learning
tutorial
code
and this is our tensorflow environment
and
so let's get started
the first we have seen a little bit of a
code walk through
in the slides as well now you will see
the actual code in action so the first
thing we need to do is import tensorflow
and then we will import the data and we
need to adjust the data in such a way
that
the
one hot is encoding is set to true one
hot encoding right as i explained
earlier so in this case the label values
will be shown appropriately
and if we just check what is the type of
the data so you can see that this is a
data sets python
data sets and if we
check the number of
images the way it looks so this is how
it looks it is an array of type float 32
similarly
the number if you want to see what is
the number of
training images there are
55 000 then there are test images 10 000
and then validation images 5 000. now
let's take a quick look at the data
itself visualization so we will use um
matplotlib for this
and
if we take a look at the shape now shape
gives us like the dimension of the
tensors or
or the arrays if you will so in this
case the training data set if we see the
size of the training data set using the
method shape it says there are 55 000
and
55 000 by 784 so remember the 784 is
nothing but the 28 by 28 28 into 28 so
that is equal to 784 so that's what it
is uh showing now we can take just uh
one image and just see what is the
the first image and see what is the
shape so again size obviously it is only
784
similarly you can
look at the image itself the data of the
first image itself so this is how it it
shows so large part of it will probably
be zeros because as you can imagine
in the image only certain areas are
written rest is
blank so that's why you will mostly see
0 say that it is black or white but then
there are these values are so the values
are actually they are scaled so their
values are between zero and one okay so
this is what you're seeing so certain
locations there are some values and then
other locations there are zeros
so
that is how the data is stored and
loaded
if we want to actually see what is the
value of the handwritten image
if you want to view it this is how you
view it so you
create like do this reshape and
matplotlib has this
feature to show you these images so we
will actually use the function called
i am show and then if you pass this
parameters appropriately
you will be able to see the different
images now i can change the values in
this position so which image we are
looking at right so we can say
if i want to see what is there in maybe
thousand
right so
5000 has three
similarly you can just say five what is
in five
five as eight
what is in fifty
again h so basically by the way if
you're wondering uh how i'm executing
this code shift enter
in case you're not familiar with jupiter
notebooks shift enter is how you
execute each cell individual cell and if
you want to execute the entire program
you can go here and say run all
so that is how
this code gets executed
and
here again we can check what is the
maximum value and what is the minimum
value of this pixel values as i
mentioned this is it is scaled so
therefore it is between the values lie
between 1 and 0. now this is
where we create our model
the first thing is to create the
required placeholders and variables and
that's what we are doing here as we have
seen in the slides so we create
one placeholder and we create two
variables which is for the weights and
biases these two variables are actually
matrices so
each variable has
784 by 10 actual values okay so
one for this 10 is for each neuron there
are 10 neurons and 784 is for the pixel
values inputs that are given which is 28
into 28
and the biases as i mentioned one for
each neuron so there will be 10 biases
they are stored in a variable by the
name b
and this is the graph which is basically
the multiplication of these matrix
multiplication of x into w and then the
bias is added for each of the neurons
and the whole idea is to minimize
the error so let me just execute i think
this code is executed then we define
what is our the y value is basically the
label value so this is another
placeholder we had x as one placeholder
and white underscore true as a second
placeholder and this will have values in
the form of uh 10 digit
10 digit
arrays and
since we said one hot encoded the
position which has a one value indicates
what is the
label for that particular number all
right then we have cross entropy which
is nothing but
the
loss
loss function
and we have the optimizer we have chosen
gradient descent as our optimizer then
the training process itself so the
training process is nothing but to
minimize
the cross entropy which is again nothing
but the
loss function
so we define all of this in the form of
a graph so up to here remember what we
have done is we have not exactly
executed any tensorflow code till now we
are just preparing the graph the
execution plan that's how the tensorflow
code works so the whole
structure and format of this code will
be completely different from how we
normally do programming so even with
people with programming experience may
find this a little difficult to
understand it and it needs quite a bit
of practice
so you may want to view this
video also maybe a couple of times to
understand this flow
because the way tensorflow programming
is done is
slightly different from the normal
programming some of you who let's say
have done
maybe spark programming to some extent
will be able to easily understand this
but even in spark the the programming
the code itself is pretty
straightforward behind the scenes the
execution happens slightly differently
but in tensorflow even the code has to
be written in a completely different way
so the code doesn't get executed
in the same way as you have written so
that that's something you need to
understand and a little bit of practice
is needed for this
so so far what we have done up to here
is creating
the variables and feeding the variables
and
rather not feeding but setting up the
variables and
the graph that's all defining maybe the
what kind of a network you want to use
for example we want to use a softmax and
so on so you have created the variables
how to load the data loaded the data
viewed the data
and prepared everything but you have not
yet executed anything in tensorflow now
the next step is the execution intensive
law so the first step for
doing any execution in tensorflow is to
initialize the variables so anytime you
have any variables defined in your code
you have to
run this piece of code always so you
need to basically create what is known
as a a node for initializing so this is
a node you still are not yet executing
anything here you just created a node
for the initialization
so let us go ahead and create that
and
here onwards is where you will actually
execute your code
in tensorflow and in order to execute
the code what you will need is a session
tensorflow session so tf.session will
give you a session and there are a
couple of different ways in which you
can do this but one of the most common
methods of doing this is with what is
known as a width loop so you have a
width
tf dot session as says and with the
colon here and this is like a block
starting of the block and these
indentations tell how far this block
goes and
this session is valid
till
this block gets executed so that is the
purpose of creating this width block
this is known as a width block so with
tf.session as says you say says
dot run init now says dot run will
execute a node that is
specified here so for example here we
are saying says dot run says is
basically an instance of the session
right so here we are saying tf.session
so an instance of the session gets
created and we are calling that
says and then we run
a node within that one of the nodes in
the graph so one of the nodes here is
init
so we say run that particular node and
that is when the initialization of the
variables happens now what this does is
if you have any
variables in your code in our case we
have w
is a variable and b is a variable so any
variables that we created you have to
run this code you have to run the
initialization of these variables
otherwise you will get an error okay so
that is the that's what this is doing
then
we within this width block we specify a
for loop
and we are saying
we want the system to iterate for
thousand steps and perform
the training
that's what this for loop does
run training for thousand iterations
and what it is doing basically is it is
fetching
the data or these images remember there
are about 50 000 images but it cannot
get all the images in one shot because
it will take up a lot of memory and
performance issues will be there so this
is a very common way of performing deep
learning training you always do in
batches so we have maybe 50 000 images
but you always do it in batches of 100
or maybe
500 depending on the size of your
system and so on and so forth so in this
case we are saying okay get me 100
images at a time and get me only the
training images remember we use only the
training data for training purpose and
then we use test data for test purpose
you must be familiar with machine
learning so you must be aware of this
but in case you are not in machine
learning also not this is not specific
to deep learning but in machine learning
in general you have what is known as
training data set and test data set your
available data typically you will be
splitting into two parts and using the
training data set for training purpose
and then to see how well the model has
been trained you use the test data set
to check or test the validity or the
accuracy of the model so that's what we
are doing here and you observe here that
we are actually calling an mnist
function here so we are saying mnist
train dot next batch
right so this is the advantage of using
mnist database because they have
provided some very nice helper functions
which are readily available otherwise
this activity itself we would have had
to write a piece of code to fetch this
data in batches that itself is a lengthy
exercise so we can avoid all that if we
are using mnist database and that's why
we use this for the initial learning
phase okay so when we say fetch what it
will do is it will fetch the images into
x and the labels into y and then you
use this
batch of hundred images and you run the
training so says dot run basically what
we are doing here is we are running the
training mechanism which is nothing but
it passes this through the neural
network passes the images through the
neural network finds out what is the
output and if the output obviously they
initially it will be wrong so all that
feedback is given back to the neural
network and thereby all the w's and b's
get updated
till it reaches thousand iterations in
this case
the exit criteria is thousand but you
can also specify probably accuracy rate
or something like that for the as an
exit criteria so here it is it just says
that okay this particular image was
wrongly predicted so you need to update
your weights and biases that's the
feedback given to each neuron and that
is run for 1000 iterations and typically
by the end of this thousand iterations
the model would have learned to
recognize these handwritten images
obviously it will not be 100 accurate
okay so once that is done
after so this happens for 1000
iterations once that is done
you then test the accuracy of these
models by using the test data set
right so this is what we are trying to
do here the code may appear a little
complicated because if you're seeing
this for the first time you need to
understand uh the various methods of
tensorflow and so on but it is basically
comparing the output with
what has been what is actually there
that's all it is doing so you have your
test data and you're trying to find out
what is the actual value and what is the
predicted value and seeing whether they
are equal or not tf.equal right and how
many of them are correct and so on and
so forth and based on that the accuracy
is
calculated as well so this is the
accuracy
and that is what we are trying to see
how accurate the model is in predicting
these numbers or these digits okay so
let us run this this entire thing is in
one cell so we will have to just run it
in one shot it may take a little while
let us see
and
not bad so it has finished the thousand
iterations and what we see here as an
output is the accuracy so we see that
the accuracy of this model is around 91
percent okay now which is
pretty good for such a short exercise
within such a short time we got 90
percent accuracy however in real life
this is probably not sufficient so there
are other ways in to increase the
accuracy we will see probably in some of
the later tutorials how to improve this
accuracy how to change maybe the hyper
parameters like number of neurons or
number of layers and so on and so forth
and
so that this accuracy can be increased
beyond 90 percent we're going to dive
right into what is keras we'll also go
all the way through this into a couple
of tutorials because that's where you
really learn a lot is when you roll up
your sleeves so we talk about what is
cross cross is a high level deep
learning api written in python for easy
implement implementation
of neural networks uses deep learning
frameworks such as tensorflow pytorch
etc as back in to make computation
faster
and this is really nice because as a
programmer there is so much stuff out
there and it's evolving so fast
it can get confusing and having some
kind of high level order in there we can
actually view it and easily program
these different neural networks
is really powerful it's really powerful
to
have something out really quick
and also be able to start testing your
models and seeing where you're going
so crossworks by using complex deep
learning frameworks such as tensorflow
pytorch
ml played etc as a back end for fast
computation
while providing a user friendly and easy
to learn front-end and you can see here
we have the cross api specifications
and under that you'd have like tf cross
for tensorflow thano cross and so on and
then you have your tensorflow workflow
that this is all sitting on top of
and this is like i said it organizes
everything the heavy lifting is still
done by tensorflow
or whatever you know underlying package
you put in there and this is really nice
because you don't have to
dig as deeply into the heavy end stuff
while still having a very robust package
you can get up and running rather
quickly
and it doesn't distract from the
processing time because all the heavy
lifting is done by packages like
tensorflow this is the organization on
top of it
so the working principle of cross
the working principle of keras is cross
uses computational graphs to express and
evaluate mathematical expressions
you can see here we put them in blue
they have the expression
expressing complex problems as a
combination of simple mathematical
operators uh where we have like the
percentage or in this case in python
that's usually your uh left your
remainder
or multiplication uh you might have the
operator of x to the power of 0.3 and it
uses useful for calculating derivatives
by using uh back propagation so if we're
doing with neural networks when we send
the error back up to figure out how to
change it
this makes it really easy to do that
without
really having not banging your head and
having to handwrite everything it's
easier to implement distributed
computation and for solving complex
problems uh specify input and outputs
and make sure all nodes are connected
and so this is really nice as you come
in through is that as your layers are
going in there you can get some very
complicated
different setups nowadays which we'll
look at in just a second
and this just makes it really easy to
start spinning this stuff up and trying
out the different models
so we look across models across model we
have a sequential model
sequential model is a linear stack of
layers where the previous layer leads
into the next layer
and this if you've done anything else
even like the sk learn with their neural
networks and propagation and any of
these setups this should look familiar
you should have your input layer it goes
into your layer 1 layer 2 and then to
the output layer
and it's useful for simple classifier
decoder models
and you can see down here we have the
model equals across sequential this is
the actual code you can see how easy it
is
uh we have a layer that's dense your
layer one has an activation now they're
using the relu in this particular
example and then you have your name
layer one layer dense relu name layer
two and so forth
and they just feed right into each other
so it's really easy just to stack them
as you can see here and it automatically
takes care of everything else for you
and then there's a functional model and
this is really where things are at this
is new make sure you update your cross
or you'll find yourself running this
doing the functional model you'll run
into an error code because this is a
fairly new release
and he uses multi-input and multi-output
model the complex model which forks into
two or more branches
and you can see here we have our image
inputs equals your cross input shape
equals 32 by 32 by three
you have your dense layers dense 64
activation relu
this should look similar to what you
already saw before
but if you look at the graph on the
right it's going to be a lot easier to
see what's going on
you have two different inputs
and one way you can think of this is
maybe one of those is a small image and
one of those is a full sized image
and
that feedback goes into you might feed
both of them into one note because it's
looking for one thing and then only into
one node for the other one and so you
can start to get kind of an idea that
there's a lot of use
for this kind of split and this kind of
setup
we have multiple information coming in
but the information is very different
even though it overlaps and you don't
want it to send it through the same
neural network
and they're finding that this trains
faster and is also has a better result
depending on how you split the date up
and you and how you fork the models
coming down
and so in here we do have the two
complex models coming in uh we have our
image inputs which is a 32 by 32 by
three or three channels or four if you
have an alpha channel
you have your dense your layers dense is
64 activation using the relu very common
x equals dense inputs x layers dense x64
activation equals relu x outputs equals
layers dense 10
x model equals cross model inputs equals
inputs outputs equals outputs name
equals minced model
uh so we add a little name on there and
again this is this kind of split here
this is setting us up to
have the input go into different areas
so if you're already looking at cross
you probably already have this answer
what are neural networks
but it's always good to get on the same
page and for those people who don't
fully understand neural networks to dive
into them a little bit or do a quick
overview
neural networks are deep learning
algorithms modeled after the human brain
they use multiple neurons which are
mathematical operations to break down
and solve complex mathical problems
and so just like the neuron one neuron
fires in and it fires out to all these
other neurons or nodes as we call them
and eventually they all come down to
your output layer
and you can see here we have the really
standard graph input layer a hidden
layer and an output layer
one of the biggest parts of any data
processing is your data pre-processing
so we always have to touch base on that
with a neural network like many of these
models
they're kind of uh when you first start
using them they're like a black box you
put your data in
you train it and you test it and see how
good it was
and you have to pre-process that data
because bad data in is
bad outputs so in data pre-processing we
will create our own data examples set
with cross the data consists of a
clinical trial conducted on 2100
patients ranging from ages 13 to 100
with a the patients under 65 and the
other half over 65 years of age
we want to find the possibility of a
patient experiencing side effects due to
their age
and you can think of this in today's
world with uh covid
uh what's gonna happen on there and
we're gonna go ahead and do an example
of that in our uh
live hands-on like i said most of this
you really need to have hands-on to
understand so let's go ahead and bring
up our anaconda
and open that up and open up a jupiter
notebook for doing the python code in
now if you're not familiar with those
you can use pretty much any of your
setups i just like those for doing demos
and showing people especially
shareholders
it really helps because it's a nice
visual so let me go and flip over to our
anaconda and the anaconda has a lot of
cool two tools they just added data lore
and ibm watson studio cloud into the
anaconda framework
but we'll be in the jupiter lab or
jupiter notebook i'm going to do jupiter
notebook for this because i use the lab
for like large projects with multiple
pieces because multiple tabs where the
notebook will work fine for what we're
doing
and this opens up in our browser window
because that's how jupiter how it's our
jupiter
notebook is set to run
and we'll go under new
create a new python3 and uh it creates
an untitled python we'll go ahead and
give this a title and we'll just call
this a cross
tutorial
and let's change that to capital there
we go i'm going to just rename that and
the first thing we want to go ahead and
do
is uh
get some pre-processing tools involved
and so we need to go ahead and import
some stuff for that like our numpy do
some random number generation
i mentioned sk learn or your site kit if
you're installing sk learn the sk learn
stuff it's a scikit you want to look up
that should be a tool of anybody who is
doing data science if you're not if
you're not familiar with the sklearn
toolkit
it's huge but there's so many things in
there that we always go back to
and we want to go ahead and create some
train labels and train samples for
training our data
and then
just a note of what we're we're actually
doing in here let me go ahead and change
this this is kind of a fun thing you can
do we can change the code to markdown
and then markdown code is nice for doing
examples once you've already built this
our example data we're going to do
experimental
there we go
experimental drug was tested on 2100
individuals between 13 to 100 years of
age
half the participants are under 65 and
95 percent of participants are under 65
experience no side effects well 95
percent of participants over 65 percent
experience side effects
so that's kind of where we're starting
at
and this is just a real quick example
because we're going to do another one
with a little bit more
complicated information
and so we want to go ahead and generate
our setup
so we want to do for i and range and we
want to go ahead and create if you look
here we have random integers
train the labels append so we're just
creating some random data
let me go ahead and just run that
and so once we've created our random
data
and if you if i mean you can certainly
ask for a copy of the code from
simplylearn they'll send you a copy of
this or you can
zoom in on the video and see how we went
ahead and did our train samples a pin
um
and we're just using this i do this kind
of stuff all the time i was running a
thing on uh they had to do with errors
following a bell-shaped curve on a
standard distribution error
and so what do i do i generate the data
on a standard distribution error to see
what it looks like and how my code
processes it since that was the baseline
i was looking for in this we're just
doing uh generating random data for our
setup on here
and we could actually go in
print some of the data up let's just do
this print
we'll do
train samples
and we'll just do the first
five pieces of data in there to see what
that looks like
and you can see the first five pieces of
data in our train samples is 49 85 41 68
19.
just random numbers generated in there
that's all that is and we generated
significantly more than that
um let's see 50 up here 1000. yeah so
there's 1000 here 1000 numbers we
generated and we could also if we wanted
to find that out we could do a quick
print the length of it
and
so or you could do a shape kind of thing
and if you're using numpy
although the link for this is just fine
and there we go it's actually 2100 like
we said in the demo setup in there
and then we want to go ahead and take
our labels oh that was our train labels
we also did samples didn't we
uh so we could also print
do the same thing
labels
and let's change this to
labels
and labels
and run that just to double check and
sure enough we have 2100 and they're
labeled one zero one zero one zero i
guess that's if they have symptoms or
not one symptoms zero none and so we
wanna go ahead and take our train labels
and we'll convert it into a numpy array
and the same thing with our samples
and let's go ahead and run that
and we also shuffle uh this is just a
neat feature you can do in numpy right
here
i put my drawing thing on which i didn't
have on earlier
i can take the data and i can shuffle it
so we have our so it's it just
randomizes it that's all that's doing
um we've already randomized it so it's
kind of an overkill it's not really
necessary
but if you're doing a larger package
where the data's coming in and a lot of
times it's organized somehow and you
want to randomize it just to make sure
that that you know the input doesn't
follow a certain pattern
that might create a bias in your model
and we go ahead and create a scalar uh
the scalar range minimum max scalar
feature range zero to one
uh and then we go ahead and scale the uh
scaled train samples so we're gonna go
ahead and fit and transform the data
uh so it's nice and scaled and that is
the age uh so you can see up here we
have 49 85 41. we're just moving that so
it's going to be between 0 and 1. and so
this is true with any of your neural
networks
you really want to convert the data uh
to zero and one otherwise you create a
bias
uh so if you have like a hundred creates
a bias versus
the math behind it gets really
complicated um
if you actually start multiplying stuff
there's a lot of multiplication addition
going on in there
that higher end value will eventually
multiply down and it will have a huge
bias as to how the model
fits it and then it will not fit as well
and then one of the fun things we can do
in jupiter notebook is that if you have
a variable you're not doing anything
with it it's the last one on the line
it will automatically print
um and we're just going to look at the
first five samples on here it's just
going to print the first five samples
and you can see here we go 0.9195.791
so everything's between 0 and 1.
and that just shows us that we scaled it
properly and it looks good it really
helps a lot to do these kind of print
ups halfway through
you never know what's going to go on
there
i don't know how many times i've gotten
down and found out that the data is sent
to me that i thought was scaled was not
and then i have to go back and track it
down and figure it out on there
so let's go ahead and create our
artificial neural network
and for doing that this is where we
start diving into tensorflow and cross
tensorflow
if you don't know the history of
tensorflow
it helps to jump into we'll just use
wikipedia
be careful don't quote wikipedia on
these things because you get in trouble
but it's a good place to start back in
2011 google brain built disbelief as a
proprietary machine learning setup
tensorflow became the open source for it
so tensorflow was a google product
and then it became
uh open sourced and now it's just become
probably one of the defactos when it
comes for neural networks as far as
where we're at
so when you see the tensorflow setup
it's got like a huge following there are
some other setups like
the scikit under the sk learn has their
own little neural network
but the tensorflow is the most robust
one out there right now
and cross sitting on top of it makes it
a very powerful tool so we can leverage
both the cross
easiness in which we can build a
sequential setup
on top of tensorflow
and so in here we're going to go ahead
and do our input of tensorflow
uh and then we have the rest of this is
all cross here from number two down
uh
we're going to import from tensorflow
the cross connection
and then you have your tensorflow cross
models import sequential it's a specific
kind of model we'll look at that in just
a second if you remember
from the files that means it goes from
one layer to the next layer to the next
layer there's no funky splits or
anything like that
and then we have from tensorflow cross
layers we're going to import our
activation and our dense layer
and we have our optimizer atom
this is a big thing to be aware of how
you optimize
your data when you first do it adam's as
good as any atom is usually there's a
number of optimizer out there there's
about there's a couple of main ones but
atom is usually assigned to bigger data
it works fine usually the lower data
does it just fine but atom is probably
the mostly used but there are some more
out there and depending on what you're
doing with your layers your different
layers might have different activations
on them and then finally down here
you'll see
our setup where we want to go ahead and
use the metrics
and we're going to use the tensorflow
cross metrics
for categorical cross entropy
so we can see how everything performs
when we're done that's all that is a lot
of times you'll see us
go back and forth between tensorflow and
then scikit has a lot of really good
metrics also for measuring these things
again it's the end of the you know at
the end of the story how good does your
model do and we'll go ahead and load all
that and then comes the fun part
i actually like to spend hours messing
with these
things and
four lines of code you're like oh you're
gonna spend hours on four lines of code
um no we don't spend hours on four lines
of code that's not what we're talking
about when i say spend hours on four
lines of code uh what we have here i'm
to explain that in just a second we have
a model and it's a sequential model if
you remember correctly we mentioned the
sequential up here where it goes from
one layer to the next
and our first layer is going to be our
input
it's going to be what they call dents
which is
usually just dense and then you have
your input and your activation
how many units are coming in we have 16
what's the shape
what's the activation and this is where
it gets interesting um because we have
in here
uh relu
on two of these and soft max activation
on one of these
there are so many different options
for
what these mean
and how they function how does the relu
how does the soft max function
and they do a lot of different things
we're not going to go into the
activations in here that is what really
you spend hours doing is looking at
these different activations
and just
some of it is just
almost like you're playing with it
like an artist you start getting a fill
for like an uh inverse tangent
activation or the 10h activation
takes up a huge processing amount
so you don't see it a lot
yet
it comes up with a better solution
especially when you're doing uh when
you're analyzing word documents and
you're tokenizing the words
and so you'll see this shift from one to
the other because you're both trying to
build a better model
and if you're working on a huge data set
um you'll crash the system it'll just
take too long to process
and then you see things like soft max
softmax
generates an interesting
where a lot of these when you talk about
rayleigh oops let me do this uh rayleigh
there we go raelu has
a setup where if it's less than zero
it's zero and then it goes up and then
you might have what they call lazy
setup where it has a slight negative to
it so that the errors can translate
better same thing with softmax it has a
slight laziness to it so that errors
translate better all these little
details
make a huge difference on your model
so one of the really cool things about
data science that i like is you build
your
what they call you build to fail and
it's an interesting
design setup oops i forgot the end of my
code here
the concept of build a file is you want
the model as a whole to work so you can
test your model out
so that you can do
uh
you can get to the end and you can do
your let's see where was it
over shot down here
you can test your test out the quality
of your setup on there
and
see where did i do my tensorflow oh here
we go i did it was right above me there
we go we start doing your cross entropy
and stuff like that is you need a full
functional set of code so that when you
run it
you can then test your model out and say
hey it's either this model works better
than this model and this is why
um and then you can start swapping in
these models and so when i say spend a
huge amount of time on pre-processing
data it's probably 80 of your
programming time
well between those two it's like 80 20.
you'll spend a lot of time on the models
once you get the model down once you get
the whole code and the flow down
set
depending on your data your models get
more and more robust as you start
experimenting with different inputs
different data streams and all kinds of
things and we can do a simple model
summary here
here's our sequential here's a layer
output a parameter
is one of the nice things about cross is
you just you can see right here here's
our sequential one model boom boom boom
boom everything's set and clear and easy
to read
so once we have our model built uh the
next thing we're going to want to do is
we're going to go ahead
and
train that model
and so the next step is of course model
training
and when we come in here
this a lot of times it's just paired
with the model because it's so
straightforward
it's nice to
print out the model setup so you can
have a tracking
but here's our model
the keyword in cross is compile
optimizer atom learning rate another
term right there that we're just
skipping right over
that really becomes the meat of um
the setup is your learning rate uh so
whoops i forgot that i had an arrow but
i'll just underline it
a lot of times the learning rate set to
0.0
set to 0.01
depending on what you're doing
this learning rate
can overfit and underfit
so you'd want to look up
i know we have a number of tutorials out
on overfitting and under fitting that
are really worth reading once you get to
that point and understanding and we have
our loss
sparse categorical cross entropy
so this is going to tell keras how far
to go until it stops
and then we're looking for metrics of
accuracy so we'll go ahead and run that
and now that we've compiled our model
we want to go ahead and
run it fit it so here's our model fit
we have our scale to train samples
our train labels our validation split
in this case we're going to use 10
percent of the data for validation
uh batch size another number you kind of
play with not a huge difference as far
as how it works
but it does affect how long it takes to
run and it can also affect the bias a
little bit
most of the time though a batch size is
between 10 to 100
depending on just how much data you're
processing in there we want to go ahead
and shuffle it we're going to go through
30 epics
and
for the verb rose of two let me just go
ahead and run this
and you can see right here here's our
epic here's our training
here's our loss
now if you remember correctly up here we
set the loss let's see where was it
compiled our data
there we go loss uh so it's looking at
the sparse categorical cross entropy
this tells us that as it goes how how
how much um how how much does the
error go down
is the best way to look at that and you
can see here the lower the number the
better it just keeps going down
and vice versa accuracy we want let's
see where's my accuracy
value accuracy at the end and you can
see 0.619 0.69 0.74 it's going up we
want the accuracy would be ideal if it
made it all the way to 1
but we also the loss is
more important because
it's a balance
you can have 100 accuracy and your model
doesn't work because it's over fitted
again you won't look up
overfitting and under fitting models
and we went ahead and went through
30 epics it's always fun to kind of
watch your code going um to be honest i
usually
the first time i run it i'm like oh
that's cool i get to see what it does
and after the second time of running it
i'm like i'd like to just not see that
and you can repress those of course in
your code
repress the warnings in the printing
and so the next step is going to be
building a test set and predicting it
now
so here we go we want to go ahead and
build our test set
and we have just like we did our
training set
a lot of times you just split your your
initial set up
uh but we'll go ahead and do a separate
set on here
and this is just what we did above
there's no difference as far as
the randomness that we're using to build
this set on here
the only difference is that
we already
did our scalar up here well it doesn't
matter because the the data is going to
be across the same thing but this should
just be just transform down here instead
of fit transform
because you don't want to refit your
data
on your
testing data
there we go now we're just transforming
it because you never want to transform
the test data
easy to mistake to make especially on an
example like this where we're not doing
you know we're randomizing the data
anyway so it doesn't matter too much
because we're not expecting something
weird
and then we went ahead and do our
predictions the whole reason we built
the model as we take our model we
predict and we're going to do here's our
x scale data batch size 10 verbose
and now we have our predictions in here
and we could go ahead and do a
oh we'll print
predictions
and then i guess i could just put down
predictions in five so we can look at
the first five of the predictions
and what we have here is we have our
age and uh the prediction on this age
versus what is what we think it's going
to be but what we think is gonna they're
gonna have uh symptoms or not
and the first thing we notice is that's
hard to read because we really wanna yes
no answer
so we'll go ahead and just
round off the predictions
using the arg max
the numpy arg max for prediction so it
just goes to zero one
and
if you remember this is a jupiter
notebook so i don't have to put the
print i can just put in
rounded predictions and we'll just do
the first five
and you can see here zero one zero zero
zero so that's what the predictions are
that we have coming out of this
is no symptoms symptoms no symptoms
symptoms no symptoms
and just as we were talking about at the
beginning we want to go ahead and
take a look at this there we go
confusion matrixes for accuracy check
most important part
when you get down to the end of the
story how accurate is your model before
you go and play with the model and see
if you can get a better accuracy out of
it and for this we'll go ahead and use
the site kit
the sk learn metrics
site kit being where that comes from
import confusion matrix
some iteration tools and of course a
nice matplot library
that makes a big difference so it's
always nice to
have a nice graph to look at a
picture is worth a thousand words
and then we'll go ahead and call it cm
for confusion matrix why true equals
test labels why predict rounded
predictions
i'll go ahead and load in our cm
and i'm not going to spend too much time
on the plotting
going over the different plotting code
you can spend
like whole we have whole tutorials on
how to do your different plotting on
there
but we do have here is we're going to do
a plot confusion matrix there's our cm
our classes normalize false title
confusion matrix
c map is going to be in blues
and you can see here we have to the
nearest c map titles all the different
pieces whether you put tick marks or not
the marks the classes the color bar
so a lot of different information on
here as far as how we're doing the
printing of the of the confusion matrix
you can also just dump the confusion
matrix into a seaborn and real quick get
an output
it's worth knowing how to do all this uh
when you're doing a presentation to the
shareholders
you don't want to do this on the fly you
want to take the time to make it look
really nice like our guys in the back
did and let's go ahead and do this
forgot to put together our cm plot
labels
we'll go ahead and run that
and then we'll go ahead and call the
little the definition
for our mapping
and you can see here plot confusion
matrix that's our the little script we
just wrote and we're going to dump our
data into it
so our confusion matrix
our classes
title confusion matrix and let's just go
ahead and run that
and you can see here we have our basic
setup
no side effects 195
had side effects 200
no side effects that had side effects so
we predicted the 10 of them
who actually had side effects and that's
pretty good i mean i i don't know about
you but you know that's five percent
error on this and this is because
there's 200 here that's where i get five
percent is uh divide these both by by
two and you get five out of a hundred uh
you can do the same kind of math up here
not as quick on the fly because it's 15
and 195 not an easily rounded number but
you can see here where they have 15
people
who predicted to have no uh with the no
side effects but had side effects
kind of set up on there and these
confusion matrix are so important at the
end of the day
this is really where where you show
whatever you're working on comes up and
you can actually show them hey this is
how good we are or not how messed up it
is
so this was a
i spent a lot of time on some of the
parts but you can see here is really
simple uh we did the random generation
of data but when we actually built the
model coming up here
here's our model summary
and we just have the layers on here that
we built with our model on this and then
we went ahead and trained it and ran the
prediction
now we can get a lot more complicated
let me flip back on over here because
we're going to do another demo
so that was our basic introduction to it
we talked about the uh oops there we go
okay so implementing a neural network
with cross after creating our samples
and labels we need to create our cross
neural network model we will be working
with a sequential model which has three
layers and this is what we did we had
our input layer our hidden layers and
our output layers and you can see the
input layer coming in
was the age factor we had our hidden
layer and then we had the output are you
going to have symptoms or not
so we're going to go ahead and go with
something a little bit more complicated
training our model is a two-step process
we first compile our model and then we
train it in our training data set
so we have compiling compiling converts
the code into a form of understandable
by machine
we use the atom in the last example a
gradient descent algorithm to optimize a
model and then we trained our model
which means it let it uh learn on
training data
uh
and i actually had a little backwards
there but this is what we just did is we
if you remember from our code we just
had let me go back here
here's our model that we created
summarized
we come down here and we compile it
so it tells it hey we're ready to build
this model and use it
and then we train it this is the part
where we go ahead and fit our model and
and put that information in here and it
goes through the training on there
and of course we scaled the data which
was really important to do and then you
saw we did the creating a confusion
matrix with keras
as we are performing classifications on
our data we need a confusion matrix to
check the results a confusion matrix
breaks down the various
misclassifications as well as correct
classifications to get the accuracy
and so you can see here this is what we
did with the true positive false
positive true negative false negative
and that is what we went over let me
just scroll down here
on the end we printed it out and you can
see we have a nice printout of our
confusion matrix
uh with the true positive false positive
false negative true negative and so the
blue ones uh we want those to be the
biggest numbers because those are the
better side and then
we have our false predictions on here
as far as this one so i had no side
effects but we predicted
let's see no side effects predicting
side effects and vice versa if getting
your learning started is half the battle
what if you could do that for free
visit scale up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
now
saving and loading models with karas
we're going to dive into a more
complicated demo
and you can say oh that was a lot of
complication before well if you broke it
down we randomized some data we created
the
keras setup we compiled it we trained it
we predicted and we ran our matrix
uh so we're going to dive into something
a lot a little bit more fun is we're
going to do a face mask detection with
karass so we're going to build a cross
model to check if a person is wearing a
mask or not in real time and this might
be important if you're at the front of a
store this is something today which is
might be very useful as far as some of
our you know making sure people are safe
and so we're going to look at mask and
no mask and let's start with a little
bit on the data
and so in my data i have with a mask you
can see they just have a number of
images showing the people in masks and
again
if you want some of this information
contact simply learn and they can send
you some of the information as far as
people with and without masks so you can
try it on your own and this is just such
a wonderful example of this setup on
here
so before i dive into the mass detection
uh talk about being in the current with
uh covid and
seeing if people are wearing masks
this particular example i had to go
ahead and update to a python 3.8 version
uh it might run in a three seven i'm not
sure i kind of skipped three seven and
installed three eight
uh so i'll be running in a three python
three eight
and then you also wanna make sure your
tensorflow is up to date
because the um they call functional
layers with that's where they split if
you remember correctly from back
let's take a look at this
remember from here the functional model
and a functional layer allows us to feed
in the different layers into different
you know different nodes into different
layers and split them a very powerful
tool
very popular right now in the edge of
where things are with neural networks
and creating a better model so i've
upgraded to python 3.8 and let's go
ahead and open that up and
go through
our next example which includes
multiple layers
programming it to recognize whether
someone wears a mask or not and then
saving that model so we can use it in
real time so we're actually almost a
full
end-to-end development of a product here
of course this is a very simplified
version and it'd be a lot more to it
you'd also have to do like recognizing
whether it's someone's face or not all
kinds of other things go into this
so let's go ahead and jump into that
code
and we'll open up a new python three
oops python three
it's working on it there we go
and then we want to go ahead and train
our mask we'll just call this train mask
and we want to go ahead and train mask
and save it
so it's it's uh it's safe mask train
mask detection
not to be confused with masking data a
little bit different we're actually
talking about a physical mask on your
face
and then from the cross standpoint we
got a lot of imports to do here
and i'm not going to dig too deep on the
imports
we're just going to go ahead and notice
a few of them uh so we have in
here we go alt d there we go
i have something to draw with a little
bit here
we have our
image processing
and the image processing right here the
underline that
deals with how do we bring images in
because most images
are like a
a square grid and then each value in
there has three values for the three
different colors
uh cross and tensorflow do a really good
job of working with that so you don't
have to do all the heavy listening and
figuring out what's going to go on
and we have the mobile net average
pooling 2d
this again is
how do we deal with the images and
pulling them
dropout's a cool thing worth looking up
if you haven't when you as you get more
and more into cross and tensorflow
it will auto drop out certain notes that
way you'll get a better
the notes just kind of die
and they find that they actually create
more of a bias and help
and they also add processing time so
they remove them
and then we have our flatten that's
where you take that huge array with the
three different colors and you find a
way to flatten it so it's just a one
dimensional array instead of a two by
two by three
uh dense input we did that in the other
one so that should look a little
familiar
oops there we go our input our model
again these are things we had on the
last one
here's our optimizer with our atom
we have some pre-processing on the input
that goes along with bringing the data
in
more pre-processing with image to array
loading the image
this stuff is so nice it looks like a
lot of works you have to import all
these different modules in here but the
truth is is it does everything for you
you're not doing a lot of pre-processing
you're letting the software do the
pre-processing
and we're going to be working with the
setting something to categorical
again that's just a conversion from a
number to a category zero one doesn't
really mean anything it's like true
false
label binarizer the same thing
we're changing our labels around and
then there's our train test split
classification report
our
im utilities let me just go ahead and
scroll down here a notch for these
this is something a little different
going on down here this is not part of
the
tensorflow or the sklearn this is the
site kit setup and tensorflow above
the path this is part of
opencv
and we'll actually have another tutorial
going out with the opencv so if you want
to know more about opencv you'll get a
glance on it in
this software especially the
second piece when we reload up the data
and hook it up to a video camera we're
going to do that on this round
but this is part of the opencv thing
you'll see cv2 is usually how that's
referenced
but the im utilities has to do with how
do you rotate pictures around and stuff
like that
and resize them and then the matplot
library for plotting because it's nice
to have a graph tells us how good we're
doing and then of course our numpy
numbers array and just the straight os
access wow so that was a lot of imports
like i said i'm not going to spend i
spent a little time going through them
but we didn't want to go too much into
them
and then i'm going to create
some variables that we need to go ahead
and initialize
we have the learning rate number of
epics to train for and the batch size
and if you remember correctly we talked
about the learning rate
to the negative 4.0001
a lot of times it's 0.001 or 0.001
usually it's in that
variation depending on what you're doing
and how many epochs and they kind of
play with the epics
the epics is how many times we're going
to go through all the data
and now i have it as two
the actual setup is for 20
and 20 works great the reason i have it
for two is it takes a long time to
process
one of the downsides of jupiter
is that jupiter isolates it to a single
kernel so even though i'm on an eight
core processor
with 16 dedicated threads only one
thread is running on this no matter what
so it doesn't matter
so it takes a lot longer to run even
though
tensorflow really scales up nicely and
the batch size is how many pictures do
we load at once in process
again those are numbers you have to
learn to play with depending on your
data and what's coming in and the last
thing we want to go ahead and do is
there's a directory with a data set
we're going to run
and this just has images of mass and not
masks
and if we go in here you'll see data set
and then you have pictures with mass
they're just images of people with mass
on their face
and then we have the opposite let me go
back up here
without masks so it's pretty
straightforward they look kind of askew
because they tried to format them into
very similar setup on there so they're
mostly squares you'll see some that are
slightly different on here
and that's kind of important thing to do
on a lot of these data sets
get them as close as you can to each
other and we'll we actually will run in
the in this processing of images up here
and the cross layers and importing and
dealing with images it does such a
wonderful job of converting these that a
lot of it we don't have to do a whole
lot with
so you have a couple things going on
there
and so we're now going to be this is now
loading the
images and let me see
and we'll go ahead and create data and
labels here's our
here's the features going in which is
going to be our pictures and our labels
going out
and then for categories in our list
directory directory and if you remember
i just flashed that at you it had a
face mask or or no face mask those are
the two options
and we're just going to load into that
we're going to append the image itself
and the labels so we'll just create a
huge array
and you can see right now this could be
an issue if you had more data at some
point
thankfully i have a 32 gig hard drive or
ram
even that
you could do with a lot less of that
probably under 16 or even eight gigs
would easily load all this stuff
and there's a conversion going on in
here i told you about how we are going
to convert the size of the image so it
resizes all the images that way our data
is all identical the way it comes in
and you can see here with our labels we
have without mask without mask without
mask
the other one would be with mask those
are the two that we have going in there
and then we need to change it to the one
not hot encoding
and this is going to take our
up here we had was it labels and data
we want the labels to be categorical so
we're going to take labels and change it
to categorical and our labels then equal
a categorical list
we'll run that and again if we do uh
labels and we just do the last or the
first 10 let's do the last 10 just
because
minus 10 to the end there we go
just so we can see where the other side
looks like we now have one that means
they have a mask one zero one zero so on
one being they have a mask and zero no
mask
and if we did this in reverse
i just realized that this might not make
sense if you've never done this before
let me run this
zero one
so zero
is
do they have a mask on zero do they not
have a mask on one so this is the same
as what we saw up here without mask one
equals
um the second value is without mass so
with mass without mask
and that's just a with any of your data
processing
we can't really zero if you have a zero
one output
uh
it causes issues as far as training and
setting it up so we always want to use a
one hot encoder if the values are not
actual uh linear value or regression
values they're not actual numbers
if they represent a thing
and so now we need to go ahead and do
our train x test x train y test y
train split test data
and we'll go ahead and make sure it's
going to be random and we'll take 20 of
it for testing and the rest for
setting it up as far as training their
model
this is something that's become so cool
when they're training these set
they realize we can augment the data
what does augment mean
well if i rotate the data around and i
zoom in i zoom out i rotate it
share it a little bit flip it
horizontally
fill mode as i do all these different
things to the data it
is able to it's kind of like increasing
the number of samples i have
so if i have all these perfect samples
what happens when we only have part of
the face or the face is tilted sideways
or
all those little shifts cause a problem
if you're doing just a standard set of
data so we're going to create an augment
in our image data generator
which is going to rotate zoom and do all
kinds of cool thing and this is worth
looking up this image data generator and
all the different features it has
a lot of times i'll the first time
through my models i'll leave that out
because i want to make sure there's a
thing we call build to fail which is
just cool to know
you build the whole process and then you
start adding these different things in
so that you can better train your model
and so we go and run this and then we're
going to load
and then we need to go ahead and you
probably would have gotten an error if
you hadn't put this piece in right here
um i haven't run it myself because the
guys in the back did this uh we take our
base model and one of the things we want
to do is we want to do a mobile net v2
um and this what we this is a big thing
right here include the top equals false
a lot of data comes in with a label on
the top row
so we want to make sure that that is not
the case
uh and then the construction of the head
of the model that will be placed on the
top of the base model
we want to go ahead and set that up
and you'll see a warning here i'm kind
of ignoring the warning because it has
to do with the
size of the pictures and the weights for
input shape
so they'll switch things to defaults
just saying hey we're going to auto
shape some of this stuff for you you
should be aware that with this kind of
imagery we're already augmenting it by
moving it around and flipping it and
doing all kinds of things to it
so that's not a bad thing in this but
another data it might be if you're
working in a different domain
and so we're going to go back here and
we're going to have we have our base
model we're going to do our head model
equals our base model output
and what we got here is we have an
average pooling 2d pool size 77 head
model
head model flattened
so we're flattening the data so this is
all
processing and flattening the images and
the pooling has to do
with some of the ways it can process
some of the data we'll look at that a
little bit when we get down to the lower
levels processing it
and then we have our dents we've already
talked a little bit about a dense just
what you think about and then the head
model has a drop out
of 0.5
what we can do with a dropout
the dropout says that we're going to
drop out a certain amount of nodes while
training
so when you actually use the model
it will use all the nodes but this drops
certain ones out and it helps
stop biases from forming so it's really
a cool feature in here they discovered
this a while back
we have another dense mode this time
we're using soft max activation
lots of different activation options
here softmax is a real popular one for a
lot of things
and so is the relu
and you know there's we could do a whole
talk on activation formulas uh and why
what their different uses are and how
they work
when you first start out you'll you'll
use mostly the relu and the softmax for
a lot of them
just because they're some of the basic
setups it's a good place to start
and then we have our model equals model
inputs equals base model dot input
outputs equals head model so again we're
still building our model here we'll go
ahead and run that
and then we're going to loop over all
the layers in the base model and freeze
them so they will not be updated during
the first training process
so for layer and base model layers
layers dot trainable equals false
a lot of times when you go through your
data
you want to kind of jump in part way
through
i
i'm not sure why in the back they did
this for this particular example
but i do this a lot when i'm working
with series and specifically in stock
data i wanted to iterate through the
first set of 30 data before it does
anything
i would have to look deeper to see why
they froze it on this particular one
and then we're going to compile our
model
so compiling the model atom
init layer decay
initial learning rate over epics and we
go ahead and compile our loss is going
to be the binary cross entropy which
we'll have that print out
optimizer for opt metrics is accuracy
same thing we had before not a huge jump
as far as
the previous code
and then we go ahead and we've gone
through all this and now we need to go
ahead and fit our model
so train the head of the network print
info training head run
now i skipped a little time because it
you'll see the run time here is um at 80
seconds per epic takes a couple minutes
for it to get through on a single kernel
one of the things i want you to notice
on here while we're while it's finishing
the processing
is that we have up here our augment
going on so
anytime the train x and trading y go in
there's some randomness going on there
and it's jiggling it around what's going
into our setup
of course we're batch sizing it so it's
going through whatever we set for the
batch values how many we process at a
time
and then we have the steps per epic uh
the train x the batch size validation
data here's our
test x and test y where we're sending
that in
and this again it's validation
one of the important things to know
about validation is
our
when both our training data and our test
data have about the same accuracy that's
when you want to stop that means that
our model isn't biased
if you have a higher accuracy on your
testing
you know you've trained it and your
accuracy is higher on your actual test
data then something in there is probably
uh has a bias and it's overfitted
so that's what this is really about
right here with the validation data and
validation steps
so it looks like it's let me go ahead
and see if it's done processing looks
like we've gone ahead and gone through
two epochs again you could run this
through about 20
with this amount of data and it would
give you a nice refined model at the end
we're going to stop at 2 because i
really don't want to sit around all
afternoon and i'm running this on a
single thread
so now that we've done this we're going
to need to evaluate
our model and see how good it is and to
do that we need to go ahead and make our
predictions
these are predictions on our test x
to see what it thinks are going to be
so now it's going to be evaluating the
network and then we'll go ahead and go
down here
and we will need to
turn the index in because remember it's
it's either zero or one it's a
zero one zero one so you have two
outputs uh not wearing uh wearing a mask
not wearing a mask
and so we need to go ahead and take that
argument at the end and change those
predictions to a
zero or one coming out
and then
to finish that off we want to go ahead
and let me just put this right in here
and do it all in one shot we want to
show a nicely formatted classification
report so we can see what that looks
like on here
and there we have it we have our
precision uh it's 97 with the mask
there's our f1 score support without a
mask 97 percent
so that's pretty high set up on there
you know you three people are going to
sneak into the store who
are without a mask and
thinks they have a mask and there's
going to be three people with a mask
that's going to flag the person at the
front to go oh hey look at this person
you might not have a mask
that's if i guess it's just set up in
front of a store
so there you have it and of course one
of the other cool things about this is
if someone's walking in to the store and
you take multiple pictures of them
you know this is just an it would be a
way of flagging and then you can take
that average of those pictures and make
sure they match or don't match if you're
on the back end and this is an important
step because we're gonna this is just
cool i love doing this stuff uh so we're
gonna go ahead and take our model and
we're gonna save it uh so model save
mass detector.model we're gonna give it
a name
we're going to save the format
in this case we're going to use the h5
format
and so this model we just programmed has
just been saved
so now i can load it up into say another
program what's cool about this is let's
say i want to have somebody work on the
other part of the program well i just
save the model they upload the model now
they can use it for whatever and then if
i get more information
and we start working with that at some
point
i might want to update this model and
make a better model and this is true of
so many things where i take this model
and maybe i'm running a prediction on
making money for a company and as my
model gets better
i want to keep updating it and then it's
really easy just to push that out to the
actual end user
uh here we have a nice graph you can see
the training loss and accuracy as we go
through the epics
we only did the you know only shows just
the one epic coming in here but you can
see right here as the
value loss train accuracy and value
accuracy
starts switching and they start
converging and you'll hear converging
this is a convergence they're talking
about when they say you're you're
i know when i work in the
scikit with sk learn neural networks
this is what they're talking about a
convergence is our loss and our accuracy
come together and also up here and this
is why i'd run it more than just two
epochs as you can see they still haven't
converged all the way
so that would be a cue for me to keep
going
but what we want to do is we want to go
ahead and create a new
python 3
program
and we just did our train mask so now
we're going to go ahead and import that
and use it and show you in a live action
get a view of both myself in the
afternoon along with my background of an
office which is in the middle still of
reconstruction for another month
and we'll call this a mask
detector
and then we're going to grab a bunch of
a few items coming in
we have our
mobile net v2 import pre-processing
input so we're still going to need that
we still have our tensorflow image to
array we have our load model that's
where most of this stuff is going on
this is our cv2 or opencv again i'm not
going to dig too deep into that we're
going to flash a little opencv code at
you
and we actually have a tutorial on that
coming out
our numpy array our im utilities which
is part of
the opencv or cv2 setup
uh and then we have of course time and
just our operating system so those are
the things we're going to go ahead and
set up on here
and then we're going to create
this takes just a moment
our module here which is going to do all
the heavy lifting
so we're going to detect and predict the
mask we have frame face net mass net
these are going to be generated by our
open cv we have our frame coming in and
then we want to go ahead and create a
mask around the face it's going to try
to detect the face and then set that up
so we know what we're going to be
processing through our model
and then there's a frame shape here this
is just our height versus width that's
all hw stands for
they've called it blob which is a cv2
dnn blob form image frame
so this is reformatting this frame
that's going to be coming in literally
from my camera and we'll show you that
in a minute that little piece of code
that shoots that in here
and we're going to pass the blob through
the network and obtain the face
detections
so face net dot set import blob
detections face net forward
print detections shape uh so these this
is what's going on here this is that
model we just created we're going to
send that in there and i'll show you in
a second where that is but it's going to
be under face net
uh and then we go ahead and initialize
our list of faces their corresponding
locations and the list of predictions
from our face mask network
we're going to loop over the detections
and this is a little bit more work than
you think
as far as looking for different faces
whatever the view of a crowd of faces
um so we're looping through the
detections and the shapes going through
here
and probability associated with the
detection uh here's our confidence of
detections
we're going to filter out weak detection
by ensuring the confidence is greater
than the minimum confidence
so we've said it remember zero to one so
0.5 would be our minimum confidence
probably is pretty good
[Music]
and then we're going to put in compute
bounding boxes for the object if i'm
zipping through this it's because we're
going to do an open cv and i really want
to stick to just the cross part
and so i'm just kind of jumping through
all this code you can get a copy of this
code from simply learn and take it apart
or look for the opencv coming out
and we'll create a box the box sets it
around the image
ensure the bounding boxes fall within
the dimensions of the frame
uh so we create a box around what's
going to be hope is going to be the face
extract the face roi convert it from bgr
to rgb channel
again this is an open cv issue not
really an issue but it has to do with
the order i don't know how many times
i've forgotten to check the order colors
when working with opencv
because there's all kinds of fun things
when red becomes blue
and blue becomes red
and we're going to resize it process it
frame it uh face frame
setup again the face the cbt color we're
gonna convert it
uh we're gonna resize it
image to array pre-process the input pin
the face locate face start x dart y and
x
boy that was just a huge amount and i
skipped over a ton of it but the bottom
line is we're building a box around the
face
and that box because the opencv does a
decent job of finding the face and that
box is going to go in there and see hey
does this person have a mask on it
uh
and so that's what that's what all this
is doing on here and then finally we get
down to this where it says predictions
equals mass net dot predict faces batch
size 32.
so these different images of where we're
guessing where the face is are then
going to go through and
generate an array of faces if you will
and we're going to look through and say
does this face have a mask on it and
that's what's going right here is our
prediction that's the big thing that
we're working for
and then we return the locations and the
predictions the location just tells
where on the picture it is and then the
prediction tells us what it is is it a
mask or is it not a mask
all right so we've loaded that all up
so we're going to load our serialized
face detector model from disk
and we have our the path that it was
saved in obviously you're going to put
it in a different path depending on
where you have it or however you want to
do it and how you saved it on the last
one where we trained it
and then we have our weights path
and so finally our face net here it is
equals cb2.dnn.readnet
prototext path weights path and we're
going to load that up on here so let me
go ahead and run that
and then we also need to i'll just put
it right down here i always hate
separating these things in there
and then we're going to load the actual
mass detector model from disk this is
the the model that we saved so let's go
ahead and run that on there also so this
is pulling on all the different pieces
we need for our model
and then the next part is we're going to
create open up our video
and this is just kind of fun because
it's all part of the opencv
video set up
and we just put this all in as one
there we go
uh so we're going to go ahead and open
up our video we're going to start it and
we're going to run it until we're done
and this is where we get some real like
kind of live action stuff which is fun
this is what i like working about with
images and videos
is that when you start working with
images and videos it's all like right
there in front of you it's visual and
you can see what's going on
uh so we're gonna start our video
streaming this is grabbing our video
stream source zero start
uh that means it's grabbing my main
camera i have hooked up um
and then you know starting video you're
gonna print it out
here's our video source equals zero
start
loop over the frames from the video
stream
oops a little redundancy there um let me
close
i'll just leave it that's how they
headed in the code so
so while true we're going to grab the
frame from the threaded video stream and
resize it to have the maximum width of
400 pixels so here's our frame we're
going to read it
from our visual
stream
we're going to resize it
and then we have we're returning
remember we returned from the our
procedure the location and the
prediction so detect and predict mask
we're sending it the frame
we're sending it the face net and the
mass net so we're sending all the
different pieces that say this is what's
going through on here
and then it returns our location and
predictions and then for our box
and predictions in the location and
predictions
and the boxes is again this is an open
cv set that says hey this is a box
coming in from the location
because you have the two different
points on there
and then we're going to unpack the box
and predictions and we're going to go
ahead and do mask without a mask equals
prediction
we're going to create our label
no mask and create color if the label
equals mask
l0225 and you know it's going to make a
lot more sense when i hit the run button
here
but we have the probability of the label
we're going to display the label and
bounding box rectangle on the output
frame
and then we're going to go ahead and
show the output from the frame cv to im
show frame frame and then the key equals
cp2 weight key one we're just going to
wait till the next one comes through
from our feed
and we're going to do this until we hit
the stop button pretty much
so you're ready for this to see if it
works we've distributed our our model
we've loaded it up into our distributed
uh code here we've got it hooked into
our camera and we're going to go ahead
and run it
and there it goes it's going to be
running and we can see the data coming
down here and we're waiting for the
pop-up
and there i am in my office with my
funky headset on
uh
and you can see in the background my
unfinished wall and it says up here no
mask oh no i don't have a mask on
i wonder if i cover my mouth
what would happen
you can see my no mask
goes down a little bit i wish i brought
a mask into my office it's up at the
house but you can see here that this
says you know there's a 95 98 percent
chance that i don't have a mask on and
it's true i don't have a mask on right
now and this could be distributed this
is actually an excellent little piece of
script that you can start you know you
install somewhere on a video feed on a
on a security camera or something and
then you'd have this really neat setup
saying hey do you have a mask on when
you enter a store or a public
transportation or whatever it is where
they're required to wear a mask
let me go ahead and stop that
now if you want a copy of this
code definitely give us a hauler we will
be going into opencv in another one so i
skipped a lot of the opencv
code in here as far as going into detail
really focusing on the cross
saving the model uploading the model and
then processing a streaming video
through it so you can see it that the
model works we actually have this
working model that hooks into the video
camera
which is just pretty cool and a lot of
fun
so i told you we're going to dive in and
really roll up our sleeve and do a lot
of coding today we did the basic uh
demo up above for just pulling in a
cross and then we went into a cross
model
where we pulled in data to see whether
someone was wearing a mask or not so
very useful in today's world as far as a
fully running application
what is in it for you today we're going
to cover what is cross
computational graphs
what are neural networks sequential
models and then we'll do a hands-on demo
so you can see what's going on with
sequential models in keras
so what is caras
cross is a high-level python deep
learning api
which is used for easy implementation of
neural networks it has multiple
low-level back-ends like tensorflow
fano
pi torch etc which are used for fast
computation
so you can think of this as cross being
almost its own little programming
language
and then it sits on neural networks in
this case the ones listed were
tensorflow thano and pi torch which can
all integrate with the cross model
this makes it very diverse and also
makes it very easy to use and switch
around with different things
cross is very user friendly as far as
neural network software goes as a high
level api
computational graphs
so computational graphs are really the
heart and soul of neural networks
we talk about a computational graph
they are a visual representation of
expressing and evaluating mathematical
equations
the nodes and data flow in a graph
correspond to mathematical operations
and variables
you'll hear a lot
some of the terms you might hear are
node and edge the edge being the data
flow in this case
it could also represent an actual value
they have
oh i think in spark they have a graph x
which works just on computing edges
there's all kinds of stuff that has
evolved from computational graphs we're
focusing just on keras and on neural
networks so we're not going to go into
great detail on everything a
computational graph does it is a core
component of a neural network is what's
important to know on this
so cross offers a python user-friendly
front-end while maintaining a strong
computation power by using a low level
api
like tensorflow pi torch etc which use
computational graphs as a back end
so one this allows for abstraction of
complex problems while specifying
control flow
if you've ever looked at some of the
back end or the original versions of
tensorflow
it's really a nightmare you have all
these different settings you have to put
in there and create
it's a lot a lot of back-end programming
this is like the old computers when you
had to
tell it how to dispose of a variable and
how to properly re-allocate the memory
for use
all that is covered nowadays in our
higher level programming well this is
the same thing with keras is it covers a
lot of this stuff and does things for
you that you could spend hours on just
trying to figure out
it's useful for calculating derivatives
by using back propagation
we're definitely not going to teach a
class on derivatives uh in this little
video but understanding uh a derivative
is the rate of change so if you have a
particular function you're using in your
neural network
a lot of them is just simple uh
y equals mx plus b your euclidean
geometry where you just have a simple
slope times the intercept and they get
very complicated they have the inverse
tangent function for activation as
opposed to just a linear euclidean model
and you can think about this as you have
your data coming in and you have to
alter it somehow
well you alter it going down to get an
answer you end up with an error and that
error goes back up and you have to have
that back propagation with the
derivative you want to know how it
changed so that you can figure out how
to adjust it for the error
a lot of that's hidden so you don't even
have to worry about it with cross and in
today's cross it'll even if you create
your own
formula for computing an answer it will
automatically compute the back prop the
the derivative for you in a lot of cases
it's easier to implement distributed
computation
so cross is really nice way to package
it and get it off on different computers
and share it and it allows parallelism
which means that two operations can run
simultaneously
so as we start developing these back
ends it can do all kinds of cool things
and utilize multiple cores gpus on a
computer
to get that parallel processing up
what are neural networks
well like i said there are already we've
talked about in computational edges you
have a node and you have a connection or
your edge so neural networks are
algorithms fashioned after the human
brain which contain multiple layers each
layer contains a node called a neuron
which performs a mathematical operation
they break down complex problems into
simple operations
so one an input layer takes in our data
and pre-processes it
when we talk about pre-processing when
you're dealing with neural networks you
usually have to pre-process your data so
that it's between
-1 and 1 or 0-1
into some kind of value that's usable
that occurs before it gets to the neural
network
in fact 80 percent of data science is
usually in prepping that data and
getting it ready for your different
models
two you have hidden layer performs a
non-linear transformation of input
now it can do a hidden a linear
transformation it can use just a basic
euclidean geometry and you could think
of a node adding all the different
connections coming in
so each connection would have a weight
and then it would add to that weight
plus an intercept in the note itself so
you can actually use euclidean geometry
but a lot of these get really
complicated they have all these
different formulas and they're really
cool to look at but when you start
looking at them look at how they work
you really don't need to know the high
math behind it
to figure them out and figure out what
they're doing
which is really cool that means a lot of
people can use this without having to go
get a phd in mathematics
number three the output layer takes the
results from hidden layer transform them
and gives a final output
so sequential models
so what makes this a sequential model
sequential models are linear stacks of
layers where one layer leads to the next
it is simple and easy to implement and
you just have to make sure that the
previous layer is the input to the next
layer
so you have used for plain stack of
layers where each layer has one input
and one output tensor and this is what
tensorflow is named after is um each one
of these layers is like a tensor
each node is a tensor and the layer is
also considered a tensor of values
and it's used for simple classifier
declassifier models you can it's also
used for regression models too so it's
not just about uh this is something this
is a teapot this is a cat this is a dog
it's also used for generating um
regret the actual values you know this
is worth ten dollars that's worth thirty
dollars uh the weather is going to be 90
degrees out or whatever it is so you can
use it for both classifier and
declassifier models
and one more note when we talk about
sequential models the term sequential is
used a lot and it's used in different
areas in different notations when you're
in data science
so when we talk about time series we'll
talk about sequential that is something
very different sequential in this case
means it goes from the input to layer 1
to layer 2 to the output so it's very
directional
it's important to note this because if
you have a sequential model can you have
a non-sequential model and the answer is
yes
if you master the basics of a sequential
model you can just as easily have
another model that shares layers
you can have another model where you
have an input coming in and it splits
and then you have one set that's doing
one set of nodes maybe they're doing a
yes no kind of node where it's either
putting out a zero or a one a classifier
and the other one might be regression
it's just processing numbers and then
you recombine them for the output
that's what they call across the cross
api
so there's a lot of different
availabilities in here and all kinds of
cool things you can do as far as
encoding and decoding and all kinds of
things and you can share layers and
things like that
we're just focusing on the basic cross
model with the sequential model
so let's dive into the meat of the
matter let's do and do a demo on here
uh today's demo in this demo we'll be
performing flower classification using
sequential model and cross and we'll use
our model to classify between five
different types of flowers
now for this demo and you can do this
demo whatever platform you want or
whatever
user interface for developing python
i'm actually using anaconda and then i'm
using jupiter notebooks to develop in
and if you're not familiar with this you
can go under environment once you've
created environment you can come in here
to open a terminal window and if you
don't have the different modules in here
you can do your conda install whatever
module it is
just happened that this particular setup
didn't have a seaborn in it which i
already installed
so here's our anaconda and then i'm
going to go back
and start up my jupiter notebook
where i already created a
new
python project python3 i'm in python 3.8
on this particular one
sequential model for flowers
so lots of fun there
so we're going to jump right into this
the first thing is to make sure you have
all your modules installed
so if you don't have numpy pandas
matplot library and seaborn in the cross
an sklearn or site kit it's not actually
sklearn you'll need to go ahead and
install all of those
now having done this for years and
having switched environments and doing
different things
i get all my imports done and then we
just run it and if we get an error we
know we have to go back and install
something
um
right off the bat though we have numpy
pandas matplot library seaborn these are
built on top of each other panda is a
data frame and built on top of numpy the
data array
and then we bring in our sk learn or
scikit this is the scikit setup sci
kit
even though you use sk learn to bring it
in it's a scikit and then our cross we
have our pre-processing the images image
data generator
our model this is our basic model or
sequential model
and then we bring in from cross layers
import dents
optimizers
these optimizers a lot of them already
come in these are your different
optimizers and it's almost a lot of this
is so automatic now um atom
is the a lot of times the default
because you're dealing with a large data
and then we get our sgd which is uh
smaller data does better on smaller
pieces of data
and i'm not going to go into all of
these uh different optimizers we didn't
even use these in the actual demo you
just have to be aware that they are
different optimizers and the digger the
more you dig into these models
you'll hit a point where you do need to
play with these a little bit but for the
most part leave it at the default when
you're first starting out
and we're doing just the sequential
you'll see here layers dense
and then if we come down a little bit
more when they put this together and
they're running the dense layers you'll
also see they have drop out they have
flattened they have activation
they have the convolutional
layer 2d max pooling 2d
batch normalization
what are all these layers uh and when we
get to the model we're gonna
talk about them a lot of times when
you're just starting you can just
import cross dot layers and then you
have your drop out your flattened
your convolutional
neural network 2d
and we'll we'll cover what these do
in the actual example when we get down
there
what i want you to take from here though
is you need to run your imports
and load your different aspects of this
and of course your tensorflow tf because
this is all built on tensorflow
and then finally import random is rn
just for random generation
and then we get down here we have our
cv2
that is your
open image or your opencv they call it
for processing images that's what the
cvd2 is
we have our tqdm
the tqdm is for um it's a progress bar
just a fancy way
of adding when you're running a process
you can view the bar going across in the
jupiter
setup not really necessary but it's kind
of fun to have
we want to shuffle some files uh again
these are all different things pill is
another
image processor it goes with the cv2 a
lot of times you'll see both of those
and so we run those we've got to bring
them all in
and the next thing is to set up our
directories
and so we come into the directories
there's an important thing to note on
here other than we're looking at a lot
of flowers which is fun
uh
as we get down here we have our
directory archive flowers that just
happens to be where the different
files for different flowers are put in
we're denoting an x and a z
and the x is the date of the image and
the z is the tag for it what kind of
flower is this
uh and the image size is really
important because we have to resize
everything if you have a neural network
and if you remember from our neural
networks let me flip back to that slide
we look at this light we have two input
nodes here
with an image you have an input node
depending on how you set it up for each
pixel and that pixel has three different
color schemes usually in it sometimes
four so if you have a picture that's 150
by 150
uh you multiply 150 times 150 times 3
that's how many nodes input layers
coming in i mean so this is a massive
input a lot of times you think oh yeah
it's just a small amount of data or
something like that
no it's a full image coming in and then
you have your hidden layers a lot of
times they match what the image size is
coming in so each one of those is also
just as big and then we get down to just
a single output
so that's kind of a thing to note in
here what's going on behind the scenes
and of course each one of these layers
has a lot of processes and stuff going
on
and then we have our different uh
directories on here let me go and run
that so i'm just setting the directories
that's all this is
archive flowers daisy sunflower tulip
dandelion rose
just our different directories that
we're going to be looking at
and then we want to go ahead and we need
to assign labels remember we defined x
in z
so we're just going to create a
definition here
and the first thing is return flower
type okay
it just returns it what kind of flower
it is i guess a sign label to it
but we're going to go ahead and make our
train data
and when you look at this there's a
couple things to take away from here
the first one is we're just appending
right onto our numpy array the image
we're going to let numpy handle all that
different
aspects as far as 150 by 150 by three
we just dump it right into the numpy
which makes it really easy we don't have
to do anything funky on the processing
and we want to leave it like that and
i'm going to talk about that in a minute
and then of course we have to have the
string a pin the label on there and i
want you to notice right here
we're going to read the image in
and then we're going to size it and this
is important because we're just changing
this to 150 by 150 we're resizing the
image so it's uniform every image comes
in identical to the other ones
this is something that's so important is
when you're resizing or reformatting
your data you really have to be aware of
what's going on
with
images it's not a big deal because with
an image you just resize it so it looks
squishy or spread out or stretched
the neural network picks up on that and
it doesn't really change how it
processes it
so let's go ahead and run that
and now we've got our definition set up
on
there and then we want to go ahead and
make our
training data
so make the train data
daisy flower daisy directory
print length of x so here we go let's go
and run that
and we're just loading up the flower
daisy so this is going all in there and
it's setting
it's adding it in to the our setup on
there that to our x and z setup
and we see we have 769
and then of course you can see this nice
bar here this is the bar going across is
that little added
code in there that just makes it really
cool for doing demos
not necessarily when you're building
your own model or something like that
but if you're going to display this to
other people adding that little what was
it called
tqdm i can never remember that but the
tqdm module in there is really nice and
we'll go ahead and do sunflowers and of
course you could have just
created an array of these
but this has an interesting problem
that's going to come up and i want to
show you something
it doesn't matter how good the people in
the back are how good you are
programming
errors are going to come up and you got
to figure out how to handle them
and so when we get all the way down to
the
[Music]
where is it dandelion here's our
dandelion directory we're going to build
jupiter has some cool things it does
which makes this really easy to deal
with
but at the same time you want to go back
in there depending on how many times you
rerun this how many times you pull this
so when you're finding errors
going in here there's a couple things
you can do and we're just gonna um hope
it wasn't there it is there's our error
i knew there was an error
this processed
1062 out of 1065.
now i can do a couple things one i could
go back into our definition
and i can just put in here try and so if
it has a bad conversion this is where
the error is coming from
uh just skip it that's one way to do it
um when you're doing a lot of work in
data science and you look at something
like this where you're losing three
points of data at the end
you just say okay i lost three points
who cares
or you can go in there and try to delete
it
it really doesn't matter for this
particular demo
and so we're just going to leave that
error right along and skip over because
it's already added all the other files
in there and this is a wonderful thing
about jupyter notebook
is that i can just continue on there and
the x and z which we're creating
is still
running and we'll just go right into the
next flower rose so all these flowers
are in there
that's just a cool thing about jupiter
notebook
uh and then we can go ahead and just
take a quick look and see
what we're dealing with and this is of
course really when you're dealing with a
other people and showing them stuff this
is just kind of fun where we can display
it on the plot library here
and we're just going to go through and
let's see what we got here
looks like
we're going to do like five of each of
them i think
is that how they set this up um
plot library five by two okay oh i see
how they did it okay so two each so we
have five by two set up on our axes and
we're just going to go in and look at a
couple of these flowers
it's always a good thing to look at some
of your data
no matter what you're doing
we've reformatted this to 150 by 150
you can see how it really blurs this one
up here on the tulip
that is that resize to 150 by 150
and these are what's actually going in
these are all 150 by 150 images you can
check the dimensions on the side
and you can see just a quick sampling of
the flowers we're actually going to
process on here
and again like i said at the beginning
most of your work in data science is
reprocessing
this different information so we need to
go ahead and take our labels
uh and run a label encoder on there and
then we're just lea is a label encoder
one of the things we imported
and then we always use the fit
to categorical y comma five x here's our
array
x so if you look at this here's our fit
we're going to transform z
that's our z array we created
and then we have y which equals that and
then we go ahead and do uh to
categorical we want five different
categories
and then we create our x uh np array of
x x equals x over 255.
so what's going on here there's two
different transformations one we've
turned our categories into
zero one two three four five as the
output
and we have taken our x array
and remember the x array is three values
of your different colors
this is so important to understand when
we do this across a numpy array this
takes every one of those three colors so
we have 150 by 150 pixels
out of those 150 by 150 pixels they each
have three
color arrays and those color arrays
range from 0 to 250.
so when we take the x equals x over 255
i'm sorry range from zero to 255.
this converts all those pixels to a
number between zero and one
and you really want to do that when
you're working with neural networks now
if you do a linear regression model it
doesn't affect it as much and so you
don't have to do that conversion if
you're doing straight numbers but when
you're running neural networks if you
don't do this you're going to create a
huge bias
and that means it'll do really good on
predicting one or two things and they'll
just totally die on a lot of other
predictions
so now we have our
x and y values
x being the data in y being our known
output
and with any good setup we want to
divide this data into our training
so we have x train
we have our x test this is the data
we're not going to program the model
with
and of course your y train corresponds
to your x train and your y test
corresponds to your x test the outputs
and this is uh when we do the train test
split this was from the site kit sklearn
we imported train test split and we're
just going to go ahead and do the test
size at about a quarter of the data 0.25
and of course random is always good
this is such a good tool i mean
certainly you can do your own division
um
you know you could just take the first
you know 0.25 of the data or whatever do
the length of the data not real hard to
do
but this is randomized so if you're
running this test a few times you can
kind of get an idea whether it's going
to work or not
sometimes what i will do
is i'll just split the data into three
parts
and then i'll test it on two with one
being the uh or train it on two of those
parts with one being the test and i
rotate it so i come up with three
different answers which is a good way of
finding out just how good your model is
but for setting up let's stick with the
x train x test and the sk learn package
and then we're going to go ahead and do
a random seed
now a lot of times the cross actually
does this automatically but we're going
to go ahead and set it up on here and
you can see we did an np random seed
from 42 and we get a nice rn number
and then we do tf random we set the seed
so you can set your randomness at the
beginning of your tensorflow and that's
what the
tf.random.set is
so that's a lot of prep
all this prep and then we finally get to
the exciting part
this is where you probably spend once
you have the data prepped and you have
your pipeline going
and you have everything set up on there
this is the part that's exciting is
building these models
and so we look at this model one we're
going to designate are sequential
they have the api which is across the
cross tensorflow api versus sequential
sequential means we're going one layer
to the next so we're not going to split
the layer and bring it back together
it looks almost the same with the
exception of
bringing it back together so it's not a
huge step to go from this to an api
and the first thing we're going to look
at is
our convolutional neural network in 2d
so what's going on here there's a lot of
stuff that's going on here
the default
for well let's start with the beginning
what is a convolutional 2d network
well convolutional 2d network creates a
number of small windows and those small
windows float over the picture
and each one of them is their own neural
network and this basically
becomes like a
a categorization and then it looks at
that and it says oh if we add these
numbers up a certain way
we can find out whether this is the
right flower based on this this little
window floating around which looks at
different things
and we have filters 32 so this is
actually creating 32 windows is what
that's doing
and the kernel size is five by five so
we're looking at a five by five square
remember it's 150 by 150 so this narrows
it down to a five by five it's a two d
so it has your x y coordinates
and
we look at this five by five remember
each one of these is is actually looking
at five by five by three
so we're actually looking at fifteen by
fifteen different
pixels and padding is just
usually just ignore that
activation by default is relu we went
ahead and put the relu in there
there's a lot of different activations
relu is for your smaller
when you remember i mentioned atom when
you have a lot of datum data use an atom
kind of activation or using atom
processing
we're using the relu here
it kind of gives you a yes or no but it
it doesn't give you a full yes or no it
has a
a zero and then it kind of shoots off at
an angle
very common it's the most common one and
then of course here's our input shape
150 by 150 by three pixels
and then we have to pool it so whenever
you have a two convolutional 2d um
layer
we have to bring this back together and
pull this into a neural network and then
we're going to go ahead and repeat this
so we're going to add another network
here
one of the cool things if you look at
this is that it as it comes in it just
kind of automatically assumes you're
going down to the next layer
and so we have another convolutional
null network 2d
here's our max pooling again we're going
to do that again max pooling
and we're just going to filter on down
now one of the things they did on this
one is they changed the kernel size they
changed the number of filters
and so each one of these steps
kind of looks at the data a little bit
differently
and that's kind of cool because then you
get a little added filtering on there
this is where you start playing with the
model you might be looking at a
convolutional neural network which is
great for image classifications
when we get down to here one of the
things we see is flattened so we add we
just flatten it remember this is 150 by
150 by 3.
well and actually
the pool size changes so it's actually
smaller than that flattened just puts
that into a 1d array
so instead of being
you know a tensor of this really
complexity with the pixels and
everything is just flat
and then the dents
is just another activation on there
by default it is probably relu
as far as its activation
and then oh yeah here we go in
sequential they actually added the
activation as relu so this just because
this is sequential this activation is
attached to the dents
and there's a lot of different
activations but relu is the most common
one and then we also see a soft max
softmax is similar
but it has its own kind of variation
and one of the cool things you know what
let me bring this up because if we if
you don't know about these activations
this doesn't make sense
and i just did a quick google search on
images of tensorflow activations um i
should probably look at which set
website this is
but this is the output of the values uh
so as your x as it adds in all those
weighted x values going into the node
it's going to activate it a certain way
that's a sigmoid activation and you can
see it goes between 0 and 1 and has a
nice curve there this also shows the
derivatives
if we come down the seven popular
activation functions non-linear
activations there's a lot of different
options on this let me see if i can find
the
[Music]
let's make sure we can find the specific
to relu
so this is a leaky relu
and you can see instead of it just being
zero and then a value between uh going
up it has a little leaky there otherwise
your railu loses some nodes they just
become inactive
but you can see there's a lot of
different options here here's a good one
right here with the rayleigh you can see
the rayleigh function on the upper on
the upper left here and then the leaky
railway over here on the right which is
very commonly used also
one of the things i use with processing
language is the
sig is the exponential one
or the tangent h the hyperbolic tangent
because they have that nice funky curve
that comes in that has a whole different
meaning and captures word use better
again these are very specific to domain
and you can spend a lot of time
playing with different models
for our basic model we'll stick to the
relu and the softmax on here and we'll
go ahead and run and build this model
so now that we've had fun playing with
all these different models that we can
add in there
we need to go ahead and have a batch
size on here
128
epix10
this means that we're going to send 128
uh
rows of data or flowers at a time to be
processed
and the epics 10 that's how many times
we're going to loop through all the data
reduce um the values and
verbose verbose equals one means that
we're going to show what's going on
um
value the monitor what we're monitoring
we'll see that as we actually train the
model this is what's what's going to
come out of there if you set the verbose
equal to 0
you don't have to watch it train the
model
although
it is kind of nice to actually know
what's going on sometimes
and since we're still working on
bringing the data in here's our batch
side here's our epics we need to go
ahead and create a data generator uh
this is our image data generator
and it has all the different settings in
here almost all of these are defaults so
if you're looking at this going oh my
gosh this is confusing
most of the time you can actually just
ignore most of this
vertical flip so you can randomly flip
pictures you can really horizontally
flick them
you can shift the picture around this
kind of helps gives you multiple data
off of them
zooming rotation there's all kinds of
different things you can do with images
most of these we're just going to leave
as false we don't really need to do all
that
setup because we already have a huge
amount of data if you're short data you
can start flipping like a horizontal
picture and it will generate it's like
doubling your data almost
so the upside is you double your data
the downside is that if you already have
a bias in your data you already have
[Music]
5 000 sunflowers and only two roses
that's a huge bias it's also going to
double that bias that is the downside of
that
and so we have our model comp model
compile and this you're going to see in
all the cross we're going to take this
model here
we're going to take all this information
as far as how we want it to go and we're
going to compile it
this actually builds the model and so
we're going to run that and i want you
to notice uh
learning rate
very important this is the default zero
zero one
there's there you really don't this is
how
slowly it adjusts to find the right
answer
and the more data you have you might
actually make this a smaller number um
with larger with you have a very small
sample of data you might go even larger
than that
and then we're going to look at the loss
categorically categorical cross entropy
most commonly used
and this is uh how how much it improves
the model is improving is what this
number means or yeah that's that's
important on there and then the accuracy
we want to know just how good our model
is on the accuracy
and then
one of the cool things to do is if
you're in a group of people who are
studying the model if you're in
shareholders you don't want to do this
is you can run the model summary
i do this by default and you can see the
different layers that you built into
this model just a quick summary on there
so we went ahead and we're going to go
ahead and create a um
we'll call it history but we want to do
a model fit generator
and so what this history is doing is
this is tracking what's going on as
while it fits
the model
now there's a lot of new setups in here
where they just use fit and then you put
the generator in here
we're going to leave it like this even
though the new default
is a little different on that
it doesn't really matter it does the
same thing and we'll go ahead and just
run that
and you can see while it's running right
here uh we're going through the epics we
have one of ten now we're going through
six to 25
here's our loss we're printing that out
so you can see how it's improving and
our accuracy the accuracy gets better
and better and this is 6 out of 25. this
is going to take a couple minutes to
process
because we are training 150 by 150 by 3
pixels across
6 layers or eight layers whatever it was
that is a huge amount of processing so
this will take a few minutes to process
this is when we talk about the hardware
and the problems that come up in data
science and why it's only now just
exploding being able to do neural
networks this is why this process takes
a long time
now you should have seen a jump on the
screen here because i did
pause the recorder to let this go ahead
and run all the way through its epics
let's go ahead and take a look and see
what these epics are
and if you set the verbose to
zero instead of one it won't show what's
going on in the behind the scenes as
it's training it
so we look at this epic 10 epic so we
went through all the data 10 times
if i remember correctly there's roughly
a gig of data there so that's a lot of
data
the first thing you're going to notice
is the
270 seconds
that's how much each of those epics took
to run
and so if you divide 60 in there you
roughly get about five minutes worth of
each epic so if i have 10 epics that's
50 minutes almost an hour of run time
that's a big deal we talk about
processing uh in on this particular
computer
i actually have what is it
eight cores with 16 dedicated threads so
it runs like a 16 core computer it
alternates the threads going in
and it still takes it five minutes for
each one of these epics so you start to
see that if you have a lot of data
this is going to be a problem if you
have a number of models you want to find
out how good the models are doing what
model to use
and so each of those models could take
all night to run in fact i have a model
i'm running now that takes over
takes about a day and a half to test
each model
it takes four days to do with the whole
data
so what i do is i actually take a small
piece of the data
test it out to find out get an idea of
how the different setups are going to do
and then i increase that size of the
data and then increase it again and i
can just take that that curve and kind
of say okay if the data is doing this
then i need to add in more dense layers
or whatever
so you can do a small chunks of data
then figure out what it costs to do a
large set of data and what kind of model
you want
the loss as we see here continues to go
down
this is the error this is how much error
is in there it really isn't a
user-friendly number other than
the more it trends down the better and
so if you continue to see the loss going
down eventually get to the point where
it stops going down and it goes up and
down and kind of wavers a little bit at
that point you know you've run too many
epics you're starting to get a bias in
there and it's not going to give you a
good model fit
the accuracy just turns this into
something that
we can use
and so the accuracy is what percentage
of guesses in this case is categorical
so this is the percentage of guesses are
correct
value loss is similar you know it's a
minus a value loss
and then you have the value accuracy and
you'll see the value accuracy is pretty
similar to the accuracy um just rounds
it off basically and so a lot of times
you come down here and you go okay we're
doing 0.5.6
0.7 and that is 70 accuracy or in this
case 68.59
accuracy that's a very usable number and
it's very important to have
if you're identifying flowers that's
probably good enough if you can get
within a close distance in knowing what
flower you're identifying
if you're trying to figure out whether
someone's going to die from a heart
attack or not you might want to rethink
it a little bit or re-key how you're
building your model
so
if i'm working with a uh
a group of clients um shareholders in a
company or something like that
you don't really want to show them this
you don't want to show them hey you know
this is what's going on with the
accuracy these are just numbers and so
we want to go and put the finishing
touches just like when you are building
a house and you put in the frame and the
trim on the house it's nice to have
something a nice view of what's going on
and so we'll go ahead and do a pie plot
and we'll just plot the history of the
loss
the history of the
value loss
over here
epics train and test and so we're just
going to compute these
this is really important and what i want
you to notice right here
is when we get to about oh
five epics a little more than five six
epics you see a cross over here and it
starts crossing as far as the
value loss and what's going on here is
you have the loss in your actual model
and your actual data and you have the
value loss where it's testing it against
the the test data the the data wasn't
used to program your model wasn't used
to train your model on
and so when we see this crossing over
this is where the bias is coming in this
is becoming over fitted and so when you
put these two together
right around five and six you start to
see how it
does this this switch over here and
that's really where you need to stop
right around five yeah six
um
it's always hard to guess because at
this point the model is kind of a black
box
uh see but you know that right around
here if you're saving your model after
each run you want to use the one that's
right around five epics because that's
the one that's going to have the least
amount of bias so this is really
important as far as guessing what's
going on with your model and its
accuracy and when to stop
it also is you know i don't show people
this mess up here um i show somebody
this kind of model and i say this is
where the training and the testing comes
in on this model
it just makes it easier to see and
people can understand what's going on
so that completes our demo and you can
see we did what we were set out to do we
took our flowers and we were able to
classify them uh within about you know
68 70
accuracy whether it's going to be a
dahlia sunflower cherry blossom rose
a lot of other things you can do with
your output as far as a
different tables to see where the errors
are coming from what problems are coming
up
and we're going to take a look at image
classification using cross and the basic
setup and we'll actually look at two
different demos on here
what's in it for you today
what is image classification
intel image classification data
creating neural networks with keras and
the vgg-16 model
what is image classification
the process of image classification
refers to assigning classes to an entire
image images can be classified based on
different categories like weather
it is a nighttime or daytime shot what
the image represents etc you can see
here we have mountains looking for
mountains well actually doing some uh
pictures of scenery and stuff like that
in deep learning we perform image
classification by using neural networks
to extract features from images and
classifies them based on these features
and you can see here where it says like
what computer sees and it says oh yeah
we see mostly forest maybe a little bit
of mountains because the way the image
is
and this is really where one of the
areas that neural networks
really shines
if you try to run this stuff through
more like a linear regression model
you'll still get results but the results
kind of miss a lot of things as the
neural networks get better and better at
what they do with different tools we
have out there
so intel image classification data
the data being used is the intel image
classification data set which consists
of images of six types of land areas and
so we have forest building glaciers and
mountains sea and street
and you can see here there's a couple of
the images out of there as a set up in
the in the
intel image classification data that
they use
and then we're going to go into creating
a neural networks with keras
the convolutional neural network that we
are creating from scratch looks
as shown below
you'll see here we have our input layer
um
they haven't listed max pooling uh so
you have
as you're coming in with the input layer
and the input layer is actually
before this but the first layer that
it's going to go into is going to be a
convolutional neural network
then you have a max pooling that pulls
those the the convolutional neural
networks returns
in this case they have two of those
that is very standard with convolutional
neural networks uh one of the ones that
i was looking at earlier that was
standard being used by
one one of the larger companies that
came in for which one for doing a large
amount of identification had two
convolutional neural networks each with
their max pooling and then about 17
dense layers after it we're not going to
do that heavy duty of a of a code but
we'll get you ahead in the right
direction and that gives you an idea of
what you're actually going to be looking
at when you look at the flattened part
and then the dents we're talking like 17
dense layers afterwards
i find that a lot of the stuff i've been
working on i end up maxing it out right
around nine dense layers it really
depends on what you have going in and
what you're working with
and the vgg16 model
vgg16 is a pre-trained cnn model which
is used for image classification it is
trained on a large varied data set and
fine-tuned to fit image classification
data sets with ease
and you can see down here we have the
input coming in
the convolutional neural network one to
one one to two and then pooling and then
we do two to one two to two
convolutional network then pooling three
to two and you can see there's just this
huge layering of convolutional neural
networks and in this case they have five
such layers going in and then in three
dents going out or
more
now when they
took this setup this actually won an
award back in 2019 for this particular
setup
and it does it does really good except
that again
we only show the three dense layers here
and as you find out
depending on your data going in and what
you have set up
that really isn't enough on one of these
setups and i'm going to show you why we
restricted it because it does take up a
lot of processing power in some of these
things
so let's go ahead and roll up our
sleeves and we're going to look at both
the setups we're going to start with the
the first classification
and then we'll go into the vgg16 and
show you how that's set up
now i'm going to be using anaconda and
let me flip over to my anaconda so you
can see what that looks like
now i'm running in the anaconda here
you'll see that i've set up a main
python 3 8. i always put that in there
because this is where i'm doing like
most of my kind of playing around
this is done in python version 3.8 we're
not going to dig too much into versions
at this point you should already have
cross installed on there usually cross
takes a number of extra steps
and then our usual
setup is the numpy the pandas
your sk your site kit which is going to
be the sk learn your seaborn and i'll
show you those in just a minute
and then i'm just going to be in the
jupiter lab where i've created a new
notebook in here
and let's flip on over there to my blank
notebook
now there's a couple of cool things to
note in here is that
one i use the the
anaconda jupiter notebook setup because
it keeps everything separate
except for cross
cross is actually running separately in
the back
i believe it's a c program
what's nice about that is that it
utilizes the multiprocessors on the
computer and i'll mention that just in a
little bit when we actually get down to
running the code
and when we look in here a couple things
to note is here's our
oops
i thought i'd grab the other drawing
thing uh but here's our numpy and our
pandas right here and our operating
system this is our psi kit you always
import it as sklearn for the
classification report
uh we're gonna be using well usually
import like seaborn brings in all of
your pie plot library also
kind of nice to throw that in there i
can't remember if we're actually using
seaborne if they just the people in the
back just threw that together
and then we have the sklearn shuffle for
shuffling data here's our matplot
library that the seaborne is pretty much
built on
cv2
if you're not familiar with that that is
our image
module for importing the image
and then of course we have our
tensorflow down here which is what we're
really working with
and then the last thing is just for
visual effect while we're running this
if you're doing a demo and you're
working with the partners or the
shareholders
this tqdm is really kind of cool it's an
extensible progress bar for python and
i'll show you that too
remember data science is not i mean
almost this code when i'm looking
through this code i'm not going to show
half of this stuff to the shareholders
or anybody i'm working with they don't
really care about pandas and all that we
do because we want to understand how it
works
so we need to go ahead and import those
different
setup on there and then the next thing
is we're going to go ahead and set up
our classes
now we remember if we had mountain
street glacier building c and forest
those were the different images that we
have coming in
and we're going to go ahead and just do
class name labels and we're going to
kind of match that class name of i for i
class name
equals the class names so our labels are
going to match the names up here
uh and then we have the number of uh
classes
and the print the class names and the
labels and we'll go ahead and set the
image size this is important that we
resize everything because if you
remember with neural networks
they take one size data coming in and so
when you're working with images you
really want to make sure they're all
resized to the same
setup it might squish them it might
stretch them that generally does not
cause a problem in these uh and some of
the other tricks you can do with if you
if you need more data
and this is one that's used regularly
we're not going to do it in here is you
can also take these images and not only
resize them but you can tilt them one
way or the other crop parts of them
so they process slightly differently and
it'll actually increase your accuracy of
some of these predictions
and so you can see here we have mountain
equals zero that's what this class name
label is
street equals one glacier equals two
buildings equals three c4 4s equals five
now we did this as an enumerator so each
one is zero through five
a lot of times we do this instead as
uh
0 1 0 1 0 1 so you have five outputs and
each one's a zero or a one coming out so
the next thing we really want to do is
we want to go ahead and load the data up
and just put a label in there loading
data
just just so you know what we're doing
i'm going to put in the loading data
down here
make sure it's well labeled
and we'll create a definition for this
and this is all part of your
pre-processing
at this point you could replace this
with all kinds of different things
depending on what you're working on
and if you once you download you can go
download this data set uh send a note to
the simply learn team here in youtube
and they'll be happy to direct you in
the right direction and make sure you
get this path here
so you have the right whatever wherever
you saved it a lot of times i'll just
abbreviate the path or put it as a sub
thing and just get rid of the directory
but again double check your paths we're
going to separate this into a segment
for training
and a segment for testing and that's
actually how it is in the folder let me
just show you what that looks like
so when i have my lengthy path here
where i keep all my programming simply
learn this particular setup we're
working on image classification
and image classification
clearly you probably wouldn't have that
lengthy of a list
and when we go in here
you'll see sequence train sequence test
they've already split this up this is
what we're going to train the data in
and again you can see buildings 4th
glacier mountain c street
and if we double click let's go under
forest you can see all these different
forest images and there's a lot of
variety here i mean we have winter time
we have summer time
so it's kind of interesting
you know here's like a fallen tree
versus
a road going down the middle
that's really hard to train and if you
look at the buildings
a lot of these buildings you're looking
up a skyscraper we're looking down the
setup
here's some trees with one i want to
highlight this one it has trees in it
let me just open that up so you can see
it a little closer
the reason i want to highlight this is i
want you to think about this
we have trees growing is this the city
or a forest
so this kind of imagery makes it really
hard for a classifier and if you start
looking at these you'll see a lot of
these images do have trees and other
things in the foreground
weird angles really a hard thing for a
computer to
sort out and figure out whether it's
going to be a forest or a city
and so in our loading of data
one we have to have the path the
directory
we're going to come in here we have our
images and our labels
so we're going to load the images in one
section the labels in another
and if you look through here it just
goes through the different folders
in fact let me do this let me
there we go
uh as we look at this we're just going
to loop through the three six different
folders that have the different
landscapes and then we're going to go
through and pull each file out
and each label
so we set the label we set the folder
for file and list
here's our image path
join the paths this is all kind of not
general stuff
so i'm kind of skipping through it
really quick
and here's our image setup if you
remember we're talking about the images
we have our cv2 reader so it reads the
image in
it's going to go ahead and take the
image and convert it to
from
blue green red to red green green blue
this is a cv2 thing
almost all the time it imports it and
instead of importing it as a standard
that's used just about everywhere it
imports it with the bgr versus rgb
rgb is pretty much a standard in here
you have to remember that with cv2
and then we're going to go ahead and
resize it this is the important part
right here we've said it we've decided
what the size is and we want to make
sure all the images have the same size
on them
and then we just take our images and
we're just going to pin the image pin
the label
and then the images it's going to turn
into a numpy array this just makes it
easier to process and manipulate
and then the labels is also a numpy
array and then we just return the output
append images and labels and we return
the output down here
so we've loaded these all into memory uh
we haven't talked too much
there'd be a different setup in there
because there is ways to feed the files
directly into your cross model
but we want to go ahead and just load
them all because really
for today's processing and what our
computers can handle that's not a big
deal
and then we go ahead and set the train
images train labels test images test
labels and that's going to be returned
in our output append and you can see
here we did
images and labels set up in there and it
just loads them in there so we'll have
these four different categories let me
just go ahead and run that
so now we've gone ahead and loaded
everything on there
and then if you remember from before uh
we imported and just go back up there
shuffle here we go here's our sk learn
utilities import shuffle
and so we want to take these labels and
shuffle them around a little bit
just mix them up so it's not having the
same if you run the same process over
and over uh then you might run into some
problems on there
and just real quick let's go ahead and
do uh
um a plot so we can just you know we've
looked at them as far as from outside of
our code we pulled up the files and i
showed you
what that was going on we can go ahead
and just display them here too
and i tell you when you're working with
different people
this should be highlighted right here um
this thing is like when i'm working on
code and i'm looking at this data and
i'm trying to figure out what i'm doing
i skip this process
the second i get into a meeting and i'm
showing what's going on to other people
i skip everything we just did
so
and go right to here where we want to go
ahead and display
some images and take a look at it
and in this display
i've taken them and i've resized the
images to 20 by 20.
that's pretty small
so we're going to lose just a massive
amount of detail and you can see here
these nice pixelated images
i might even just stick with the folder
showing them what images were processing
uh
again this is
yeah be a little careful this
maybe resizing it was a bad idea
in fact let me try without resizing it
and see what happens oops so i took out
the image size and then we put this
straight in here
one of the things again this is um
but the d there we go one of the things
again that we want to know
whenever we're working on these things
is the cv2
there are so many different
image classification setups it's really
a powerful package when you're doing
images
but you do need to switch it around so
that it works with the pie plot and so
make sure you take your numpy array and
change it to a
u integer 8 format because it comes in
as a float
otherwise you'll get some weird images
down there
and so this is just basically we've
split up our we've created a plot
we went ahead and did the plot 20 by 20
um or
the plot figure size is 20 by 20
and then we're doing 25 so a 5x5 subplot
nothing really going on here too
exciting but you can see here where we
get the images
and
really when you're showing people what's
going on this is what they want to see
so you skip over all the code and you
have your meeting you say okay here's
our images of the building
don't get caught up in how much work you
do get caught up in what they want to
see so if you want to work in data
science that's really important to know
and this is where we're going to start
having fun
here's our model this is where it gets
exciting
when you're digging into these models
and you have here
let me get
there we go
when you have here if you look here
here's our convolutional neural network
2d
and
2d is an image you have two different
dimensions x y and even though there's
three colors it's still considered 2d
if you're running a video you'd be
convolutional neural network 3d if
you're doing a series going across
a time series it might be 1d
and on these you need to go ahead and
have your convolutional neural network
if you look here there's a lot of really
cool settings going on
to dig into um we have our input shape
so everything's been set to 150x150
and it has of course three different
color schemes in it that's important to
notice
activation
default is relu this is
small amounts of data being
processed on a bunch of little
neural networks
and right here is the 32 that's how many
of these convolutional null networks are
being strung up on here
and then the three by three
uh when it's doing its steps it's
actually looking at uh a little three by
three square on each image
and so that's what's going on here and
with convolutional neural networks the
window floats across
and adds up all these numbers going
across on this data and then eventually
it comes up with 30 in this case 32
different
feature options that it's looking for
and of course you can change that 32 you
can change the three by three so you
might have a larger setup you know if
you're going across 150
by 150 that's a lot of steps so we might
run this as 15 by 15. uh there's all
kinds of different things you can do
here
we're just putting this together again
that would be something you would play
with to find out which ones are going to
work better on this setup
and there's a lot of play involved
that's really where it becomes an art
form is guessing at what that's going to
be
the second part i mentioned earlier and
i can only begin to highlight this
when you get to these dense layers
one is the activation is a relu they use
a relu and a soft max here
it's a whole
whole setup just explaining why these
are different
and how they're different because
there's also an exponential there's a
tangent in fact
there's just a ton of these and you can
build your own custom activations
depending on what you're doing
a lot of different things go into these
activations
uh there are two or three major thoughts
on these activations and
rayleigh and softmax are well relu
you're really looking at just the number
you're adding all the numbers together
and you're looking at euclidean geometry
ax plus b
x 2 plus c x 3
plus a bias
with softmax this belongs to the party
of
it's activated or it's not except it's
they call it soft max because when you
get the the to zero instead of it just
being zero
uh it's actually slightly
a little bit less than zero so that when
it trains it doesn't get lost
um there's a whole series of these
activations
another activation is the tangent
where it just drops off and you have
like a very narrow area where you have
from minus one to one or exponential
which is zero to one
so there's a lot of different ways to do
the activation
again we can do that would be a whole
separate lesson on here
we're looking at the convolutional
neural network um and we're doing the
two pools
this is so common you'll see two two
convolutional neural networks stacked on
top of each other each with its own max
pool underneath let's go ahead and run
that so we built our model there and
then we need to go ahead and
compile the model so let's go ahead and
do that
uh we're going to use the atom
optimizer the bigger the data the atom
fits better on there there's some other
optimizer but i think atom's a default
i don't really play with the optimizer
too much that's like the
if once you get a model that works
really good you might try some different
optimizers but atoms usually the most
and then we're looking at loss
pretty standard we want to minimize our
lot we want to
maximize the loss of error
and then we're going to look at accuracy
um everybody likes the accuracy i'm
going to tell you right now
i
i start talking to people and i'm like
okay what's what's the loss on this and
that and as a data science yeah i want
to know how the lot what what's going on
with that and we'll show you why in a
minute
but everybody wants to see accuracy we
want to know how accurate this is
and then we're going to run the fit and
i wanted to do this just so i can show
you
even though
we're in a python
setup in here where jupyter notebook is
using only a single processor
i'm going to bring over my little cpu
tool
this is eight cores on 16 dedicated
threats so it shows up as 16 processors
and actually i got to run this and then
move it over
so we're going to run this
and hopefully it doesn't destroy my mic
and as it comes in you can see it's
starting to do go through the epics and
we said i set it for five epics
and then this is really nice because
cross uses all the different uh threads
available
so it does a really good job of doing
that
uh this is going to take a while if you
look at here it's uh
eta
two minutes and 25 seconds 24 seconds so
this is roughly two and a half minutes
per epic
and we're doing five epics so this is
going to be done in roughly 15 minutes
i don't know about you but i don't think
you want to sit here for 15 minutes
watching the green bars go across so
we'll go ahead and let that run
and
there we go uh there was our 15 minutes
it's actually less than that
uh because i did when i went in here
realized that uh
uh where was it
here we go here's our model compile
here's our model flip fit
and here's our epics so i did four epics
so a little bit better a little more
like 10 to 11 minutes instead of
doing the full
15. and
when we look at this here's our model we
did we talked about the compiler uh
here's our history we're going to
history equals the model fit
we'll go into that in just a minute
and what we're looking at is we have our
epics
here's our validation split
so as we train it
we're weighing the accuracy versus
you kind of pull some data off to the
side
while you're training it
and the reason we do that is that
you don't want to overfit
and i'll we'll look at that chart in
just a minute
here's batch size
this is just how many images you're
sending through at a time
the larger the batch it actually
increases the processing speed um and
there's reasons to go up or down on the
batch size because of the uh the the
smaller the batch
there's a certain point where
you get too large of a batch and it's
trying to fit everything at once
so i yeah 128 is kind of big
depends on the computer you're on what
it can handle
and then of course we have our train
images
and our train labels going in telling it
what we're going to train on
and then we look at our four epics here
here's our accuracy we want the accuracy
to go up
and we get all the way up to
0.83 or 83 percent now this is actual
percentage based pretty much
and we can see over here our loss we
want our loss to go down really
fluctuates 55
seven 1.2.77 point four eight
uh so we have a lot of things going on
there
let's go ahead and graph those
turn that up
and our
team in the back did a wonderful job of
putting together um this basic plot set
up
um here's our subplot coming in we're
going to be looking at um
uh from the history we're going to send
it the accuracy and the value accuracy
labels are set up on there
and we're going to also look at loss and
value loss
so you can see what this looks like
what's really interesting about
this setup and let me just go ahead and
show you because
without actually seeing the plots it
doesn't make a whole lot of sense
it's just basic plotting of
of the data using the pi plot library
and i want you to look at this this is
really interesting
when i ran this the first time i had
very different results
um and they vary greatly and you can see
here our accuracy continues to climb
um
and there's a crossover here
put it in here
right here's our crossover
and i point that out because as we get
to the right of that crossover where our
accuracy
and we're like oh yeah i got point eight
percent
we're starting to get an overfit here
that's what this this switch over means
um
as our value uh as a training set versus
the value
accuracy stays the same and so that this
is the one we're actually really want to
be aware of and where it crosses
is kind of where you want to stop at
and we can see that also with the train
loss versus the value loss right here we
did one epic and look how it just
flatlines right there with our loss
so really
one epic is
probably enough
and you're gonna say wow okay point
eight percent um certainly if i was
working with the shareholders um
telling them that it has an 80 accuracy
isn't quite true and and we'll look at
that a little deeper it really comes out
here that the accuracy of our actual
values is closer to 0.41 right here
even after running it this number of
times
and so you really want to stop right
here at that crossover
one epic would have been enough
so the date is a little overfitted on
this when we do four epics
and uh whoops there we are
okay
my drawing won't go away um let's see if
i can get there we go
um for some reason i've killed my
drawing ability and my recorder
all right took a couple extra clicks
uh so let's go ahead and take a look at
our actual test loss
so you see where it crosses over that's
where i'm looking at
that's where we start overfitting the
model
and this is where
if we were going to go back and
continually upgrade the model
we would start taking a look at the
images and start rotating them
we might start playing with the
convolutional neural network instead of
doing the three by three window
we might expand that or you know find
different things that might make a big
difference as far as the way it
processes these things
so let's go ahead and take a look at our
our test loss now remember we had our
training data
now we're going to look at our test
images and our test labels
for our test loss here and this is just
model evaluate just like we did fit up
here
where was it
one more
model fit with our training data going
in now we're going to evaluate it on the
and this data has not been touched yet
so
this model's never seen this data this
is on
completely new information as far as the
model is concerned of course we already
know what it is from the labels we have
and this is what i was talking about
here's the actual accuracy right here
point four eight
uh or four eight four seven
so this 49 of the time
guesses what the image is
uh and
i mean really that's the bottom dollar
uh does this work for what you're
needing does 49 work do we need to
upgrade the model more
um
in some cases this might be uh
oh what was i doing i was working on
stock evaluations
and
we were looking at what stocks were the
top performers
well if i get that 50 correct on top
performers
i'm good with that
that's actually pretty good for stock
evaluation
in fact the number i had for stock was
more like
30 something percent as far as being a
top performer stock
much harder to predict um but at that
point you're like well you'll make money
off of that so again this number right
here depends a lot on the domain you're
working on
and then we want to go ahead and bring
this home a little bit more uh as far as
looking at the different setup in here
and one of the
from sk learn if you remember actually
let's go back to the top
uh we had the classification report and
this came in from our sklearn or scikit
setup
and that's right here you can see it
right here on the
see there we go
classification report right here sklearn
metrics import classification report
this we're going to look at next
a lot of this stuff
depends on who you're working with
so when we start looking at
precision
you know this is like for each value i
can't remember what one one one was
probably mountains so if 44
is not good enough if you if you're
doing like
um you're in the medical department and
you're doing cancer is it is this
cancerous or not and i'm only 44
accurate
not a good deal
you know i would not go with that um
so it depends on what you're working
with on the different labels and what
they're used for facebook yeah you know
44 i'm guessing the right person i hope
it does a little bit better than that um
but here's our main accuracy this is
what almost everybody looks at they say
oh 48 that's what's important
um again it depends on what domain
you're in and what you're working with
and now we're going to do the same model
oops somehow i got my there it goes i
thought i was going to get stuck down
there again
this time we're going to be using the
vgg16
and remember this one is
all those layers
going into it so it's basically a bunch
of convolutional neural networks getting
smaller and smaller on here
and so we need to go ahead and
import all our different stuff from
cross we're importing the main one is
the v
g 16 set up on there let me just aim
that there we go
there's kind of a pre-processing images
applications pre-process input this is
all part of the vg g16 setup on there
and once we have all those we need to go
ahead
and create our model
and we're just going to create a vgg16
model in here
inputs model inputs outputs model inputs
i'm not going to spend as much time as
they did on the other one uh we're going
to go through it really quickly
one of the first things i would do
is if you remember in cross you can
create
treat a model like you would a layer
and so at this point i would probably
add a lot of dense layers on after the
vgg-16 model and create a new model with
all those things in there
and we'll go ahead and run this
because here's our model coming in and
our setup
and it'll take it just a moment to
compile that what's funny about this is
i'm waiting for it to download the
package since i pre-ran this
it takes it a couple minutes to download
the vgg16 model into here
and so we want to go ahead and train
features for the model we're going to
predict that we're going to predict the
train images and we're going to test
features on the predict test images on
here
and then i told you it's going to create
another model too and the people in the
back did not disappoint me they went
ahead and did just that
and this is really an important part um
this is worth stopping for i told you i
was going to go through this really
quick
so here's our uh
we we have our model 2
coming in and we've created a model up
here with the vgg16 model equals model
inputs model inputs and so we have our
vgg16
this has already been pre-programmed
and then we come down here i want you to
notice on this
right here
layer model two layers minus four to one
x layer x
we're basically taking this model and
we're adding stuff on to it
and so
we've taken we've just basically
duplicated this model we could have done
the same thing
by using
model up here as a layer
we could have the input go to this model
and then have that go down here so we've
added on
this whole setup
this whole block of code from 13 to 17
has been added on to our vgg16 model
and we have a new model uh with the
layer input and x down here
let's go ahead and run that and compile
it
and that was a lot to go through right
there when you're building these models
this is the part that gets so
complicated
that you get stuck playing in and yet
it's so fun
it's like a puzzle how can i loop these
models together
and in this case you can see right here
that the layers
we're just copying layers over and
adding each layer in
this is one way to build a new model
and we'll go ahead and run that
like i said the other way is you can
actually use the model as a layer i've
had a little trouble playing with it
sometimes when you're using the straight
model over
you run into issues
it seems like it's going to work and
then you mess up on the input and the
output layers there's all kinds of
things that come up
let's go ahead and do the new model
we're going to compile it again here's
our metrics accuracy sparse categorical
loss
pretty straightforward just like we did
before you got to compile the model
and just like before we're going to take
our create a history
the history is going to be
a new model fit train 128
and just like before if you remember
when we started running this stuff we're
going to have to go ahead and it's going
to light up our setup on here and this
is going to take a little bit to get us
all set up it's not going to just happen
in a couple minutes so let me go ahead
and pause the video and run it and then
we'll talk about what happened
okay now when i ran that these actually
took about six minutes each
so it's a good thing i put it on hold we
did four epics i actually had to stop it
says at 10 and switch it to forks i
didn't want to wait an hour
and you can see here our accuracy
and our loss numbers going down
and just at a glance
it actually performed if you look at the
accuracy
0.2658
so our accuracy is going down or you
know 26 percent um 34
35
and you can see here at some point it
just kind of kicks the bucket again this
is overfitting
that's always an issue when you're
running on
programming these different neural
networks
and then we're going to go ahead and
plot the accuracy
history we built that nice little
subroutine up above so we might as well
use it
and you can see it right here
there's that crossover again
and
if you look at this look how the how the
um uh the red shifts up how the uh
our loss functions and everything
crosses over we're over fitting after
one epic um we're clearly
not helping the problem or doing better
we're just going to it's just going to
baseline this one actually shows with
the training versus the loss
value loss maybe second epic so on here
we're now talking more between the first
and the second epic and that also shows
kind of here so
somewhere in here it starts overfitting
and right about now you should be saying
uh oh uh something went wrong there i
thought that
um
we went up here and ran this look at
this we have the accuracy up here it's
hitting that 48 percent
and we're down here um
you look at the score down here that
looks closer to
20 percent
not nearly
anywhere in the ballpark of what we're
looking for
and we'll go ahead and run it through
the
the actual test features here and there
it is
we actually run this on the unseen data
and everything
0.18 or 18
um i don't know about you but i wouldn't
want you know at 18 this did a lot worse
than the other one
i thought this is supposed to be the
supermodel the
model that beats all models uh vgg16
that won the
awards and everything
well the reason is is that
one we're not
pre-processing the data so it needs to
be more there needs to be more
um as far as like rotating the data at
you know 45 degree angle taking partials
of it so you can create a lot more data
to go through here
and that would actually greatly change
the outcome on here and then we went up
here we only added a couple dense layers
uh we added a couple convolutional
neural networks
this huge pre-trained setup is looking
for a lot more information coming in
as far as how it's going to train
and so
uh this is one of those things where i
thought it would have done better and i
had to go back and research it and look
at it and say why didn't this work why
am i getting only
18 here instead of 44 or better
and that would be wise it doesn't have
enough training data coming in
uh and again you can make your own
training data so it's not that we have a
shortage of data it's that that some of
that has to be switched around and moved
around a little bit
and this is interesting right here too
if you look at the precision
we're getting it on number two and yet
we had zero on everything else
so for some reason it's not seeing
the different variables in here so it'd
be something else to look in and try to
track down
and that probably has to do with the
input but you can see right here we have
a really good solid 0.48 up here and
that's where i'd really go with is
starting with this model and then we
look at this model and find out why are
these numbers not coming up better is it
the data coming in
where's the setup on there
and that is the art of data science
right there is finding out which models
work better and why and that brings us
to the end of this video tutorial on
keras and tensorflow full course by
simply loan if you have any queries
please feel free to put them in the
comments section of the video thank you
for watching
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
you